Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wie ist dein Handicap?
Ich spiele kein Golf, aber ich will auch nicht Präsident werden.
So, es ist Juni und wir offenbaren, wir haben beide noch nie Golf gespielt.
Nein.
Wir haben also kein Handicap. Ich weiß nicht mal, was das ist.
Na, das Handicap meint, wie viele Schläge du brauchst, um die gesamten 18 Loch hinter dich zu bringen. Das heißt, es gibt eine gewisse Zahl von Schlägen, die dann kommst du bis auf ein Handicap von Null. Das ist jetzt quasi dann, dass man sagt, es sind, ich weiß nicht.
Home Run. Ist das dann der Home Run?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, man braucht ja schon, also man kommt ja nicht mit einem Schlag von Loch zu Loch. Das kann ja nicht gehen.
Also es gibt einen standardisierten, weil ich dachte, der Handicap ist so eine Ansage allgemein über verschiedene Spielflächen.
Nein, es gibt Leute, die durchaus auch semi-professionell sind oder die sehr engagiert sind, die dann ein Handicap haben können von 5 oder ich glaube Trump behauptet er hat 6 oder ich glaube Biden sagte dann auch so was wie 6 oder 8. Es gibt viele, die dann sich damit begnügen, ein Handicap von 25 zu haben. Das heißt, die brauchen 25 mehr Schläge als jetzt so ein Tiger Woods oder so was. Aber auch die sind dann nicht bei Null, die sind bei 1, 2, 3, darum geht es. Aber mehr kann ich dir schon zu Golf gar nicht sagen. Wir können uns also schnell um Kopf und Kragen reden. Wir können auch andere um Kopf und Kragen reden lassen. Genau, wir haben ja genug Material da. Wir sind heute Morgen früh aufgestanden, um die Debatte noch schnell zu sehen. Du hast dankenswerterweise Clips geschnitten.
Ich kann dir genau sagen, wie es war. Ich lag im Keller, denn ich habe aus Temperaturgründen einfach der Bequemlichkeitshalber im Keller geschlafen. Aus meiner ersten Corona-Woche hinter mir. Ich war so noch leicht, man hört es mich näselnd. Dann habe ich die Debatte im Keller geguckt. Dann bin ich hoch zu meinen Kindern, die von mir das wollen, was Kinder so wollen. Eine Brotbüchse und Kram und Sonnencreme und so. Ich dachte, endlich wieder normale Leute. Ich habe schon in der Stunde, die ich im Keller mit Trump und Biden verbracht habe, vergessen, was es mit der Welt eigentlich auf sich hat. Was eigentlich wichtig ist, wie man eigentlich miteinander spricht.
Es ist ein solch desaströses Duell gewesen, dass ich entsetzt darüber war, was ich heute morgen sehen musste. Ich habe dann sogar gedacht, ich schaue jetzt noch mal kurz in das alte Duell rein, also dass sie beim ersten Mal aufgeführt haben.
Also noch junge Männer waren.
Und selbst da war ja Biden schon nicht der allerfitteste. Aber der Vergleich jetzt noch einmal ist enorm und zeigt einfach, dass man es hier mit einem sehr gebrechlichen Mann zu tun hat, der nicht mehr in der Lage ist, klug zu argumentieren, der nicht mehr in der Lage ist, den Präsidenten zu performen. Und um Performance geht es. Und wir sehen einen Trump, der sich gar nicht viel Mühe macht, weil das eigentlich ein Selbstläufer zu sein scheint. Trump beantwortet ja eigentlich jede Frage, die man ihm stellt, damit dass er sagt, es sind zu viele Migranten. Biden hat die alle reingelassen. Er ist der schlimmste Präsident aller Zeiten. Das ist ja seine Standard-Aussage, die ja leicht variiert, dann über 90 Minuten.
Genau, wir hören jetzt rein und hören dann, Bidens Antwort ist, nein, du bist der Schlechteste aller Zeiten. Es nimmt sich da nicht viel, es war ein bisschen erschreckend. Also wir hören uns das an, denn der Gruselfaktor, wir haben es jetzt gesehen, wir sehen es auch hier auf dem Bildschirm, wir müssen es ein bisschen dimmen. Also es zu sehen, wenn man es sieht, glaube ich, ist allen klar, der Drops ist gelutscht, das wird nichts. Also mit Biden ist kein Start mehr zu machen. Mit Trump natürlich auch nicht. Aber die Hoffnung, die man überhaupt noch hatte, wenn man das Duell geschaut hat, war ja, dass Biden vielleicht doch ein bisschen lebenshafter noch ist, als man dachte. Was auch noch mal zu dem Hinweis führt, denn ab heute werden ja viele diese Gespräche führen. Es ist nicht das Alter, sondern es ist die Gebrechlichkeit bei beiden. Man muss da ganz scharf und deutlich sein, denn wir wollen hier kein Ageism machen oder sowas, sondern Biden ist einfach in einem Zustand nur drei Jahre älter als Trump, aber gefühlt 30 Jahre. Also da liegen wirklich Welten dazwischen. Und da bitte detailliert und genau sein. Es ist die Gebrechlichkeit, denn lasst es euch sagen, von demjenigen, der ganz viel über das Alter diskutiert mit Leuten, bei Gebrechlichkeit gibt es kaum Widerworte. Wenn du mit Alter anfängst, stehen die Omas Publikum auf und sagen, sie haben noch nicht so viel Hass auf der Bühne gesehen. Also da, Vorsicht. Okay, wir schauen uns ein paar Clips an. Wir beginnen natürlich mit Eingangsstatements, allein um mal zu hören, inhaltlich, okay, das ist schon ganz okay, aber die Performance. Dass er von den Sehgewohnheiten abweicht und wir einen etwas lebendigeren kriegen. Haben wir nicht.
Alles monoton. Das geht die ganze Debatte über so durch. Es gibt keine Höhen und Tiefen.
Kein Leben. Und seit Donald Dragon wissen wir, was zählt. Ja. Es ist der Auftritt, die Performance.
Na ja und wenn das überhaupt jemand weiß, dann die Amerikaner.
Dann die, genau. Von Trump zum Staat bekommen wir das, was unsere Sehgewohnheiten erwarten.
Wir wurden mit Covid verletzt.
Erstaunlich fand ich, dass relativ zügig deutlich wurde, so inhaltlich können die sich jetzt widersprechen und liegen auf unterschiedlichen Sphären, aber der eine wird dem anderen nicht in den fundamentalen Eckdaten der Politik ausreden, hier doch anders zu sein, sondern nein, nein, wir wollen wirklich gegen die Ausländer. Und ja, ja, die Reichen sind wirklich zu reich. Nein, nein, die Reichen sind wirklich zu arm und so, ne? Also die sind da ganz deutlich, man weiß genau, was man kriegt. Hier zum Beispiel, wir hören jetzt, wie Biden Trump vorwirft, er hätte ja mit zur Misere beigetragen, indem er die größten Tax-Cuts aller Zeiten gemacht hat, die größten Steuerleichterungen aller Zeiten. Und Trump nimmt es nicht als Vorwurf an, sondern lächelnd und nickt dabei in die Kamera. Also die Botschaften ans Publikum sind klar. Nope. Ja, Trump steht daneben, ja den letzten Punkt, den rede ich gleich wieder aus, aber das mit den Tax-Cuts, genau, das ist meine Werbebotschaft eigentlich. Danke, dass du sie mir auch noch mal den Leuten unterbringst. Trumps Covid-Performance wird hier noch mal aufgegriffen, denn die Frage ist jetzt, wo wir drei, vier Jahre nach der Corona-Pandemie liegen und wir gar nicht mehr so genau wissen, wie war das noch mal genau, gab es einen zweiten Lockdown? Wann war der eigentlich? Hatten wir die Schulen noch mal zu oder nicht? Also die größten Aufreger ihrer Zeit sind heute so, ja keine Ahnung. In der Hinsicht hat man Trump gesagt, mach Vorwärtsverteidigung, da bist du eh gut. Hau denen allen das um die Ohren. Lass die gar nicht erst Themen aufgreifen, die sie dir angeblich vorhalten, sondern setz sofort den Ton und so macht das auch.
Weil die Taxi-Karte die größte Wirtschaft in der Welt verweist, vor Covid-19.
Also gar nicht mehr sich jetzt entschuldigen, noch mal gucken, man hätte vielleicht dies und das tun können. Nein, er bar darauf, dass seine Präsidentschaft die größte aller Zeiten war.
Genau, Covid ist allenfalls eine Zäsur, die halt wie über die Welt hereingebrochen ist, so während die ganze Inflation allein Biden schuld ist. Das hat sonst die Welt nicht betroffen. Covid ist halt einfach so eine Zäsur und ansonsten war das die allerbeste Präsidentschaft aller Zeiten.
Wir wollten etwas haben, das niemand anderes hatte.
Ja, ich hab dir das beste Land aller Zeiten überlassen. Also ich weiß noch, wie das hier in Deutschland reportiert wurde. Als Corona kam und dann in Amerika diese Woche schon wieder zwei Millionen mehr Arbeitslose. Und die nächste Woche schon wieder zwei Millionen mehr Arbeitslose. Am Ende waren 30 Millionen Leute arbeitslos. Alles war durcheinander und das ist für ihn... Nö, das war das beste Land aller Zeiten.
Viele, viele Corona-Toten.
Genau, Biden hätte es einfach nur in Ruhe lassen sollen.
So, jetzt können wir natürlich überlegen, wie kann man dem etwas entgegensetzen? Argumentativ ist das nicht machbar, weil Trump sich überhaupt nicht darauf einlässt. Also das ist so, wenn du jetzt was zu AI erklärst und ich sage daraufhin, Stefan ist der schlechteste Podcaster der Welt und alle wissen es zu Hause. Und damit wissen wir, dass wir nicht miteinander darüber reden können. Und wie geht man jetzt damit um? Die einzige Möglichkeit ist ja jetzt, auch nur Performance zu machen und zu sagen, ich, der Präsident Biden, habe die größte, die großartigste Leistung vollbracht. Ich habe dafür gesorgt, dass und dann muss man die Dinge nicht so, wie er das macht, so ganz schulbuchhaft aufzählen. Er nennt ja immer drei Punkte. Es ist dann immer verwunderlich, dass er wirklich alle drei auch noch nennen kann.
Aber gelingt nicht immer.
Gelingt nicht immer, ja. Aber er muss dann eigentlich den Präsidenten spielen und muss zeigen, dass er derjenige ist, der es noch besser performt. Es geht bei diesen Duellen ja, wie wir hier schon an diesen winzigen Clips sehen, überhaupt nicht um inhaltliche Auseinandersetzung. Das zeigt sich besonders, wenn wir jetzt noch die Fragen einblenden würden. Also Trump wird irgendwas gefragt, ob er mit Putin verhandeln würde. Und Trump kommt erst noch mal zwei Minuten auf die Textcats zu sprechen.
Ich hab dazu auch viele Clips, die aber aus Zeitgründen nicht gucken. Trump bekommt eine Frage, zum Beispiel, ich kann ja mal lesen, was ich so rauskomme, also Klimakrise. Oder sehr viele Menschen bezahlen noch mehr Geld für Kinderbetreuung als fürs Wohnen. Und Trump beantwortet keine Einzelne dieser Fragen, sondern er sagt immer, ich will noch mal drauf zurückkommen, was Biden eben sagte. Weil diese Stimmung lag ja immer noch in der Luft. Diese Frage dazwischen sagt halt substantiv, irgendeinmäßig so große Dramen, aber nicht groß emotional verfangen. Und dann werden solche gigantischen Themen einfach ausgeblendet. Und das, was du jetzt meintest, ja, also Bidens Aufgabe ist hier wirklich tricky. Ich referiere mal ein bisschen, was ich so bei Hacks on Tap, also da sind ja David Axelrod, also der große Wahlkampfleiter und Election-Magier David Axelrod und ihm gegenüber Mike Murphy, der also ganz viele republikanische Präsidenten betreute. Und jetzt eben durch Trump da so ein bisschen in das Gegenlager wechseln. Und die meinten für Biden ist die größte Herausforderung gewesen, den Leuten zu sagen, es läuft viel besser, als es laufen könnte. Also wir haben Wirtschaftswachstum von vier Prozent oder so in Amerika. Wir haben diesen Inflation Reduction Act, der sehr viel Industrie nach Amerika holt. Und so also das betonen, wie man die Welt outperformt, während man gleichzeitig ganz viel Verständnis dafür zeigt, dass es für die Leute so teuer ist wie noch nie und sie sich für die großen Metathemen eigentlich nicht interessieren. Und diese Herausforderung, das auf diese, sagen wir mal 30 Sekunden, weil wir gucken hier Clips, so wie die ganze Welt diese Debatte guckt. Das sind TikTok-Schnipsel, das sind irgendwelche YouTube-Videos, Twitter-kleine Dinger, die die nächsten Wochen auftauchen. Niemand guckt die ganze Debatte am Stück. Also ja klar, es gucken so ein paar Millionen zu, aber das links Ohr, rechtes Ohr, bleiben tut das, was dann im Kondensat mündet. Und diese Botschaft zu vermitteln, wäre sowieso schon eine krasse Herausforderung gewesen. Also auf der einen Seite dieses, ich hab's schon ganz schön gut gemacht und ich weiß, für euch ist es trotzdem blöd, aber es war eine große Krise und so weiter. Und eigentlich kaum zu machen.
Naja, er müsste zeigen, dass er ja einen Masterplan hat. Ich bin nicht so begeistert von diesem Plan. Wir werden ja heute noch ein bisschen über China vielleicht sprechen und die E-Mobilität, aber im Ganzen ist ja dieser Inflation-Reduction-Act ein protektionistischer Akt, der die heimische Industrie stärken will, allerdings auch unter der Prämisse, dass man sie in Teilen abschwächt, um dann aber so ein großes Problem, oder was man als Problem ansieht, zu lösen, nämlich China. Man will China schwächen, muss sich dadurch aber möglicherweise auch ein bisschen selbst schwächen. Das müsste er verkaufen können. Und ja, das geht nur über Umwege. Er müsste also eine sehr direkte Ansprache finden. Ich glaube allerdings, dass es fast nicht möglich ist mehr, wenn du jemanden gegenüberstehen hast wie Trump, der einfach auf keine einzige Frage mehr eingeht, der sich einfach mit diesen Dingen nicht mehr auseinandersetzt und im Zweifelsfall immer antwortet, Biden hat Millionen Menschen hierhin geholt, die kommen alle über die Grenzen, die kommen aus Nervenheilanstalten und Gefängnissen hier rüber und machen sich hier breit und nirgends ist es mehr sicher. Wenn man das fortwährend sagt, ist also mit Trump keine Debatte mehr möglich. Also kann er nur noch eine Debatte entweder mit den Moderatoren führen oder mit den Zuschauern direkt zu Hause. Dafür müsste man aber in der Lage sein, die Zuschauer direkt anzusprechen und das tut Biden gar nicht mehr. Biden redet das so für sich, zeigt noch vielleicht das Interesse, seinen Demokraten unter Beweis zu stellen, dass er doch noch einigermaßen formulieren kann. Das ist aber nicht gelungen. Also ich habe noch dann heute 15 Minuten CNN so eine Runde mir angesehen, in der nur Leute saßen, die Biden toll finden und die Demokraten sich alles für die Demokraten wünschen würden. Und da war eine solche Enttäuschung. Ja, fast Tränen in den Augen hatten die Leute, die da gesprochen haben, dass man dachte, okay, diese Geschichte ist für Biden sehr schlecht ausgegangen.
Sehr schlecht ausgegangen. Wir können ja mal, dieses Thema wurde von Precht, als er jetzt bei Junge naiv war, sehr deutlich markiert, ohne dass der Chat oder Tilo oder irgendwer darauf eingestiegen ist. Im Buch wurde es auch nicht so deutlich, aber Precht hat es an einem Wort festgemacht, Subkutan. Was bedeutet das? Subkutan, habe ich jetzt per Plexity gefragt, ist ein Fachbegriff aus der Medizin oder so. Es geht um eine anatomische Ortsangabe. Steht hier. Es ist unter der Haut. Es ist nicht sichtbar, aber es prägt den Gesundheitszustand. Jetzt kann man wegen Symptom zum Arzt gehen und dann sagt er, mach mal hier, Creme da und so weiter, vielleicht Make-up. Aber nein, man müsste eigentlich an die Subkutan-Ursachen eines Problems.
Und das Problem, was Precht hier schildert, ist ja auf die Frage, woher kommt der Rechtsdruck. Es gibt Subkutan, auch über die AfD-Wählerschaft hinaus, das Gefühl, dass man nicht mehr als Deutschland oder Europa oder der Westen wichtig ist.
Genau, der Bedeutungsverlust der eigenen Nationen und Europas.
Make America Great Again ist exakt das Versprechen, dass dies aufgreift und sagt, mit uns aber nicht, wir werden schon dafür sorgen. Also diese Subkutan-Ursachen deshalb, weil es ja nicht so ist, dass wenn ich jetzt auf der Straße einen AfD-Wähler fragen würde, warum hast du die gewählt, dann sagt er, dann sagt er nicht, ja sehen Sie, die geopolitische Situation ist ja folgende, natürlich antwortet er das nicht, sondern er wird höchstens auf jemanden zeigen, da sind wieder Ausländer, aber er kann nicht in die höhere Analyse hineingehen, ist aber ganz in dieser Weltanschauung eigentlich drin, ohne dass er es auf den Punkt bringen kann. Und Trump hat das bis heute, dieses Talent genau, diese Subquotane aufzugreifen und auf den Punkt zu bringen, der führt ja auch überhaupt gar nichts geopolitisch aus, außer zu sagen, make America great again und mir hätte es diesen Ukraine-Krieg nie gegeben.
Genau, die Frage ist, wer von den beiden kann die Timmung gut treffen, bei der sich Menschen, die ansonsten nicht in der Lage sind, inhaltlich über ihr Schicksal sich zu äußern, sich verstanden fühlen? So und jetzt hören wir mal diesen Clip, wie gut das Trump gelingt.
Throughout the entire world, we're no longer respected as a country. They don't respect our leadership. They don't respect the United States anymore. We're like a third world nation between weaponization of his election, trying to go after his political opponent. All of the things he's done, we've become like a third world nation. And it's a shame. The damage he's done to our country, and I'd love to ask him and will, why he allowed millions of people to come in here from prisons, jails and mental institutions, to come into our country and destroy our country.
So inhaltlich ist das nicht der Rede wert. Das ist völlig klar. Aber auf dieser, wir müssen hier ins Subkutane unter der Haut, die in diesen Nerv treffen. Wir werden nicht mehr respektiert. Wir sind ein dritte Weltland. Und jetzt macht er auch noch die Grenzen auf und schickt die ganzen Verbrecher hier rein. Trump hat später noch eine Erklärung dafür. Das sollen mal seine Wähler sein, deswegen macht er das. Also die Verschwörungstheorien werden gestrickt. Aber mittendrin in diesem Clip war noch so ein sehr wirkmächtiges. Und das würde ich Ihnen auch gerne mal fragen. Stellvertretend für das Publikum, Herr Biden, warum richten Sie uns so zugrunde? So, und das sind diese Sachen, die bei uns natürlich, wir übersehen sie, wenn wir sie so in der Debatte hören. Aber es gibt Leute, die sehen das vom Fernsehen und sind da Feuer und Flamme.
Manchmal wird das ja sehr explizit. Denn du erinnerst dich, dass der CEO der deutschen Börse, Theodor Weimer, eine Rede hielt und sagte, Deutschland wird nicht mehr ernst genommen. Deutschland wird wie ein Entwicklungsland inzwischen wahrgenommen. Wirtschaftlich läuft nichts mehr und das Migrationsproblem kriegt niemand in den Griff. Also eine sehr ähnliche Rede, als die, wir verglichen jetzt mit der beiden. Und was ist die Folge? Es wird von allen Rechten und Konservativen geteilt und damit wird verbunden. Seht ihr, der Abstieg ist keine Illusion, der von der deutschen Börse sagt das auch. Wir sind am Ende. Also dieses subkutane Sprechen haben wir da von einem aus der Wirtschaft erlebt. Und das ist dann nur etwas, was man politisch aufgreifen muss. Und bei Trump geht das dann natürlich Hand in Hand. Er zeigt sich auch immer noch als Unternehmer dadurch, dass er sagt, ich habe ganz viele Leute während meiner Amtszeit gefeuert. Biden hat noch nie jemanden gefeuert.
Das ist, ich habe es leider auch ausgelagert, aber vielleicht gucken wir das später noch mal irgendwann. Trump kriegt immer wieder diesen Vorwurf, du hast unsere Tropen als Loser bezeichnet. Und dann sagt Trump, nein, das habe ich ja gar nicht. Und wenn ich einer als Loser bezeichne, dann nur dein Sohn und so was. Solche Sachen. Und kommt dann aber mit diesem Punkt, Afghanistan war so eine Schande für unser Land, ich hätte alle verantwortliche Militär gefeuert. Also Trump ist auf der inhaltlichen Ebene völlig inkonsistent und rantet gegen die Hälfte der Militärs, die jetzt gerade da im Amt sind. Also es ist völlig verrückt. Gut, wir haben ja typischerweise, wenn jetzt hier so eine Subkotane, wir treffen mal den Nerv unter der Haut-Angelegenheit stattfindet, dann sagen wir ja immer, das ist doch nur Gefühl, wir müssen doch jetzt hier mal die Sozialpolitik, die armen Leute und so weiter. Können wir ja auch aus Europa, wir haben so ein bisschen den doppelten Macron. Außenpolitisch greift er so dieses Subkotane Europas Bedeutungsverlust auf und versucht da die große europäische Verlangs- und Verteidigungsfähigkeit aufzubauen, während er im Land die Rentenpolitik und die Sozialpolitik und Reichensteuer gibt's schon mal gar nicht und so. Also da völlig so, dass wir alle sagen, ne, das geht ja gar nicht. So, also Trump hat jetzt dieses Angebot gemacht. Außenpolitisch sind wir hier ein Niemand. Niemand respektiert uns mehr. Kein Wunder, dass die alle Kriege über unsere Köpfe hinweg machen. Wir werden nicht mehr respektiert. Jetzt versucht Joe Biden, das auf linker Ebene mit, ja gut, dann mach ich mal Anmerkungen zur Sozialpolitik zu kontern. Und wir hören uns mal im Vergleich zu dem Sing-Sang eben und wie der verfängt. Versuchen wir jetzt auf uns wirken zu lassen, wie diese Anmerkungen zur Sozialpolitik hier wirken.
Ist unglaublich, das zu sehen. Das ist wahrscheinlich der Clip, der dafür sorgen wird, dass, ich will nicht dafür sagen, dafür sorgen, aber möglicherweise denken die Demokraten jetzt doch noch mal über einen anderen Kandidaten nach.
Ja, Isra Klein hat es ja in seinem Podcast aufgeschlüsselt, wie wirkmächtig die Partei bei ihrer eigenen Convention ist, dass die Vorwahlen also, das fanden ja auch für beiden statt, so ein bisschen unter dem Radar, ohne Gegenkandidat, dass man die Vorwahlen durchaus ignorieren kann. Man hätte dann natürlich das Problem, wie damals bei Clinton, als es hieß, ja, macht die Partei ja immer, aber diesmal könnte die Notwendigkeit, aber ob das für das allgemeine Publikum noch verständlich zu transportieren ist.
Es ist zu kurzfristig vielleicht, um das noch zu machen.
Vor allem die ganze Partei müsste sich auf einen Gegenkandidaten einigen, ohne dass es da noch mal Streit gibt. Ohne, dass man vorher ein Verfahren hatte, das Publikum noch mal mitentscheiden zu lassen. Und dann hast du Wittchen oder wie sie heißt und Newsome, die vielleicht dann beide wollten.
Also die einzige Möglichkeit wäre, dass Biden jetzt selbst ein Einsehen hat und sagt, ich höre jetzt auf. Aber das glaube ich nicht, dass das passiert. Das hätte er viel früher erkennen müssen. Das hätte sein Umfeld erkennen müssen. Und es geht ja hier wie gesagt nicht, weil das dann immer so ein bisschen dargestellt wird, ja jetzt wird das gesucht. Es geht nicht darum, dass man mal irgendwann den Faden verliert oder dass einem ein Wort nicht einfällt und dass man mal ein bisschen aus dem Fahrwasser gerät. Aber man kann einfach an der gesamten Performance und an dem, was gesprochen wird, erkennen, dass hier jemand alle Kraft zusammennehmen muss, um überhaupt noch durch diese Debatte durchzukommen. Und wir sehen zugleich einen Schwätzer wie Trump da, der einfach daneben steht. Er weiß, es gibt einen Splitscreen. Wir sehen rechts den stammelnden Biden. Wir sehen links Trump, der schaut zu Biden rüber. Muss euch da gleich helfen, was ist mit dem los? Und genau diese Bildsprache ist es, die so wirkmächtig ist, dass jetzt noch hundert gute Argumente kommen könnten. Die kommen ja nicht, aber die könnten kommen. Und es würde nicht helfen.
Und das ist hier 13. Minute, da sind die Leute noch aufmerksam. Das ist ja nicht wie beim Fußball, dass alle nur die letzten zehn Minuten gucken. Hier ist ja genau umgedreht.
Das gesamte Konzept USA beruht auf Stärke. Das ist ein reines, starke Konzept. Die ganze Weltpolitik, wissen wir jetzt von den strukturellen Realisten, ist ein Machtgeschacher. Und da geht es darum, zu zeigen, dass man stark ist. Dies zeigt, wir haben es mit einem schwachen Präsidenten zu tun. Selbstverständlich hat er gute Leute im Hintergrund, aber das ist das, was am Ende verfängt.
Die er auch nicht zeigt, das ist eine ganz große Kritik.
Die zeigt er gar nicht, die sind nirgendwo zu sehen. Das war ja bei Obama doch auch noch anders. Obama hat auch das sehr auf sich zentriert, aber trotzdem hat man noch andere wahrgenommen.
Er hat ja ein junges Kabinett, Putin-Chech, der ja auch mit ihm schon auf der Debattenbühne stand damals, nirgendwo zu sehen. Entsprechend einfach ist es für Trump, hier rhetorisch einfach so Cash-in-Momente zu machen.
Du weißt es und ich weiss es. Wir haben ein Gespräch. Seine Präsidentschaft ist ohne Frage der schlimmste Präsident, der schlimmste Präsidentschaft in der Geschichte unseres Landes. Wir sollten nicht darüber reden.
Ja, und man sieht dann auch hier wieder im Split-Screen Bidens Gesicht, dass sich...
Guckt auf den Boden, wirklich gibt sich geschlagen.
Ja, wie kann das sein?
Tepper fragt jetzt mal Biden nach seiner so wichtigsten sozialpolitischen Maßnahme. Es sind wirklich nur wenige Sekunden, die man hier mal kurz... Ja, das ist schon ganz gut, das so zu sagen. Wir wissen alle, ein amerikanischer Präsident meint es nie so. Biden gelingt eine kleine Pointe.
Du hast noch 82 Sekunden übrig. Oder ist das nur eine genug?
So, ja. So, jetzt hat Biden hier gesagt, die wichtigste sozialpolitische Maßnahme ist Trump zu bekämpfen und zu besiegen, er darf nicht Präsident werden, denn er würde den Sozialstaat abschaffen.
Jetzt kontert Trump.
So, zum einen greift er auf, wofür er mal kritisiert wird, das kennt man ja so als Mut bei ihm, dass er dann immer den anderen vorwirft, eigentlich solltet ihr alle ins Gefängnis, ihr wollt mich ins Gefängnis stecken und ich soll ein Lügner sein, ihr seid doch alle Lügner, also Biden ist ein großer Lügner, denn Social Security... Weil Migranten kommen und in New York in Luxushotels leben. Bereitgestellt von Joe Biden, der sich später als Wähler braucht.
Nur auch hier wieder das Bild, Split-Screen. Wir sehen Biden, wie er konstant auf den Boden guckt, beziehungsweise er hat ja, das habe ich dann ein paar mal gesehen, doch ein paar Seiten dort liegen, Manuskript. Sie dürfen ja eigentlich nicht viel damit reinnehmen, aber so ein paar Stichpunkte, irgendwas ist da. Er hebt da auch mal irgendwas hoch, während er da nicht dran ist. Das geht alles nicht und das weiß eigentlich ein beiden, das wusste ein beiden vor zehn Jahren, dass man in die Kamera die ganze Zeit legt, dass man miemisch signalisiert, dass man nicht einverstanden ist, dass man sich über den einen Wand lustig macht, was auch immer, dass so es funktioniert, das weiß jeder fast intuitiv. Zumindest jeder, der schon einmal im Fernsehen aufgetreten ist. Man muss ja nur mal ansehen, wie treten Leute...
Das Problem ist, beiden weiß das ja auch, aber er kann es halt nicht.
Er kann es nicht mehr.
Und das sieht man daran. Er kann es nicht. Er ist zu gebrechlich dafür.
Und das heißt aber doch, dass wir jetzt dieses Duell, wir bemühen uns noch ein bisschen, inhaltlich fassen, aber eigentlich beobachten wir hier nur noch Bilder und Ausdrücke. Wir machen jetzt also das, was die KI's noch nicht so gut können, also das Bilder so auslesen, welche Emotionen... Da werden wir heute noch. Aber das ist quasi das neue Feld, das jetzt ganz groß wird. Also welche Infos kann man über Kameras gewinnen, wenn man Kameras einsetzt? Also die aufgeschriebene Welt ist eingespeist bei Chatchipiti und sonst wo.
Genau, aber abseits.
Aber die sichtbare Welt, all das, was miemisch ausgedrückt werden kann, das ist etwas, was wir jetzt hier noch in erster Linie machen. Wir gucken uns das an, denn Inhalte werden eh keine sinnvollen verhandelt. Und daraufhin werden jetzt Wahlentscheidungen getroffen. Ich frage mich ja schon, wenn man jetzt, wir haben ja viel über Demokratie in den letzten Salons gesprochen, das nochmal sich so vergegenwärtigt. Welche Art von Wahl findet eigentlich statt? Es ist am Ende doch das, was alle einstudiert bekommen, wenn sie Deutschland sucht, den Superstar oder Supertalent sehen, irgendeine Performance und am Ende sagen, Nena oder Dieter Bohlen, da habe ich aber Gänsehaut bekommen und das war's.
Also wir können das, was du jetzt sagtest, mal testweise an einem Clip. Das ist ganz interessant, weil wir gucken das ja gerade. Also wir sehen die beiden auch, wir schreiben es ja für euch. Ihr hört das ja nur, selbst wenn ihr den Podcast schaut, ihr hört das ja nur. Jetzt ist es aber so, nicht nur wird die Debatte geschaut, in dem sehr viele Leute ganz kurze TikTok-Schnitzel und so sehen, sondern die Bildsprache wird natürlich auch transportiert, ganz häufig, wo kein Ton mitgeliefert wird. Öffentlicher Raum, Bildschirme hängen rum, Wartezimmer, irgendwas. So, man sieht diese beiden. Und wir hören jetzt einen Clip von Trump und jeder fragt sich, wäre ich in der Lage, diesen Clip genauso zu verstehen, wie ich ihn gehört habe, wenn ich ihn nur sehen würde, aber nicht hören? Ist es darstellbar, dass Trump über Mimik, G-Stick, Haptik dieselbe Botschaft jetzt transportiert, die wir nur hören? Und ich glaube, wir haben alle das Bild vor Augen und wissen eigentlich, warum es funktioniert, warum 70 Millionen Wähler sagen, ja, ja, den werde ich wählen.
Und sie haben mich getötet als der Beste, okay?
Das funktioniert einfach auch ohne Ton. Da guckt man das Bild und Trump sagt, ich bin der Beste. Die Leute, ich will den Besten und dann, ja, dann will doch mich. Okay, so, das ist dann der Kurzschluss, der da kommt. Biden wird jetzt explizit zu seinem Alltag gefragt.
Well, first of all, I spent half my career being.
Ja, das kann man natürlich sagen. Er ist jünger, aber inkompetenter oder weniger kompetent. Aber wenn man so klingt dabei, hat man eine Bildtonschere, dann klappt das nicht so richtig.
Was ist überhaupt mit der Stimme da los?
Ja, er ist besonders schwach. Oder es ist ja nur ein Normalzustand. Jonathan Seward hat ja gefragt, wenn ihr immer behauptet, er hat den Laden im Griff, dann zeigt uns doch mal die Bilder davon. Wir sehen ihn immer nur gebrechlich. Und jetzt hier haben wir wieder nur gebrechlich gesehen.
Ja, es war doch jetzt auch nochmal in den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen auf einer Seite. Ich kann es jetzt nicht sicher sagen, ZDF oder ARD. Wo nochmal aufgeschrieben wurde in einem langen Artikel, dass das rechte Narrative sind, dass Biden gebrechlich ist. Und dann denke ich mir, gut, es mag sein, dass die Rechten hin und wieder auch Videos so schneiden, dass er besonders gebrechlich wirkt oder was aus dem Kontext zerren. Aber generell wird niemand nach diesem oder nach den anderen Auftritten, die die beiden jetzt in den letzten Monaten hatten, sagen, dass das ein Mann ist, dem man das Präsidentsein zutraut.
Jetzt verhandeln sie nochmal die ganz harten Themen. Wir haben sie ja schon zu Beginn angesprochen.
He took none. I'd like to see him take one, just one, a real easy one. Like go through the first five questions, he couldn't do it. To do that, you have to be quite smart and you have to be able to hit the ball a long way. And I do it. He doesn't do it. He can't hit a ball 50 yards. He challenged me to a golf match. He can't hit a ball 50 yards.
Ich bin Clubmeister geworden. Das ist so, als ob wir eine Vereinsmeisterschaft der Zehnjährigen durchführen und dann, weißt du, und nicht mal senior.
Bevor diese Golfdebatte dann anfing, mein Eindruck, da dachte ich, wenn man jetzt so zwei Ortsbürgermeister in einem Duell erleben würde, die würden sich ja nicht schlecht daran stellen.
Nö, bei Ortsbürgermeistern hab ich ja, also mein Vorstell, also ich denke ja immer, die Themen, die die hier verhandeln, wenn du das auf einer Ebene tiefer sagst, würde dich jeder aus dem Saal schicken und sagen, du bist bescheuert. Ich hab das schonmal angesprochen, in welcher Leichtfertigkeit, Merz, Dobrindt und so weiter immer vor der Kamera stehen und völlig verfassungswidrige Sachen einfach fordern, während du selber in deiner Vereinstätigkeit, bei jeder kleinen Satzungsänderung, dir wirklich viele Gedanken machst, das vorher besprichst mit den Leuten, bevor das überhaupt mal Tagesordnungsthema relevant wird. Und die stehen einfach da und kloppen da die wirklich eins A verfassungswidrigen Bürgergeld-Sachen hier, Migration, Grenze und so weiter einfach durch. Das ist unglaublich. Wenn wir gucken hier auf eine Schule, hier sitzen 1.400 Schüler, die werden alle über kurz oder lang ihren Schulabschluss schreiben. Da kannst du sowas wie die beiden hier machen nicht bringen. Nicht eine Sekunde davon kannst du in so einer mündlichen Prüfung abliefern. Die zeigen dir ein Vogel und schicken dich nach Hause. Und die stehen hier da und machen 90 Minuten lang. Also wir hören uns jetzt mal die, was wird hier gerade verhandelt in diesem nächsten Klippen?
Du kannst sehen, dass er 6'5 und nur 223, oder 235 lb ist. Ich habe meinen Handyschuh, als ich Vice-Präsident war, bis zu 6'0. Er ist ein 6-Handicap. Ich war ein 8-Handicap.
Und jetzt sagt schon Trump, wir gehen nicht wie Kinder auswählen. Denn Biden beantwortet diese Handicap-Frage oder greift sie auf in einer Ernsthaftigkeit, als wäre es jetzt den Nahostrieg zu beenden. Es ist so absurd und deswegen muss ich das mal klarstellen, was ich nicht meinte, dass Ortsbürgermeister auf diesem Niveau diskutieren, sondern die müssen ja fachlich sich auseinandersetzen. Die müssen ja wissen, kann man da eine Umgehungsstraße bauen oder nicht. Aber ich würde sagen, von der reinen Performance, wie wirkt man vor einer Kamera, würde ich sagen, kann das jeder, der noch nie vor einer Kamera stand, mindestens genauso gut, wie das, was Biden jetzt da abliefert.
Ja, also ich kann es nicht in Worte fassen, wie ich das finde, was wir hier sehen. An jedem Gartenzaun wäre es unmöglich, wenn da einfach ein 83-jähriger steht und sagt, du bist fett, kannst ja nicht mal dein Golfding selber tragen. Und guck dich doch mal an.
Und der andere fragt, was hast du da für ein Handicap?
Ja, da fragt man nicht, genau, da fragt man nicht zurück und so, sondern das ist dann einfach nur gut alter Mann und so. Das ist hier eine Präsidentendebatte in Amerika. Also ich finde dafür keine Worte. Trump natürlich.
Ich wäre nicht hier gewesen.
Also er wird eigentlich von Biden zurückgerufen, nachdem Biden alles in den Sand gesetzt hat.
Er rief mich, ich muss jetzt Amerika retten, denn, und das ist so absurd, auf der einen Seite dieses, wer schafft es noch, seinen eigenen Golf-Dings zu tragen, wer ist wie Fett und gaukelt aber vor, eigentlich ein bisschen leichter zu sein, schauen die doch an und so. Und dann aber die Themen. Ich frag mich, wie es ist, wenn du zum Bewerbungsgespräch gehst und sagst, ich hab Ihren Chef gestern im Fernsehen gesehen, deswegen bewerbe ich mich hier, ich müsste gar nicht hier sein, aber Ihr Unternehmen, haben Sie Ihren Chef im Fernsehen gesehen? Das ist ja unglaublich. Das muss jetzt mal besser gemacht werden. Nehmen Sie mal mich, ich bin der Beste, den Sie je eingestellt haben, ich werde hier Chef werden. So ungefähr wäre das. Kommst du so als Zirkling da rein? Also es ist wirklich, es ist alles gruselig.
Aber hier sind wir wieder beim Subkutanen. Die Amerikaner wollen keinen Krieg.
Das stimmt.
Menschen wollen in der Regel keinen Krieg. Und er sagt, dieser Präsident führt die Nation in den Dritten Weltkrieg und das müssen wir verhindern. Das wirkt.
Absolut. Also dazu werden wir gleich nochmal, wir gehen mal diesen Rundown durch. Du erinnerst mich an einen Clip, den wir gleich unbedingt noch spielen müssen. Wird Trump die Niederlage, wenn sie ihn denn ereilt, nach Wahlergebnis akzeptieren? Das ist wieder dieses typische, ach sie haben mir eine Frage gestellt, auch so eine wichtige Frage, das ist mir egal. Ich schließe noch mal kurz, ich habe noch ein anderes Thema. So, aber er kriegt die Frage natürlich dann nochmal. Er will sie immer noch nicht beantworten. Er braucht noch eine dritte Nachfrage. Aber ja, das System ist kaputt und er hat ja nichts falsches gemacht. Und jetzt steht er ja wieder zu einer regulären Wahl. Das wird ja schon irgendwie hinhauen. Also, nimmt er jetzt die Wahl an oder nicht, wenn er verliert?
Also nein.
Diesen Clip werden wir noch ein paar Mal hören, denn das öffnet natürlich wieder Tür und Tor. Biden hat, finde ich, schon einen ganz guten allerletzten Moment gehabt, bevor dann die Ausgangsstatements kamen. Du bist ein Weiner und irgendwas ist bei dir kaputt gegangen, als du das letzte Mal verloren hast. Es sind doch Rachegelüste. Zum Thema Rache äußern sie sich sehr viel. Trump sagt halt einfach, meine Rache wird mein Erfolg sein. Na gut, bisschen theatralisch. Bevor wir noch mal drei Clips zur Abtreibung schauen, hören wir noch mal zwei Clips aus Amerika und die Welt. Das sind also Clips, die sind heute nicht allzu entscheidend. In einem Fall aber doch, da wir es häufiger angesprochen haben. Also, Biden, hören wir hier mal, wie stotternd er Trump vorwirft. Aber du hast doch zu Putin gesagt, mach was du willst. Wenn die hier nicht zahlen, ich stehe irgendwann aus der NATO aus und so. Trump feiert sich nochmal dafür. Aber ich hab die doch voll krass erpresst. Ich darf es eigentlich gar nicht sagen, aber in so einer geheimen Sitzung habe ich denen gesagt, wenn ihr hier nichts bezahlt, verteidige ich euch nicht gegen Putin. Und dann haben die plötzlich alle gezahlt und so. Also das hat ihm ja das erste Amtsenthebungsverfahren eingebracht, weil er das nämlich Zelensky am Telefon so gegenüber gesagt hat. Also wenn du nicht zahlst, die 400 Millionen und so, dann... Nee, so, wenn du mir nicht beistehst bei einem CNN-Interview und mich lophudelst, dann zahle ich dir die 400 Millionen Militärhilfe gegen Putin nicht. Und das war noch vor dem Krieg. Gut, also hier zwei Clips, wie Biden es komplett verstolpert, hier Vorwürfe zu machen. Ja, also einfach alle Substantive durcheinander gebracht. Er hat der Ukraine Trump gesagt, mach da was du willst, Putin. Also muss man erstmal, das erfordert so viel Mitdenken bei den Leuten, damit sie überhaupt verstehen, was er hier sagt. Solche müssen ja eigentlich wirklich wie eine gesungene Phrasierung sitzen, ansonsten würden die gar nicht.
Sie waren es, die dafür gesorgt haben.
Genau, das muss auch geübt werden und so weiter. Also so funktioniert das gar nicht. Und dann reagiert Trump wie folgt zum Thema Ukrainekrieg. Ich hab ja gesagt, am Tag eins würde das machen. Jetzt sagt Trump noch vorher. Er hat den jetzt inzwischen im Novemberswahl, im Januarsamtzeit, in der Zeit wird er den Ukraine-Krieg lösen. Und ich glaube, das geht. Die große Ansage des President-Elekt, er fährt dahin, macht einen Deal, sagt den Europäern, das ist der Fall, Alarm unterschrieben, verteidigt euch selber, wenn ihr weiter Krieg machen wollt, macht, aber ohne uns. Und er wird der große Friedenspräsident für ungefähr drei Milliarden Menschen auf der Welt sein. Die sich übrigens jetzt gerade sagen, ach, ihr habt diesen Assange freigelassen, jaja, was war nochmal das große Thema des Assanges, das er euch vorgehalten hat, Collateral-Murder, dass aggressive Angriffskriege falsch sind. Und selbst nach einer Million Toten im Krieg gegen Irak habt ihr das immer noch nicht eingesehen. Also diese Ur-Sünde, dass Angriffskriege jetzt wiedergehen, nachdem wir eigentlich das Ende der Geschichte ausgerufen hatten und so. Der bricht auch noch mal betont, wie wichtig das eigentlich ist. Das ist alles Subkultan, steckt das hier drin.
Ja, ich meine, wir bekommen jetzt noch mal von allen Seiten, von den deutschen Medien, von den Podcastern gesagt, dass es jetzt auf keinen Fall Verhandlungen geben darf und wir auf keinen Fall auf Putin eingehen müssen. Ich will es mal auf einer anderen Ebene noch mal betrachten, nämlich was wir ja gerade sehen, ist, dass durch AI alles merkwürdig ins Wanken gerät und plötzlich müssen sich erbitterte Feinde mal zusammensetzen, um einen Deal auszuhandeln. Undenkbar wäre das vor einer Weile gewesen, dass die eine sinnvolle Verhandlung führen können, aber die haben ja ein gemeinsames Interesse und dieses heißt Profit und da muss man sehen, wie man sich ins Benehmen setzt. Und jetzt will ich nicht sagen, Nationen sind genau wie Konzerne, aber es zeigt ja, dass man Deals schließen kann und ja, Deals sind meistens so aufgebaut, dass sie für beide Seiten nicht das Beste rausholen, sondern dass man sich auf ein kleineres Übel, gemeinsames Übel einigen kann und dennoch ganz gut dabei rauskommt. Und ich halte das durchaus für möglich, dass Trump etwas verhandelt. Die Sache ist ja auch, er wird es so machen, dass er das alleine macht und dann im Prinzip in Berlin und Paris nur noch bekannt gibt, dass er das jetzt so geregelt hat.
Ja, so wie jeder alles nur noch bekannt gibt. Der französische Präsident hat seiner Regierung nicht gesagt, dass er das Parlament auflöst, er hat es der Öffentlichkeit gesagt. Christian Drosten, wir werden dieses Buch lesen, betont wieder und wieder, dass er den Politikern immer nur sagte, was er in seinem Podcast schon gesagt hat. Also es gibt eine Bekanntgabe von Informationen und darüber hinaus findet nicht sehr viel statt. Das Einzige, was wir jetzt vermuten können, ist, Trump wird irgendwelche Leute, oder irgendwelche Leute werden sich selber beauftragt haben und Trump wird das dann abnicken, dass man da Vorverhandlungen führt. Aber für Putin ist das der einzige Weg, aus dem Krieg im Amt zu bleiben. Dass Trump da so ein Deal macht. Also die Kräfte, von denen wir jetzt sagen können, die werden das schon, sind wirklich stark. Es wird hier und unsere Semantik, die nun mit den Subquotan-Gegebenheiten nichts zu tun haben, wird es wirklich, wir werden hier mal wieder verarscht. Das übliche Podcast-Gespräch, wenn wir Deutschlandfunk-Journalisten zuhören oder Politikern, die uns ein Talkshow oder so was erzählen, ist nicht das, wie 80 Prozent der Welt darüber denken, was hier passiert. Und zwar bei beiden Kriegen, Ukraine und Gaza. Ja. Da ist die deutsche Position einfach sehr eigen und sehr abgewendet von dem, was ansonsten diskutiert wird.
Und dieses Versprechen jetzt für die Leute, die ohnehin wenig Perspektive in den USA haben, wir werden nicht in einen dritten Weltkrieg gehen, ist schon etwas, was die Leute dazu bringen kann, Trump zu wählen.
Trump hatte damals 60 Marschflugkörper auf Syrien abgeschossen, nachdem es da wieder Giftgaseinsätze gab. Und es haben ihm seine Wähler wirklich übel genommen. Das haben die damals auch registriert, die Republikaner, dass sie wirklich unter keinen Umständen einen Auslandseinsatz des Militärs wollen. Also einen kriegerischen Auslandseinsatz. Sicherheitstechnisch verfeiern die das natürlich überall, wenn der Flugzeugpräger aufmarschiert und so. Nur halt keine schießende Auseinandersetzung. Gut, wir gucken noch in ein kleines Thema Abtreibung, drei Clips. Denn das ist erstens stellvertretend für die Debatte allgemein. Es wurden ja doch ein paar Themen verhandelt, die wir jetzt aus Zeitgründen natürlich nicht alle durchschauen und die auch für die Amerikaner sehr viel interessanter sind als für uns. Aber dieses Abtreibungsthema ist ja besonders interessant, weil da ja mindestens mal der Hälfte der Bevölkerung als Frauen oder Töchterhabend oder Mütter, die betroffen waren oder wie auch immer, jeder kennt jemanden, gesagt wird, die Republikaner sind im Grunde unwählbar. Die haben sich damit so ein eigen Tor geschossen, das ist das Zero vs. Vade nach 50 Jahren. Wir regeln immer Abtreibungen über Datenschutz und so. Ihr müsst niemandem Bescheid sagen, es bleibt unter euch, was ihr mit dem Arzt vereinbart ermöglicht hatten. Und wie das hier diskutiert wird, ist wirklich haschträubend. Denn Trump, wieder mit seiner alten Leier, wenn mir vorgewürfen wird, ich bin der Radikale, drue ich das einfach um.
der 9.
Also er macht jetzt das Bild auf, in Amerika kann man sich nach der biologischen Geburt noch entscheiden, ein Kind abzutreiben und erlassen, dass die Ärzte einfach liegen. Das gibt es nicht immer in Hollywood Filmen, das gibt es irgendwo, das ist völlig, aber da ist man dann einfach beigeblieben.
Das bedeutet, dass er die Leben des Babys in dem neunten Monat und sogar nach Geburt nehmen kann, weil einige Staaten, die demokratisch sind, es nach Geburt nehmen. Put the baby down, then we decide what to do with it.
Also das Maß, in dem hier einfach all in gegangen wird, bei einer Argumentation, einfach nur um Performance delivern zu können, ist wirklich haarstreuend. Ja, das ist einfach haarstellerisch. Das war die Debatte. Wir haben hier den künftigen amerikanischen Präsidenten gesehen. Mit sehr hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit. Es spricht immer weniger dafür, dass hier also ich kann mir jedenfalls kein Szenario vorstellen.
Ja und die Alternative ist ein Kreis, der dann hoffentlich so ein bisschen vorgeführt wird, dass man hin und wieder so paar Clips hat, über die dürfen dann alle lachen, aber die Entscheidungen werden von irgendjemand anders getroffen, im Weißen Haus und Biden muss dann hin und wieder stolperfrei irgendwo raufgehen und was sagen.
Es ist ja im Grunde das Schicksal Beider. Trump hat jetzt dieses riesige Heritage Foundation Programm da, schon was Trump da irgendwie untergejubelt werden soll. Von dem hat Trump ja auch keine Ahnung. Da werden immer einfach unter der Hand 50.000 Leute ausgetauscht, im Regierungsapparat, die machen dann irgendwas. Also im Grunde wird ein Deep State installiert, der einfach nur die Chance wettert, wenn dann jetzt, weil sie sehen auch, wenn Trump jetzt nicht gewählt wird, dann ist die republikanische Partei gerade in keinem Zustand, nächsten Kandidaten aufzustellen. Weil so eine Jahrhundertfigur wie Trump, der einfach medial gestellt ist, der da eine Freude dran hat und dem wirklich alles scheißegal ist, also das braucht auch eine gewisse biologisch-psychische Konstellation im Gehirn, die findet man nicht so einfach. Das ist sozusagen dieses Rodger Brechmann-Argument, mit dem stimmt irgendwas nicht, wirklich auf die Spitze getrieben. So einen haben die da nicht. Also das ist jetzt deren Chance, das zu machen. Also machen die das jetzt auch. Nur das hat mit Trump auch nichts zu tun. So wie die nächste Präsidentschaft von Biden mit Biden als Person auch nichts zu tun hätte. Also das sind beides jetzt, nachdem wir sich hier über ihr Golfen reden, eigentlich droht hier auf beiden Seiten so eine institutionelle Black-Box-Regentschaft.
Dann ist das so, das müssen wir jetzt einfach sagen, das sind so Maskottchen. Also es ist eigentlich wie bei der EM gibt es noch ein Maskottchen, das spielt aber nicht selbst Fußball. Das sieht man und sagt man, das ist der Goleo.
Es gibt ganz viele Maskottchen bei der EM. Also hier hat man jetzt zwei Herren gesehen, die ja nun wirklich kurz vorm Lallen und so weiter und ihren eigenen Sing-Sang mitbringen. Hast du mal Fußballbericht gehabt und gesehen, wenn Schweinsteiger danach Spiele bespricht?
Nein.
Das ist ja kaum zu ertragen. Der lallt ja auch vor sich hin, als wäre er so leicht angetrunken. Also da gibt es gar keine Mühe beim Sprechen, sondern es ist einfach so ein... Also es gibt ganz viele Maskottchen überall, gerade in EM-Zeiten. Das ist im Grunde nur Maskottchenarbeit, die hier stattfindet.
Ja, vielleicht ist das dann so eine neue Phase, in die wir eintreten. Es gibt dann gute und schlechte Maskottchen und dann gibt es irgendwas dahinter, was technokratisch entweder gut funktioniert oder dysfunktional ist. Naja, man kann natürlich auch sagen, wenn wir jetzt über diese Präsidentschaft sprechen und uns selbst so auf diese Kandidaten fokussieren, dann machen wir den Fehler zu erkennen, dass ein Staat sehr viel mehr ist. Und wir sehen das ja auch jetzt bei der Europawahl, über die wir heute kaum sprechen werden.
Lass mich nur eine Anmerkung zur Europawahl machen. U25-Wahl in Frankfurt, Grüne.
Bevor wir dazu kommen, ich weiß jetzt, was du gleich sagst, ich will das nur sagen, wir haben zugleich eine Kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von der Leyen, die auch irgendwo als Maskottchen jetzt sich auserkoren wurde, die setzt man jetzt dahin. Aber das hat ja auch nichts mit Wählerwillen oder sonst was zu tun.
Nicht so viel mit Wählerwillen, aber ich glaube schon, dass das Kabinett von Ursula von der Leyen noch sehr von ihr handverlesen ist und so. Anders als hier.
Aber es scheint ja eine Kluft zu geben zwischen Leuten, die wir sehen und Leuten, die es machen. Also wir haben ja einen Europawahlkampf gehabt, wo Leute auf Wahlplakaten groß waren, wie zum Beispiel Olaf Scholz oder Sarah Wagenknecht, die ja nicht dahin gewählt werden können. Zugleich haben wir bei der CDU, bei der letzten Wahl, so gehabt, dass nirgends Ursula von der Leyen auftauchte, die plötzlich aus dem Hut gezaubert wurde, weil man die jetzt lieber hatte.
Ja, aber da denke ich mir auch, es ist auch mit Wählerentscheid gewesen, zu sagen, Europa ist so gebaut, wie Europa gebaut ist. Und wir machen in Deutschland auch keine Kanzlerwahl, sondern wir wählen ein Parlament. Und das Parlament wählt danach aus seinen Kreisen einen Kanzler, der allerdings kann als Minister jeden ernennen. Also Gerhard Schröder hatte damals diesen, in keiner Partei, in keinem Parlament seien wir Wirtschaftsminister. Einfach aus der Energiewirtschaft rekrutiert. Und das ist dann halt so. Das ist da an der Spitze direkt, aber dafür ist ja die Europäische Kommission auch nicht wirklich eine Regierung. Sie hat halt diese Initiativrechte, die genauso gut auch beim Parlament liegen könnten. Das allerdings ist ja auch jetzt mittlerweile bei jeder Legislatur immer ein Thema, dass das irgendwann kommt, dass das EU-Parlament einfach selber, das EU-Parlament darf heute schon die Kommission auffordern, eine Initiative vorzulegen. Also es rückt da immer weiter ran. Wenn man sich das historisch anschaut, wird das, was wir hier gerade kritisieren, immer weiter ausgemerzt. Früher war es so, das Europäische Parlament hatte gar nichts zu sagen und die Kommission wurde aus dem Hut gezaubert. Dann kamen irgendwann die Veto-Rechte, jetzt müssen alle Einzelnen am Europaparlament antreten. Also in deren Sicht würde ich sagen, es ist ein System im Wandel und im Entstehen und du wolltest noch was zu Frankfurt sagen. Ja, Frankfurt. Also Europawahl U25 in Frankfurt, war ja mal Rechtsruck und so weiter. Grüne 16 Prozent, Volt 14, Linke 13. Dann kommt das die CDU mit 10, dann die FDP mit 8, dann die SPD mit 7, AfD 6. Also urbane Zentren funktionieren, selbst wenn diese U25 hier wirklich mit zu den Ärmsten in Deutschland gehören. Also wir haben es hier nicht mit luxuriösen Verhältnissen wie auf dem ostdeutschen Lande zu tun, wo sie alle AfD wählen, wo einfach unendlicher Wohnraum für 3,80 Euro angemietet werden kann und so, sondern wenn ökonomische Argumente für den Rechtsdruck, dann muss man das nochmal hart überprüfen. Genauso wie im Ruhrgebiet, das ja ärmer ist als der Osten, strukturell und abstrahiert betrachtet und da wird auch nicht so viel AfD gewählt.
Aber man konnte schon sehen, dass wenn Armut und niedriger Bildungsabschluss miteinander gekoppelt sind, dass in, bis auf ein paar urbane Zentren, aber da ist ja eh immer alles ein bisschen anders, dass dann die AfD sonst hoch im Kurs liegt.
Man sollte da die subkultanen Subkultanen-Sachen noch mal.
Na ich würde sagen, es gibt den Zusammenhang schon, es gibt den nur nicht überall und es ist auch eine andere Armut, ob du jetzt im Osten auf dem Land bist, eine Ausbildung gemacht hast, keinen richtigen Job findest oder nur einen Job findest, der dir ewig Mindestlohn verspricht und nicht mehr oder ob du in Frankfurt für 750 Euro ein WG-Zimmer anmieten musst, aber Soziologie und BWL studierst und danach vielleicht Unternehmensberater wirst oder was auch immer. Das heißt, diese Armut ist schlimm, die man dort erlebt, aber da scheint noch so etwas wie ein Ausweg vorhanden zu sein. Während die Auswegslosigkeit zum Beispiel im Osten oder auch in Teilen des Ruhrgebiets oder auch im ländlichen Raum von Rheinland-Pfalz eine andere ist und da kann man dann tatsächlich diese enge Verbindung sehen zwischen AfD und Wählern, die aus dieser Perspektivlosigkeit dazu entscheiden.
Hier kann man ja die Begriffsunterscheidung mal schärfen. In Frankfurt gibt es finanzielle Armut, im Osten ist sie soziale Armut.
Ja, möglicherweise.
Oder kulturelle Armut, wie auch immer. Aber hier ist es zum Glück nur temporäre und finanzielle Armut in der Hoffnung, dass junge Leute dann auch in die Welt hinein starten. Gut, du hast unseren Kanzler geguckt.
Na so schnell machen wir das noch nicht. Wir wollen erst ganz kurz auf den Salon hinweisen. Wir haben jetzt gerade schon kurz Europa angeschnitten. Dann schauen wir uns doch mal an, wie Europa funktioniert oder nicht. Nämlich wollen wir das Buch Brüssel sehen und sterben, wie ich im Europaparlament meinen Glauben an fast alles verloren habe. Ich würde das Buch von Nico Semsrott lesen. Das wird aber nicht das einzige Buch sein, sondern Nico Semsrott hat noch einen Bruder, Arne Semsrott. Er hat ein Buch geschrieben, das heißt Machtübernahme. Was passiert, wenn Rechtsextremisten regieren, eine Anleitung zum Widerstand? Das ist eine ganz interessante Perspektive, die wir mit diesen beiden Büchern einnehmen. Wir blicken sowohl auf Europa und diesen technokratischen Apparat und den Parlamentarismus, den Semmsrott, so klingt es ja schon im Titel, arg kritisieren wird. Zugleich haben wir dann mit seinem Bruder die Idee, dass man über Institutionen, über andere gesellschaftspolitische Mechanismen dafür sorgen könnte, dass der Rechtsextremismus aufgehalten wird oder abgebremst wird. Wir werden also diese beiden Perspektiven uns ansehen und das dann auch verbinden mit den Ergebnissen der Europawahl und den anderen Rechtsrucken, die noch so kommen und auch der Frage, wie denn es eigentlich um die Demokratie direkt bestellt ist. Wir haben das ja jetzt immer sehr theoretisch verhandelt, zum Beispiel mit Veit Selk und wollen dann uns es einmal in der Praxis ansehen und auch mal schauen, ob nicht diese Kritik an Brüssel mit all den Privilegien, eine ist, die zu kurz greift. Denn ich will jetzt nicht die Privilegien der Politiker verteidigen. Ich würde nur sagen, dass wir vielleicht auf eine andere Ebene müssen, aber dafür müssen wir erst die beiden Bücher lesen.
Dieses Nico Semsrott Buch hat auch einen guten Einstieg, passend zu den beiden Herren, die wir gerade geschaut haben. Denn er sagt am Anfang, die Lügen haben die Politik kaputt gemacht, deswegen will ich sie gar nicht anlügen. Sie haben hier ein Buch von mir in der Hand. Das habe ich weder geschrieben noch nicht mal gelesen. Dafür bin ich viel zu depressiv. Ich habe einfach Leuten alle meine Notizen gegeben und die haben daraus ein Buch gemacht. Das ist immer ein sehr guter Einstieg in so ein Politiker-Buch.
Wir sind also gespannt. Man kann den Salon und auch den Live-Salon, den wir letzten Monat in Frankfurt haben, alles nachhören, wenn man uns abonniert. Das ist am Allereinfachsten über Steady. Das empfehlen wir. Dort sind auch alle alten Salons vorhanden. Am besten geht man auf die Seite neuezwanziger.de. Da ist ein goldener Button. Dann kommt man zum Salon. Man kann ab 2,50 Euro, wir sind also sehr günstig, im Gesamtprogramm von Steady, kann man den Salon dann... Tatsächlich.
Man kann ja nicht mehr, wenn man dort ein neues Projekt mit unter 3 Euro machen kann.
Kann man also dann den Salon abonnieren, kann dann auch die alten Salons hören. Und wer mehr geben will, hat auch da die Möglichkeit, ein höheres Abo abzuschließen. Man kann außerdem, wenn man Apple-Kunde ist und es bequem mag und man auch in Kauf nehmen will, dass man 50 Cent mehr zahlt, über Apple den Salon abonnieren. Wer schon bei Patreon ist, kann das über Patreon tun. Und wir wollen noch darauf hinweisen, dass wir am 24. August in Frankfurt live zu erleben sind. Es gibt noch ein paar Karten. Es wird dann sehr groß sein, 800 Leute passen in diesen Saal rein. Wir freuen uns dann. Das ist dann der Sommersalon. Wer da Karten haben will, wir werden in die Beschreibung den Link setzen zu dieser Veranstaltung. Und jetzt lasse mich noch eine halbe Minute Eigenwerbung machen, denn ich habe ein Buch geschrieben für dich und die deinen. Denn du hast ja drei Kinder. Du brauchst mindestens drei Bücher dann. Ich habe mit Ole zusammen ein Kinderbuch geschrieben. Es heißt Die Kleinen Holzdiebe und das Rätsel des Juggernaut.
Wer ist da ein Juggernaut? Oder bleibt das ein Rätsel?
Nein, aber ein Juggernaut ist ja so ein Trophän, Zeremonienwagen, der sich in Bewegung setzt und immer weiterrollt und diese Metapher Juggernaut ist sehr verbreitet im britischen Diskurs, aber wir beziehen uns, um das schon mal hier rauszulassen, natürlich auf Marx.
Ja, wen sonst?
Wir haben uns gedacht, wenn Carsten Maschmeyer und viele andere solche Leute Kinderbücher schreiben, in denen sie schon den Kleinsten einreden, dass man vor...
Aber hat er nicht nur so ein kleines Bilderbuch gemacht?
Nein, nein, nein, er hat ein richtiges Buch mit der Erzählung, mit einem Kinderbuchautor zusammen. Und da geht es darum, früh Investor zu werden, früh die Start-up-Mentalität zu entwickeln. Es gibt ganz viele Bücher, die sind irrsinnig beliebt bei Eltern. Wie kann ich mein Kind zu einem reichen Kind machen?
Die lesen wir unseren Kindern alle vor und hören dabei Mozart.
Es ist grauenhaft, was da gemacht wird.
Und wir lesen natürlich auf Chinesisch.
Also wie mache ich aus meinem siebenjährigen Kind schon ein Bitcoin-Pro? Es ist verrückt. Und wir dachten, wir müssen etwas dagegen setzen und haben eine Abenteuer- Geschichte geschrieben, die 270 Seiten lang ist, mit wunderbaren Illustrationen von Nick Martin-Sternitzke.
Ja, die wurden handgezeichnet, die sind nicht generiert.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nicht hier, Chat-G-Bit-Kram. Also das ist noch richtig geschrieben und noch richtig gezeichnet. So wie du uns ja die ganze Zeit einredest, wird es bald nicht mehr sein. Aber wir haben es nochmal so richtig gemacht und ja, das ist jetzt, was ich dazu sagen will. Wer das Buch vorbestellt, würde uns damit eine große Freude tun, denn es ist ja gar nicht so leicht, im Buchhandel vertreten zu sein. Das heißt, man kann es online vorbestellen. Noch schöner wäre es, wenn es in den lokalen Buchhandlungen bestellt wird, dann werden die auch darauf aufmerksam. Also die kleinen Holzdiebe und das Rätsel des Yoganaut erscheint bei Insel bzw. Surkamp und kommt am 12.
Sehr gut.
Wir müssen jetzt einmal Revue passieren lassen, was wir so im Podcast von uns geben. Ein Hörer hat uns darauf hingewiesen, dass wir vor einem Jahr...
Haben wir Quatsch erzählt?
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich weiß noch nicht, worum es geht.
Vielleicht du. Also wir werden jetzt mal gucken. Es geht darum, dass wir vor einem Jahr über die Klimakleber diskutiert haben, diese ganzen Aktionen auch im Museum und darüber, wie ist das dann jetzt mit den Straßen, die blockiert werden. Und wir hören uns jetzt mal den Clip von damals an. Also wir spulen jetzt quasi ein Jahr im Podcast zurück und hören mal, was wir damals so von uns gegeben haben.
Also ihr hört jetzt uns aber aus der Konserve für eine Minute 47. Und es ist halt immer so ein bisschen fragwürdig, wohin führt es denn eigentlich? Wir haben jetzt die Situation gehabt, dass die neue Justiz-Senatorin von Berlin, das hast du bestimmt auch gesehen, in den Tagesthemen zu Kassel war. Genau und sie hat ja da zum Beispiel über die Klimakleber gesprochen und meinte dann, hat dann so vorgerechnet, naja, erste Statistiken zeigen, dass in Berlin Krankenwagen mit lebensgefährlich verletzten Menschen 26 Minuten später am Klinikum ankommen, also da Versorgung gefährdet ist.
Das gilt wahrscheinlich aber auch, wenn Berlin Marathon ist.
Und das ist nämlich der Punkt. Jetzt hat sie von Seiten der Politik die Argumentation aufgemacht, dass Stau, Verkehrsbehinderung grundsätzlich erstmal ein Problem ist. Am Beispiel Blockade durch Klimakleber. Aber was ist denn mit, wenn man das als Schiffrindehm mit den anderen Blockaden? So und jetzt kann man sagen, ja gut, die Selbstbeschreibung der Klimakleber war echt scheiße. Jetzt kann man sagen, meine Fremdbeschreibung ist auch ein bisschen dämlich, indem ich die irgendwie vergleiche mit zwei Kindern im Supermarkt. Aber es führte dazu, dass wir jetzt eine regierende Justizministerin haben, die plötzlich einen Diskurs aufmacht zum Thema, die Gründe einer Verkehrsverzögerung sind nicht mehr egal. Und das ist ja eben beschrieben, wie die Verkehrsverzögerungen so aussehen. Welche Diskussionen haben wir denn in einem Jahr, wenn wir das mal ein bisschen weiterführen, wenn daran jetzt angeschlossen wird. Und da würde ich sagen, das kann durchaus mal eine Verkehrswende einleiten, wenn nicht mehr jeder einfach alles auf der Straße machen darf, zum Beispiel mit einem dicken SUV rumfahren, wenn der Anlass dafür war zu sagen, auf der Straße darf man nicht alles, man darf sich zum Beispiel nicht da festkleben. Würde ich sagen, stimmt, auf der Straße darf man nicht alles, zum Beispiel man darf sich da nicht festkleben. Man sollte man zum Beispiel noch alles nicht dürfen. Und dann ist das für mich ein Einstieg auch in der SUV- Diskussion zum Beispiel.
Immer noch in der Argumentation schlüssig?
Ich bin total immer noch auf meiner Seite.
Die Sache ist nur, wir sind jetzt ein Jahr später und genau nichts ist geschehen. Und das habe ich in gewisser Weise schon prophezeit, das ist aber nicht so schwer. Man kann eigentlich in Deutschland immer sagen, wird aber nichts ändern.
Man hat was gegen SUVs gesagt, ist aber nichts passiert.
Man hat immer recht, wir hören mal gerade noch, wie das weiterging, die Diskussion zwischen uns. Denn es ist, glaube ich, ganz gut, jetzt noch mal zu sagen, Klimakleber waren das ganz große Thema. Weiß das noch einer?
Und ich saß auf dieser Bank bei diesem Handbeispiel in der Sonne und plötzlich höre ich diesen Scheiß da die ganze Zeit. Selbst die reden darüber. Nur, sie reden mehr ein guter Diskurs.
Aber ist das ein guter Diskurs denn, sie reden ja dann über diese Aktionen und sie reden ja nicht konstruktiv darüber, wie könnte man generell den Verkehr besser geschmeidiger organisieren, sondern es ist ja ein Aufregen über einzelne Akteure und man sieht ja auch bei YouTube, was einem angezeigt wird. Ich glaube nicht, dass sich das verändern wird. Ich glaube, das sind solche Debatten wie die um die Papierstrohhalme und so ein Kram. Also man hat solche Scheindebatten und tatsächlich müsste man doch dahin kommen, dass die Debatte eher ist, du hast es ja eben vorgemacht. Die Wasserversorgung stimmt ja eigentlich gar nicht und ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass von diesen Aktionen und von der Debatte um diese Aktionen und das ist ja nicht alleine den Klimaklebern anzugreiten, sondern generell, dass von diesen Debatten aus irgendetwas hinführt zu den fundamentaleren Fragen.
Also ich werbe noch mal für die eine Sensorik, es sind Zukunftsbilder.
Ihr habt doch, ihr sind doch bestimmt KI-Leute und alles, die sollen mal so eine Erinnerung machen. Wir haben jetzt Ende Mai 2023, Ende Mai 2024, vielleicht kann da irgendjemand mal eine Erinnerung machen, ob sich die Debatte so verändert hat, wie Stefan uns das jetzt hier skizziert hat. Wir haben es jetzt in Zahlen. Die Klimakleber sind mit ihren Aktionen nach einigen Interviews und Fernsehauftritten nicht mehr weitergekommen, haben sich dann dazu entschieden zu kandidieren, also die letzte Generation, um es jetzt mal korrekt zu fragen, für das Europaparlament 0,3%. Ich habe mir dann die Mühe gemacht und habe grüne Städte ausgesucht. Man kann das ja sehr genau alles nachvollziehen. Also Städte, in denen ganz viele Leute grün wählen, die sehr universitär sind, die ein hohes ökologisches Bewusstsein haben.
Vogue-Towns.
Könnte man, wenn man so will, sagen. Da haben die Grünen verloren. Zum Teil deutlich verloren, mehr als zehn Prozent verloren. Was ist passiert? Die Leute sind entweder nicht wählen gegangen oder sie haben Volt gewählt oder sie haben vielleicht irgendeine andere Partei, die dem Ökologischen nicht ganz abholt ist, gewählt. Sie haben nicht die letzte Generation gewählt. Das heißt, wir haben vor einem Jahr einen unglaublichen Tumult gehabt, wegen dieser Aktionen. Ich habe damals gesagt, diese Aktionen werden überhaupt nichts bringen. Das wird so eine wunderbare Vogue-Town- Debatte sein. Alle können da mal im Sommerloch sich austoben. Das führt zu nichts. Ich glaube, wir sehen hier schon bestätigt, was Anton Jäger, auch wenn wir dieses Buch jetzt nicht über alle Maßen gefeiert haben, diagnostiziert hat. Nämlich, das ist eine Hyperpolitik, die so ganz kurz einmal funktioniert. Dann wäre wahrscheinlich im Juni letzten Jahres das Wahlergebnis für die letzte Generation bei 4,5 Prozent gewesen und dann ist es aber sofort wieder weg. Wir können das ja auch bei Fridays for Future sehen, dass große Aktionen dort nicht mehr passieren und dass Luisa Neubauer eigentlich krampfhaft versucht, immer wieder neue Themen noch mal zu besetzen, um weiterhin aktivistisch stattzufinden in den Medien. Aber wir sehen daran schon, dass also keine Strukturen aufgebaut wurden, die in irgendeiner Weise nachhaltig sind und es ist auch nicht gelungen, von diesen Provokationen etwas abzuleiten, das dahin führt, dass man zum Beispiel mal darüber nachdenkt, wie müssten denn eigentlich Städte, Straßen usw. organisiert sein.
Ja, aber rückblinkend würde ich sagen, diese Proteste der Klimakleber haben ja überhaupt nur medial funktioniert, weil die Gegenseite sie nutzen konnte.
Ja, dann hat es ja eher noch der Gegenseite genutzt. Aber das ist ja noch schlimmer.
Ja, aber es gab dann, also irgendwo sind ja diese Grünenstimmen dann auch hingegangen in die Nichtwählerschaft oder in diese Protestwählerei. Mit denen, die sich drum gerangeln, wäre denn jetzt die beste gegen gendern, gegen vogue, gegen was auch immer. Das hat dann CDU, CSU, AfD usw. unter sich aufgeteilt und so sei auch das Wahlergebnis aus.
Aber das war das ja, weil du sagtest ja, die Leute haben damals alle darüber gesprochen in dem Clip, den wir jetzt eben gespielt haben.
Also ja, die saßen auf dieser Bank und haben über die Heizungen, über die Klimakleber, aber immer mit diesem Unterton solche Idioten.
Richtig und das ist nicht gelungen, dass man genau diese Leute für die Klimasache gewinnt. Wenn man natürlich sagt, die sind alle verloren oder die sich so empfinden, dann wählen die selbstverständlich CDU oder noch wesentlich weiter rechts.
Ich bin aber auch weiterhin dafür, dass wenn, das hatten wir jetzt auch bei der EM zum Beispiel, es ist Europameisterschaft und hier finden Spiele in Frankfurt statt. Was bedeutet, der Nahverkehr auf der Schiene kann nicht fahren, nicht weil er auf der Straße fährt. Er hat ein eigenes Schienenbett, sondern weil er ab und zu die Straße überqueren muss. Und auf diesen drei Metern stehen dann die Autos. Die stehen eh 15 Kilometer im Stau und dann auch noch genau auf den Schienen, sodass die Bahn dann auch nicht durchkommt. Und da wäre ich dafür weiterhin, dass man dieses Tor nutzt, zu sagen, also wenn es eine juristische Diskussion zum Thema, da ist ein Krankenwagen zu spät, weil irgendjemand an der Straße festgeklebt hat, dann würde ich auch eine juristische Diskussion zum Thema, 20 Leute sitzen in der Straßenbahn und kommen einfach nicht an, weil sich einer nicht an die Regeln gehalten hat im Straßenverkehr und dafür einen Stau verursacht hat, also dass ein Verursacher eines Staus auf jeden Fall erst mal sich rechtfertigen muss dafür, kann ja am Ende freigesprochen werden, wie auch immer, aber wer auf eine Schiene hält und weiß, ich kann jetzt nicht vor und zurück, sondern ich ziehe den ganzen Straßenbahnverkehr in meine Mitleidenschaft, der ist dafür verantwortlich zu machen, juristisch.
Ich bin ganz auf deiner Seite, nur die Sache ist ja, wie kommt man jetzt über solche Einzelfälle hinaus zu einer anderen Klimapolitik oder müssen wir zumindest mal eines tun, dass wir also nicht mehr auf solche Aktivismus-Events hereinfallen, also dass man so viel Gehirnschmalz aufbringt, um jetzt über die Klimakleber zu diskutieren, die dann ein Jahr später gänzlich marginalisiert sind. Man kann es im Übrigen auch an der Buchbranche so gut sehen. Man weiß genau, was los war. Klimakleber, großes Thema, also sollen Aktivisten aus diesem Umfeld oder Leute, die ihnen nahe stehen, mal Bücher über Protest und Aktivismus schreiben. Dann werden diese Bücher schnell verfasst, aber natürlich nicht schnell genug. Die erscheinen dann im Februar, März und niemand kauft diese Bücher. Man kann das sehr gut nachvollziehen über Amazon oder wenn man Leute kennt, die einen Media-Control-Zugang haben, dann weiß man einfach, das ist nicht. Und manche Bücher, die angekündigt wurden, ich habe wirklich mal darauf geachtet, wurden sogar schon jetzt verschoben ins nächste Jahr oder auf den St. Nimmerleins-Tag oder sind völlig wieder aus dem Programm genommen. Also das ist schon bemerkenswert und deswegen will ich jetzt noch eine Kopplung machen an die medialen Aufreger. Also wir versuchen ja nicht so sehr in diese Schnappatmung reinzukommen, dass wir auf alles so aufspringen. Klar, ein Duell müssen wir jetzt mal hier verhandeln. Wir haben gar nicht so viel über Sylt gesagt, aber dieses Sylt-Video vor sechs Wochen hat unglaublich viel Tinte freigesetzt, viele Light-Artikel, Vogue-Tons wurden dazu geschrieben.
Wir haben den Denk-Level von Rosenfeld gehört, als sie sich fragte, ob die Reichen jetzt auch rassistisch sind.
Ja, zugleich würde ich jetzt aber mal Folgendes machen wollen. Dieses Video war abscheulich und dieses Video sagt auch etwas aus über die deutsche Gesellschaft. Aber ich glaube, dass wir ein Problem bekommen, wo wir aufgrund dieses Videos, aufgrund von 20, 30 Leuten wieviel es auch sind, die ein rassistisches Lied grölen, dass man daraufhin auf Grundlage dieses Videos eine große Gesellschaftsanalyse machen kann. Ist das sinnvoll?
Also da gibt es ja eine gute Abhandlung, sehr soziologisch von Fran O. Sreczky, die Diagnose-Gesellschaft, wo genau dieses punktuelle und das gibt den Zeitgeist wieder.
Denn es ist mir was aufgefallen, ich will das auch unbedingt ansprechen, damit es nicht so ist, als würde man es verschweigen wollen. Das war eine Gruppe von Leuten dort, die da saß und ein rassistisches Lied gesungen hat und dann wurde das aufgenommen und dadurch hat das dann auch so ein Memifizierungscharakter und dann geht das überall viral. Wovon wir keine Aufnahme haben, wovon wir aber trotzdem sehr gut unterrichtet sind, ist der Fall, der jetzt gerade in Bad Oeynhausen stattgefunden hat, in der Nähe von Bielefeld. Das ist schon interessant, dass du sofort auch nachfragen musst, aber was ist das? Also Sylt ist ein Begriff, muss ich nur sagen. Sylt, weiß jeder Bescheid.
Also Bad Oeynhausen ist ja für uns auch ein Begriff, weil Niklas Luhmann da gelebt hat.
Ja, aber Bad Oeynhausen ist uns jetzt noch mal in eine andere Weise ein Begriff, deshalb, weil dort eine Abifeier stattfand, ein Abiturient, Philippos hieß er, mit einem Freund zusammen durch diesen Stadtpark nachts nach Hause geht. Dort ist eine Gruppe von jungen Männern, zehn, zwölf Leute, genaue Zahlen weiß man noch nicht. Es gibt irgendeinen Wortwechsel, eine Streiterei und dieser Philippos wird dann totgeprügelt. Und dieser Philippos ist, der Name sagt es, auch jemand, der eine Migrationsgeschichte hat, dadurch, dass sein Vater, glaube ich, Grieche ist. Und zu der Sache gehört aber, dass der Hauptverdächtige, der jetzt von der Polizei geschnappt wurde und die Medien haben ja darüber berichtet, ein Syrer ist. Und wir haben vor einer Weile einen Mord an einem Polizisten gehabt mit dem Messer. Wir haben ein paar solcher Fälle gehabt, wo eine Art von barbarischer Brutalisierung stattfindet, die einen so erschaudern lässt, genau deshalb, weil wir eigentlich gewöhnt sind, Gewalt im Ganzen zu ächten. Und diese Art der Attacken, wo Leute totgeprügelt mit Messern erstochen werden, in dieser Weise völlig geächtet und verbannt haben. Und es ist aber auch da in der Gesellschaft. Es findet statt. Und es sind dann doch interessante Bewegungen zu beobachten, dass man bei Sylt sofort von linksradikal bis linksliberal Mitte alle Ableitungen bereit ist zu machen. Wenn aber so was wie in Bad Ouenhausen stattfindet, wo ich sagen kann, ja, das war ja einfach eine gleich große Gruppe, die haben aber nicht nur gesungen, die haben auch jemanden noch totgeschlagen. Dass daraus nicht eine Ableitung stattfindet. Ich will nicht dazu einladen zu den rechten Ableitungen. Denn die Rechten greifen natürlich diesen Fall aus und sagen, und deshalb brauchen wir mehr Abschiebungen, deshalb brauchen wir mehr dies, mehr das und so weiter. Ich kann gar keine sinnvolle Ableitung da machen, weil ich erstmal fassungslos gegenüber dieser Tat bin und nicht genau sagen kann, woran es liegt. Aber dass es offenbar ein Problem gibt, das sich in solcher barbarischer Art Gewalt äußert, das kann nicht einfach von einem großen Teil, also einem eher linksliberalen bis linksradikalen Teil, einfach so, ja, hat wohl stattgefunden, es ist einfach so wie so ein, gab wohl irgendwo mal ein Banküberfall oder so, sondern das hat auch eine politische Komponente. Und es geht nicht, dass man bei Sylt glaubt, die ganze deutsche Gesellschaft erklären zu können und dass man bei einem solchen Fall einfach sagt, reden wir einfach gar nicht drüber, das ist ein immenses Problem. Zumal es ja nicht hier ist, das sind irgendwie die Migranten gegen die Deutschen, die hier schon immer wohnen, nein, hier haben wir auch jemanden, wo auch eine latente Migrationsgeschichte da ist, aber wir haben auch offenbar mit dem Hauptverdächtigen jemand, der hier war, der schon auffällig geworden ist der Polizei gegenüber und der jetzt verdächtig wird, dieses barbarische Verbrechen begangen zu haben. Und das ist einfach ein sehr großes gesellschaftliches Problem. Und das sollte man nicht den Rechten überlassen, damit nicht nur diese Ableitungen erfolgen. Und deshalb brauchen wir mehr Frontex oder so. Das kann nicht die Lösung sein, es hilft auch niemanden da. Aber man kann auch nicht die Augen davor verschließen. Und die Wahrheit ist, dass auch viele Leute genau vor solchen Dingen Angst haben, dass sowas passiert, weil es ein Ausmaß von Gewalt ist, was wir wirklich nicht mehr kennen. Ich will noch einen letzten Satz dazu sagen, wenn wir jetzt irgendwelche Festivals oder so besuchen, irgendwelche Veranstaltungen, da sind überall so Safety-Teams. Das heißt, es gibt richtige Ordner, die Angestellte. Und dann gibt es noch mal von den Veranstaltern selbst Leute, die sagen, hey, wenn da irgendwas ist, wenn da sich jemand jemanden bedrängt oder so, ihr könnt euch jederzeit hier an die Leute mit den grünen Westen oder so wenden. Also man hat einen Sensibilisierungsgrad erreicht. Und das ist ein großer Fortschritt, dass man jetzt auch noch mal ein Team hat, dass so diese kleinen, nicht so juristisch gleich zu fassenen Dinge auch noch mal da einen Blick drauf hatte und da versucht, als Ansprechpartner zur Verfügung steht, um Leute auch vor so was zu schützen, was man nicht jetzt gerade mal so nur im Gesetzbuch nachlesen kann. Wir haben also dann einen hohen Grad von Sensibilisierung erreicht. Und zugleich haben wir auch diese barbarischen Akte in dieser Weise. Und jetzt kann man sagen, ja, aber es gibt ja auch ganz viele rechtsradikale, brutale Akte. Ja, genau, über die reden wir ja auch. Und wir müssen aber auch über diese anderen Akte reden.
Ja, also bei diesen medialen Diskursen, die ich jetzt in dem Falle so gar nicht verfolgt hat, also von Bad Oeynhausen habe ich noch gar nichts gehört, kann natürlich sein, dass das ein mega Thema war und ich, aber ich hatte auch Corona die Woche, mein erstes Corona. Vielleicht bin ich ein bisschen entschuldigt. Häufiger, und wir kennen das im Podcast wie Micky Beisenherz oder so oder Sascha Lobo auch, viele News, da hat man dann so ein Tenor, okay, wir müssen heute mal über Nahost reden. Und dann kommen plötzlich so Themen auf, dass man so Argumentationsstränge, die ungefähr so lauten. Sehr viele Leute demonstrieren jetzt gegen den Einsatz Israels in Gaza. Wo waren diese Leute, als in Somalien Völkermord stattfand? Wo schauen die hin, wenn in Ruanda, Elfenbeinküste? Ist mir jetzt dunkel in Erinnerung, dass da auch irgendwas war. Auf jeden Fall Jemen oder so. So, und daran sieht man ja die Leute, die da und da und da nicht diskutiert haben, aber jetzt plötzlich diskutieren, sind ja alles Antisemiten, weil sonst hätten die ja auch... Denen geht es ja gezielt um Israel und so. Und wenn ich das höre, denke ich mir, nein, das ist der falsche Weg. Wir wollen nicht noch mehr über irgendwelche Sachen diskutieren auf der Straße. Also wenn wir jetzt auch noch Somalia und Rwanda und Jemen auf der Straße ausfechten, dann ist es nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis in Podcastgesprächen die Frage ist, ja, und wo ist jetzt die Aufregung zu so und so. Es gibt halt manchmal Sachen, an denen... Ich will jetzt nicht kristallisiert sagen, weil das ist ja mein neubesetzter Grundbegriff, aber an denen, die die erregen haben, so besondere Subkultane, irgendwas und so weiter. Und dann werden die besonders diskutiert. Und da würde ich sagen, wenn man sich prüft und denkt, das ist irgendwie komisch, ich verstehe nicht genau, warum sie diskutieren. Lass sie diskutieren. Es ist jetzt keine Gegenräte erforderlich. Deutschland ist gigantisch groß. Jede Schule hat inzwischen irgendeine Jugendhilfe oder so. Wenn man dahingeht, hat man genauso viele Probleme. Also man könnte sich jetzt überall einmischen und einfach und so weiter. Das haben wir in Amerika auch. Da werden ja die Lehrer und so weiter von irgendwelchen Schoolboards bestellt. Und über die Schoolboards haben dann die Eltern Einflüsse. Also gibt es da so ein paar Eltern, die manche Themen einfach krass politisieren, dann skandalisieren und am Ende funktioniert gar nichts mehr. Beim Thema Gaza sitzen plötzlich die Vorsitzenden dieser Ausschüsse, also dieser Leistung, Leitungsausschüsse der verschiedenen Unis vorm Kongress, kriegen dort Fragen, die sie nicht so beantworten, wie die popularisierte Öffentlichkeit das beantwortet haben möchte und werden alle gefeuert. Einfach nur, weil so Stimmung im Raum ist. Also wenn irgendwo Diskussionen stattfinden und man muss sich nicht beteiligen, einfach nicht beteiligen, einfach Sachen ignorieren.
Also falls das jetzt zu schwach klingt, was ich sage. Ich meine jetzt auch nicht, dass ich jetzt von jedem Mal einen Poster zu erwarte. Ich beteilige mich grundsätzlich an solchen Dingen nicht. Ich habe keine Schwarze Kacke gepostet, ich habe auch kein, weiß ich nicht, was, Ceasefire Now gepostet und ich poste auch nichts zu Bad Ouenhausen oder zu sonst was. Das mache ich grundsätzlich nicht. Nur was auffällig ist, dass man bereit ist, bei manchen Dingen große politische Ableitungen zu machen und bei den anderen überlässt man die politischen Ableitungen nur den Rechten und was die sagen, wissen wir alle, was dann da kommt. Und wem die die Schuld in die Schuhe schieben, nämlich allen Migranten dann oder allen Leuten, die sie als Migranten betrachten wollen. Wenn ich aber selbst gar nichts dazu zu sagen weise und dann am Ende noch sich Leute sogar dazu versteigen und sagen, na ja, das Problem gibt es in dem Sinne gar nicht, das ist von Rechten gemacht, dann würde ich sagen, das kann auch nicht die Lösung sein. Denn solche Geschichten sind welche, die groß rezipiert werden. Und wenn das nicht aufgegriffen wird, man kann da nicht ignorieren. Das ist ja was anderes. Also hier haben wir ja beim Neust-Konflikt eine sehr, sehr starke deutsche Verwicklung in die Sache aus, sowohl historisch als auch aktuell politisch.
Das Apelle im Raum stehen zu mehr Protest, mehr Aufregung. Warum regt sich jemand dazu nicht aus? Wo sind die Bekenntnisse? Ich will es mal anders formulieren.
Ich würde sagen, man kann es vielleicht mit Sylt ein bisschen runter drosseln, dass man nicht völlig hyperventiliert über eine Woche hinweg ist.
Da ist aber jetzt die Frage, wem sagst du das? Denn bei Sylt hat sich Armin Laschet als ehemaliger Kanzlerkandidat geäußert und gesagt, ich finde es gut, dass die alle ihren Job verloren haben. Die amtierende Bundestagspräsidentin hatte gesagt, hier sollte das Strafmaß ausgeschöpft werden, fünf Jahre Haft für solche Sachen. Ja, also an dem Punkt, klar können wir jetzt so einen Appell machen, Leute irgendwie und so weiter, Twitter doch mal weniger. Aber hier haben sich ja wirklich die Staatsspitzen, die politischen Verantwortlichen aufstachen lassen zu irgendwelchen Kommentaren, die ihrerseits dann wieder Leute in die Diskussion brachten. Das war natürlich völlig daneben. So wie ich das mitbekommen habe, wir haben dieses Sylt-Video gesehen. Der erste Blick, so wie wir auch bei Trump und Biden eben betont haben, dieser rein visuelle Blick, ist ja super entscheidend. Wir haben dort reiche Leute gesehen, dann stellen wir fest, das sind irgendwelche Halbtagsangestellten bei Influencern und so weiter. Wenn es dann heißt, Freude, die haben ihren Job verloren, tun die mir auch ehrlich gesagt leid. Wir wissen alle, wie das ist. Dann läuft halt so ein Lied und man singt das Bild und grinst dann noch so in die Kamera. Da denkt sich nichts dabei, keine Ahnung.
Nee, nee, also jetzt fängst du ja an das zu verhablosen. Das war ja nicht mein Ansinn. Also, dass die dieses Lied nicht einfach nur mal so mitsingen und die machen da ein Hitler-Bärchen und so weiter. Das ist ja nicht so, ich habe irgendwo ein Lied mitgesungen. Also, ich würde schon sagen, dass diese Gruppe und auch sicherlich symptomatisch für eine gewisse Klientel steht, dass man sagt, ja, die sind durchaus für rassistisches Gedankengut offen, was nicht bedeutet, dass die jetzt alle AfD-Wähler sind oder so. Nee, es ist eher so ein, ja, aber irgendwie sind es doch wohl Ausländer, die anderen, die nicht so aussehen wie ich.
Und da allerdings.
Und da sind wir ja bei dieser Wir-und-Sie-Unterscheidung, Wir-und-die-Anderen-Unterscheidung. Und deswegen kann man auch manche Ableitungen davon machen. Nur, wenn ich zugleich einen Fall habe, wie Bad Ouenhausen, wo wir also eine Art der Gewalt erleben, die wirklich eine Dimension der Vorstellung für mich zumindest sprengt, die in einer Rohheit daherkommt. Und man dazu aber dann von dem ganzen Lager, das sich jetzt nur mit Sylt beschäftigt hat, überhaupt nichts hört. Dann finde ich das verdächtig und es ist auch leicht zu erklären. Man kann natürlich seine Klischees, die man im Kopf hat von Rich Kids bestätigen, wenn da irgendwelche Leute mit Kashmir-Pulli und Polo-Hemd sitzen und ein rassistisches Lied kommen, das hat man Aya immer gedacht. Und während man hier, ja, was sagt man denn da eigentlich? Man will ja nicht falsche Ableitungen machen, aber indem man jetzt einfach sagt, ja, wir reden gar nicht drüber, dann ist es für mich etwas, was ich, weil ich ja glaube, dass diese Leute hinter Vogel nach und nach am Ende doch darüber reden, ist es doch etwas, was offenbar einen blinden Fleck im Diskurs veranschaulicht.
Lass uns das abschließen, weil wir haben noch sehr viele Themen heute, die wir behandeln müssen und die auch, sage ich ganz bewusst, viel wichtiger sind, weil sie eben auf so einer strukturellen Ebene hier wirklich Sachen zertrümmern, während manche Sachen halt so auf Gesprächsebene stattfinden. Aber zwei Sachen. Mich haben ja zuletzt zwei Sachen wirklich verändert im Denken. Was ich nachhaltig merke, das eine ist das Kristallisieren, also dieser Wunsch, wenn politische Diskussionen laufen, es von der emotionalen Ebene auf die erste pragmatische heruntertransferieren. Ich habe das ja im Salon versucht, es ein bisschen spielerisch vorzustellen. Wir werden das sehr übend machen bei vielen Sachen, aber wenn jemand sagt, wir sollen hier Remigration machen und so weiter, dann so wie Mafalani da sitzen und sagen, was bedeutet das denn? Wir schieben 25 Millionen Menschen ab. Wie sieht es dann aus im Krankenhaus? Wie sieht es dann aus in der Schule? Ganz konkret wissen, nicht irgendwelche Sachen fühlen. Das zweite ist dieser immer wiederkehrende Gesprächsanlass, weil der Rassismus im Spiel ist. Nach der Lektüre von Gilda Sahebis Buch habe ich mein Denken da wirklich grundlegend geändert, denn ich finde fast alles, was man im politischen Diskurs sieht, ist rassistisch.
Alles.
Die Frage ist nur, wenn man das anmerkt, meint man das dann vorwurfsvoll oder wie Sahebi, dass man sagt, das steckt einfach in der Natur des Menschen drinnen und das ist immer zu bändigen. Wir unterscheiden uns von anderen. Wir können auch nicht acht Milliarden Menschen übersehen, also überspannen in unserer Argumentation, dieser Universalismus aufs Ultimative getrimmt ist ein Desiderat, ein Wunsch. Den wollen wir immer transportieren. Deswegen auch diese ganze Kantsche Philosophie, die ist eigentlich schon 7000 Jahre alt. Warum ist sie immer noch aktuell? Warum sitzt Brecht jetzt in einem Interview und sagt, ich halte mich da an Kant, weil wir es immer wieder aktualisieren müssen. Also wenn irgendwer auch nur sagt, Migration begrenzen, ist das Rassismus. Und zwar nicht vorwurfsvoll gemeint, sondern nur als Hinweis, das bringt keine Lösung. Wir müssen das hier kristallisieren. Die Probleme sind woanders. Wenn also, wie ich jetzt höre, in Bad Oeynhausen ein Syrer jemand anderen verprügelt hat, dann gibt es da ganz viele Sachen, die wir beachten müssen. Sehr viele Opfer politischer Gewalt sind AfD-Abgeordnete. Sehr viele Opfer ausländischer Gewalt sind Ausländer. So, in dem Falle ist der Täter ein Ausländer. Wenn wir uns diesen Fall dann wirklich anschauen, es gibt eine juristische Aufarbeitung, schon von Staatswegen bei solchen Sachen, wenn wir das jetzt abwarten, in einem Jahr auf diesen Fall gucken, wie prägend für die Erklärung, was da vorgefallen ist, wird es sein, dass der junge Mann aus Syrien kommt? Wie prägend werden andere Merkmale sein? Diese Abwägungen kann man dann alle machen. Und selbst wenn es krass prägend ist, dass er aus Syrien kommt, ziehen wir dann die Diagnose-Gesellschaft, Franz Uschretzky, den Schluss, ja, das ist ja klar, alle Syrer sind doch Mörder.
Eben nicht, aber das wird ja gerade von den Rechten gemacht.
Ja, genau.
Und deswegen sage ich ja, deswegen darf man ja nicht jetzt von der anderen Seite einfach sagen, wir tun so, als gäbe es das Thema nicht.
Genau, ich habe leider weder den Vorfall noch viel oder wenig Aufregung es dann aus der Zeit nach.
Und de facto ist es ja so, dass fast alle Syrer, die hier leben, sowas nicht machen. Und das heißt ja erst mal was. Und da muss ich aber zugleich sagen, es gibt aber offenbar irgendwelche Missstände, die vorhanden sind, denn sonst könnte es ja nicht sein, dass eine solche Tat geschieht.
Irgendwas wird schon vorgefallen sein, genau. Die Deviance des menschlichen Verhaltens gehört zum menschlichen Verhalten, gerade in größeren Zusammenhängen und Bad Oeynhausen. Von uns in Frankfurt aus müssten wir durch ganz Hessen fahren und dann durch ganz Nordrhein-Westfalen, um da anzukommen. Das liegt ganz im Norden. Wir fahren also, wenn wir nur rechts und links jeweils 100 Kilometer betrachten, fahren wir an 30 Millionen Menschen vorbei, bevor wir zu diesem einen devianten Fall kommen, über den wir dann reden. Also die Friedfertigkeit der 30, 40 Millionen Menschen, die wir da einfach haben links liegen lassen, kann man auch reinholen in so eine Diskussion.
Aber das muss man machen. Also darüber muss man ja reden. Also man muss nicht sagen, Bad Oeynausen ist überall. Das wäre das, was die Rechten jetzt gerne machen. Die sagen, draußen ist Bürgerkrieg. Wir müssen euch davor beschützen. Aber man muss ja genau diesen Zusammenhang dann darstellen und muss das aber auch in aller Sensibilität tun, denn das hilft dem Opfer und hilft den Angehörigen nicht, wenn man sagt, aber die anderen 40 Millionen waren friedlich. Sondern man muss auch ein konkretes Problem versuchen, auszumachen. Und ich bin in den Fallen nicht eingerichtet. Ich kenne ja die Umstände nicht in dem Sinne. Ich habe Pressemeldungen gelesen, aber dass man es auswendet und nicht als solches sieht, genauso auch dieser Messermord an den Polizisten, der stattgefunden hat, das hat ja auch möglicherweise eine politische Dimension. Also bei Sylt ist man sofort bereit zu politisieren. Und ich pfeife dich ja hier direkt zurecht, sobald du sagst, die haben da ein Lied mitgekrölt.
Das ist das, was ich gesehen habe.
Wir müssen das politisch ableiten, das finde ich schon. Nur hier muss man das vielleicht auch. Und wenn dies zum Beispiel in Zusammenhang stünde mit einem fundamentalistischen Islamismus, dann muss es auch so benannt werden. Und man kann nicht immer so tun, als gäbe es das überhaupt gar nicht. Es wird von den Rechten großgemacht, weil die davon sich Wählerstimmen erhoffen. Aber man kann auch nicht einfach sagen, es gibt das nicht.
Wer sagt das denn? Es gibt das nicht.
Ich bin noch nicht... Man kann es daran sehen, dass es von ganz vielen Seiten sehr gerne gar nicht thematisiert wird. Und ich finde, da kann man schon, ich will niemanden aufrufen, irgendwelche Posts zu machen.
Bei Dürnhausen habe ich zuletzt gehört, als ich in Bielefeld studiert habe.
Ich will jetzt nicht dazu aufwachen, aber es ist auffällig, dass zu solchen Taten keine Posts von ganz vielen, die sonst immer zu solchen Dingen posten, stattfinden. Und das ist für mich nur etwas, was ich erlebe. Und ich merke ja selbst, wie ich hier mit Worten ringe, dass es offenbar sehr viel schwerer fällt, das zu mehr thematisieren, wenn wir vielleicht nochmal was zu Sylt sagen können.
Du hast das jetzt problematisiert, weil sehr viele Leute zu sehr vielen anderen Themen sich äußern. Ich möchte das problematisieren nicht, weil sie sich dann nicht zu Bad Oeynhausen äußern, sondern weil sie sich zu den anderen Themen äußern. Haltet doch einfach mal alle die Fresse. Löscht eure Twitter-Accounts. Das ist doch nicht mehr erträglich. Ich kriege mittlerweile Push-Nachrichten, weil Julian Reichelt irgendwas auf Nios gepostet hat. Auf dem Neuen Zwanziger-Account. Der Neuen Zwanziger-Account hat zwei Follower. Du und ich. Und irgendwer auf der Welt, Elon Musk, entscheidet, es sollte einen Algorithmus geben, der mich deswegen, weil wir da unsere Podcast-Dinger posten, darauf hinweist, dass ich mich jetzt auch noch zu den Sachen, die Julian Reichelt gemacht hat, äußern soll. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich bin da jetzt dagegen. Leute, schaltet den Fernseher aus. Fahrt Slalom um die Nachrichten. Hört Neuen Zwanziger. Wir zeigen euch am Ende des Monats, was wichtig ist. Aber diese allgemeinen Diskussionen, die in Deutschland gerade ablaufen, sind wirkliche Zeitverschwendung. Ihr verschwendet euer Leben. Kein Milliardär im Silicon Valley duldet es, dass seine Kinder so ein Medienverhalten haben. Niemand bei Verstand macht es. Schaltet aus. Wir kommen in Teufels Küche.
Habeck war in China.
Okay, Habeck war in China.
China ist nach den USA der zweitwichtigste Handelspartner Deutschlands. China ist aber auch systemischer Rivale. Entsprechend viel Fingerspitzengefühl fordert diese Reise von Wirtschaftsminister Habeck. Erst recht, weil Peking sauer ist wegen der Strafzölle auf chinesische Elektroautos. Die USA hatten hier den Anfang gemacht mit 100% Einfuhrzoll. Die EU-Kommission in Brüssel zog nach, ruht nun auch mit Zöllen bis zu 38%. Wie erwartet, schlägt China zurück, prüft wohl auch Strafzölle, zum Beispiel auf Schweinefleisch, was vor allem Spanien treffen könnte.
Willkommen im Handelskrieg. Habeck ist jetzt als Wirtschaftsminister dahingereist, einmal um deutsche Interessen zu vertreten, aber auch um europäische Interessen zu moderieren.
Wir haben jetzt hier gehört, China ist unser systemischer Rivale. Wir haben das Buch von Brecht dazu gelesen. Es ist wie dieses Buch vorher mit Wälzer, umso mehr Zeit ins Land geht, umso wichtiger nehme ich das. Weil erst jetzt höre ich ja umso sensibilisierter, was so der allgemeine Sprech ist. Und in China leben 400 Millionen Menschen im Rentenalter. Die Jugendarbeitslosigkeit liegt bei 25 Prozent oder so was. Das halbe Land steckt noch immer in Armut. Wir sind kein systemischer Rivale, sondern es ist wie Brecht schrieb, wir sind in einer globalen Schicksalsgemeinschaft um die großen Fragen der Menschlichkeit mit China. Und jeder, der davon abrückt und es anders sieht, muss das begründen. Und diese Begründung fand in diesem O-Ton hier nicht statt. Was für mich bedeutet, das ist kein akzeptabler, von gut und schlecht will ich gar nicht sagen, das ist kein akzeptabler Journalismus für die deutsche Wählerschaft. Ja, so kann man das nicht machen. Und ich will es ausdrücklich dazu sagen, wir haben jetzt alle auch das Gespräch von Brecht bei Tilo gesehen. Dieses, ich habe da einen Philosophen, der wirklich wichtige Anmerkungen macht und ich zwinge ihn die ganze Zeit in irgendwelche Kinkerlitzchen, die so dumm sind, wie wir sonst noch bei Trump gegen Biden sehen, wer kann hier weiter mit dem Golfschläger schlagen, ist auch völlig daneben. Und wir finden langsam keine Nische mehr, in der ordentlich diskutiert wird. Also wir sollten sehr froh sein, dass wir jemanden wie Brecht haben, der noch mal in ökonomischer Freiheit, die er sich erarbeitet hat, uns solche Themen überhaupt bearbeitet. Weil, so wie Trump sagte, ich kann ja auch jetzt Golf spielen gehen und so weiter, aber der richtet ja das Land zu Grunde und deswegen, die große Lüge muss ich ja jetzt hier rein. Das ist bei Brecht nicht so. Brecht sagt niemandem, ich will dein Kanzler sein, ich belüge dich jetzt, damit du mich wählst und so weiter und so fort. Dieser ganze Scheiß. Nein, Brecht macht ein Denkangebot. Das kann man lesen oder nicht. Dann kann man daran anschließen oder nicht. Wenn man das Buch nicht mag, einfach ignorieren. Man muss den Autor jetzt nicht in irgendwelche Pseudokontroversen reinziehen. Und ich sage das auch explizit, weil wir immer wieder Fragen bekommen von jungen Hörern. Wir haben sie jetzt getroffen. Sie war mit uns in der Oper. Wir haben sie in einer Case gesehen. Und dann kommt immer mal wieder die Frage. Ihr informiert uns jetzt so über die Sachen. Wie kann ich denn jetzt Sachen verändern? Und es tut mir dann immer im Herzen leid, zu sehen, wie engagiert diese jungen Leute sind und ihre eigene Biografie, die sie gestalten können, darüber verlieren und vergessen und übersehen. Ich gehe jetzt raus in die Welt und verändere irgendwas für alle. Nein, so falsch es klingt. Aber wenn jeder sich um sich selber kümmert und dann noch um eine weitere Person, dann ist schon ganz schön viel erreicht. Was nicht erreicht ist, wenn sich Leute irgendwie auf die Straße kleben und den ganzen Scheiß. Diese Bilanzen haben wir da jetzt gerade in Atroch gezogen. Hier muss jetzt ein neues Umdenken stattfinden. Begonnen bei Kritik an so einer Art von Journalismus. China ist nicht unsere systemische Rivale. Es kann sein, dass die politischen Klassen Kontroversen haben, aber da leben 1,4 Milliarden Menschen und hier leben 80 Millionen Menschen. Und die sind einfach nicht in systemischer Rivalität. Das ist einfach gelogen.
Die meisten von uns haben noch nie mit Chinesen längere Zeit gesprochen. Weiß nicht, ob das Rivalen sind, wenn ich die überhaupt nicht kenne.
Ja, wenn wir Rivalen sind, machen wir eine Fußball-EM. Aber nicht sowas. Nicht so ein Journalismus.
Einen Satz noch zu dieser Frage nach dem Engagement, das bekommt man häufig gestellt. Ich würde es jetzt nicht ganz so individualistisch beantworten. Ja, man muss sich um sich selbst kümmern. Und da kommt man auch nicht umhin. Also man kann sich nicht selbst verlieren darüber, dass man sich um andere kümmert. Damit ist am Ende niemandem geholfen. Nur, was ich schon glaube, ist, dass man sich über mehr als noch eine weitere Person verständigen kann, sondern man kann sich durchaus in kleineren Gruppen zusammenschließen, die irgendetwas machen. Also es gibt ja Vereine, die sich für einen besseren Wohnraum, für eine grünere Innenstadt, um sehr zu kleinere Dinge anzusprechen, also im Sinne klein von lokal, bis hin zu anderen Fragen, zum Beispiel Seenotrettung oder so, zusammenschließen. Und das geht schon. Nur ist es nicht ein Entweder-oder. Also es ist nicht ein, ich opfere mein Leben der grünen Innenstadt oder ich führe ein eigenes Leben. Sondern ich führe ein eigenes Leben und dazu gehört auch, dass ich mich für die Umwelt einsetze oder für irgendetwas anderes einsetze. Und das muss, glaube ich, zusammengedacht werden und dieses ausschließlich, ich gehe hinaus in die Welt und verändere sie, das ist etwas, was nur Enttäuschungen produzieren kann. Nun haben wir jetzt schon sehr gut herausgearbeitet, wie einfach dieses Regierungs-Sprechen vollkommen übernommen wird vom ZDF heute. Wir hören jetzt mal weiter in diesen Bericht rein.
Als Robert Habeck in Peking ankommt, macht er sich erst mal auf den Weg zu einem Treffen mit den Botschaftern der EU und verkündet danach seine Idee für eine europäische China-Strategie.
Das neudeutsche Wort ist immer Diversification, also eine breitere Aufstellung von Lieferketten, die Investitionen, die wir im Ausland tun, nicht alle nur in China vorzunehmen, sich, man muss es so hart sagen, von chinesischen Abhängigkeiten zu befreien.
Wozu die aktuellen Abhängigkeiten führen können, spürt er bei dieser Reise besonders. Denn es brodelt ein Handelsschreit. Ausgelöst, weil China E-Autos unrechtmäßig subventioniert haben soll. Brüssel droht mit Strafzöllen, Peking mit Gegenmaßnahmen. Sie könnten unter anderem deutsche Autobauer treffen, China ist mit ihr wichtigster Absatzmarkt. Es wächst die Sorge vor einem Handelskrieg.
Die Stimmung ist da schlecht und da hoffe ich mir natürlich, dass der Vizekanzler und Wirtschaftsminister jetzt hier hinkommt und auch ein klare Message sendet, dass Deutschland eben kein Interesse an diesen Zöllen hat.
Das war jetzt ein Herr von der Handelskammer. Nun, welche Sache finden wir eigentlich vor? USA und China befinden sich in so einer Systemrivalität, die ausgerufen wurde, aber vor allem von Trump und dann von Biden dankbar übernommen wurde. Jetzt will die EU sich dem anschließen, denn wir wissen Ursula von der Leyen ist da ganz auf Bidens Seite. Nun ist Habeck in einer eigenartigen Position, eigentlich einer dreifachen. Er soll jetzt die europäischen Interessen moderieren in China. Er soll aber auch die deutschen Wirtschaftsinteressen vertreten, die andere sind, denn da hat man kein Interesse an den Zöllen. Und sagen wir, es gibt sogar vier Ebenen. Die dritte Ebene ist, dass er jetzt seiner Partei zeigen muss, dass auch er Werte geleitete Außenpolitik machen kann. Genau, das ist das Vierte. Den Journalisten, und das hat schon wohl ziemlich gut funktioniert, alle haben sich wieder sofort verliebt in Habeck, den Journalisten muss er zeigen, dass er eigentlich der bessere Kanzler ist. Und die Frage ist dann, was geschieht hier eigentlich? Ich meine, wir sehen ihn in China, wie er da steht und was von Diversifizierungen erzählt und wie man sich von chinesischen Abhängigkeiten löst. Man kann ja nur hoffen, dass sie das in China nicht sehen. Denn eigentlich müsste er ja in China sagen, es waren wunderbare Gespräche, wir haben tolle Kooperation gemacht und wir haben einen wunderbaren Zukunftsplan für eine saubere Zukunft oder so etwas. Ja, sowas würde man eigentlich machen als Wirtschaftsminister. Aber nein, er erzählt da nur seinen Journalisten nochmal ganz deutlich, ja, es gibt diese Systemrevalität.
Ja, hier müsste man eigentlich auch auf dieser nonverbalen Ebene gibt es eine Gemeindepressekonferenz. Wenn nicht, wo kriegt er doch einen Raum, wo er das machen kann? Draußen auf der Straße. Draußen auf der Straße und so, ne? Solche Sachen müssen ja, das sind diese Haltungs- und Stilnoten, auf die die Chinesen ja so viel Wert legen.
Er ist also dort unterwegs und dann am späten Abend einen Achtungs-Erfolg.
Heute, nach den Gesprächen, die ich mit der chinesischen Regierung geführt habe, haben wir Kontakt mit der Europäischen Kommission aufgenommen. Ich habe mit dem Kommissar Dombrowski gesprochen und er wiederum hat uns nach seinen Gesprächen mit dem chinesischen Handelsminister informiert, dass es jetzt konkrete Verhandlungen geben soll. Das ist insofern neu und ich würde sogar sagen überraschend, als es die ganzen letzten Wochen nicht gelungen ist, in einen konkreten Verhandlungsfahrplan einzusteigen. Ich hatte über den Tag das Gefühl, dass die Botschaften, die ich senden wollte, die wir gesendet haben, immer mehr verstanden wurden. Wenn das dazu beigetragen hat, dass der europäische Kommissar und der chinesische Handelsminister so reden konnten, dass sie für die Zukunft auf einen konstruktiven Pfad einschwenken, dann wäre das gut.
Du weißt jetzt auch nicht, was Habeck da eigentlich gemacht hat. Also er hat in China dafür gesorgt, dass doch mal Europa und China wieder miteinander reden.
Dass es Gespräche gibt, bevor Europa endgültig entscheidet, was jetzt Sache ist.
Anfang Juli soll das ja kommen, mit diesem Zoll. Wir hören jetzt mal, wie Habeck das überhaupt einschätzt, was die EU da plant.
Die zweite Frage ist, es ist ja eine Struktur der chinesischen Wirtschaft, die auch dazu geführt hat, dass diese Zolle jetzt verhängt werden. Es ist ja kein Einzelfall, was dahinter steckt. Also wie viel ist da überhaupt zu machen am Ende?
Ja, das ist auch meine Beobachtung, beziehungsweise so würde ich die Lage insgesamt beschreiben. Die chinesische Gesellschaft ist darauf angewiesen, dass es Wachstum gibt. Dieses Wachstum ist durch einen großen Baumuum beispielsweise ausgelöst worden. Kann man hier in Shanghai sehen, es ist ziemlich viel gebaut worden. Also man kann diese Halbinsel ja nicht zweimal bebauen. Man muss ein anderes Wirtschaftsmodell sich überlegen. Und dieses Wirtschaftsmodell ist sehr stark exportorientiert. Das ist auch richtig und gut und soll so sein. Wir kommen aus Deutschland, ich bin der deutsche Wirtschaftsminister. Wer hätte etwas gegen eine leistungsfähige Exportwirtschaft? Nur wenn dieser Export leistungsfähig gemacht wird, indem er staatlich subventioniert wird, dass kein anderes Land auf einem fairen Wettbewerb, bei einem fairen Wettbewerb mithalten kann, dann gibt es ein Wettbewerbsproblem.
Also nicht nur versteht man nicht, was er sagt, sondern auch, was genau, also wie man dieses Problem jetzt im Kleinen lösen sollte. Subventionen müssten nachgewiesen werden, damit man die auf Welthandelsorganisationsebene mit entsprechenden Bestrafungen dann irgendwie ausgleichen kann. Also dann mit Zöllen höheren Gebühren bei der Einfuhr, die diese Subventionen ausgleichen. Nur diesen Nachweis kann man halt nicht erbringen. Es ist doch falsch.
Es ist auch nicht so, dass China das jetzt hier billiger anbietet, als sie das anderen Partnern anbieten oder so. Das ist nicht wahr.
Aber selbst wenn man es irgendwie nachweisen könnte, gibt es ja immer noch, finde ich, die Großwetterlagen, Klimadiskussion. Beim Klima sagen wir auch, klar, jetzt gerade verbraucht Deutschland so 2% des weltweiten Budgets an CO2, aber historisch gesehen ist die Verantwortung viel höher, weil wir ja schon Jahrzehnte länger und so weiter und so fort. Die europäische Wirtschaftsmacht, beginnend beim Kolonialismus und allen Einmischungen danach, beruht immer darauf, dass man mit politischem Interesse und auch so ein bisschen über den particularistischen Zaun eines Unternehmens hinausgrasen, Hermesbürgschaften und dieser ganze Kram, geh mal ins Ausland, wenn es scheitert, gleichen wir das aus und so. Und jetzt kommt man den Chinesen gegenüber und sagt, das ist aber alles verboten, das darf man gar nicht und so. Das ist doch verlogen.
Wir hatten in der Wirtschaftskrise eine Abwrackprämie.
Sowas zum Beispiel.
Was ist denn das anderes als eine Subvention der Autoindustrie? Jetzt kann man sagen, ja, damit konnte man aber noch ein anderes Auto kaufen. Ja, aber es hat vor allem die heimische Wirtschaft gestärkt.
Wir hatten sprichwörtlich eine Deutschland AG. Und kritisieren jetzt, dass es eine China AG gibt.
Ich lese vor aus dem Inflation Reduction Act, was da eigentlich der Fall ist. Da gibt es nämlich auch Voraussetzungen dafür, dass man E-Mobilität gefördert bekommt. Um aktuell in den Genuss der Gutschrift zu kommen, Auto, Motor und Sport ist das jetzt hier, muss es in Nordamerika montiert worden sein. Fragt man sich, was hat das mit E-Mobilität, ist man schon nicht für E-Mobilität, ist egal, wo das Ding zusammengeschraubt ist. Weiteren Vorgaben ab 2024 zufolge werden nur noch Modelle mit dem vollen Fördersatz subventioniert, wenn ihre Batteriekomponenten nicht aus einem als bedenklich angesehenen Land stammen. Als solche Länder gelten zum Beispiel China, Russland, Nordkorea oder der Iran. Von 2025 an gilt diese Vorgabe auch in Sachen Batterierohstoffe. Das heißt, man supportet die westliche Industrie, aber Klimawandel second. Das ist hier das Ding. Also wenn wir uns jetzt mal überlegen, die Merkel-Ära, du weißt ja gerne darauf hin, hat dafür gesorgt, dass mehr Menschen in Armut leben und es mehr Millionäre gibt. Deutlich mehr. 2008, ja doppelt so viel sogar. 2008 ist die Finanzkrise, Merkel und Steinbrück retten die Banken in einer großen Aktion, mit wie den anderen zusammen. China hatte auch mit der Krise zu kämpfen, kommt aber danach im Schluss, wir müssen also jetzt staatliche Investitionen hochfahren, um auch das Klimaproblem anzugehen. Denn bei denen meint Klima auch einfach, SMOK meint, dass die Leute kaum Luft haben zum Atmen.
Wir haben diese Bilder aus Peking und so weiter, deswegen diese Elektromobilität.
So, und dann gehen sie dazu über, was machen wir? Wir machen eine Niedrigzinspolitik und hoffen mal, dass schon irgendwie die Investitionen an die richtige Stelle rücken. Was passiert?
Nichts.
Die deutsche Autoindustrie baut jetzt inzwischen irgendwelche Luxuslimousinen, die so PS-stark sind, dass man sie nur getrostelt fahren kann, dass die nie anders irgendwo losgelassen werden, mit irgendwelchen verrückten Specials, die es noch gibt.
Zwei Tonnen zu schwer pro Auto.
Ja, und man hat es jetzt sogar noch geschafft, um noch an eine E-Förderung ranzukommen. Also wenn du jetzt so eine Luxuslimousine fährst mit verlängertem Radstand, gibt es noch eine E-Förderung, wenn da noch ein Teil mit Batteriebetrieb ist.
Wenn die Bremskraft aufgefangen wird in einem kleinen Akku fürs Licht, dann...
Da wird nochmal, also das subventionieren wir. Wir subventionieren sogar noch Luxuslimousinen. Was macht China? China sagt, wir brauchen E-Mobilität, Busse und so weiter, aber auch Autos, denn China ist ein Land, das nicht nur mit Gleisen befahren werden kann. Autos, wer kann sich eigentlich Autos leisten? Die deutsche Autoindustrie geht von Leuten aus, die 50.000 Euro für ein Auto ausgeben. China sagt, nee, wir brauchen vor allem E-Mobilität, Autos unter 20.000, die zuverlässig sind. Die deutsche Autoindustrie ignoriert das, die französische auch, die westliche generell ignoriert das. China geht darauf ein. Das ist ja auch eine sehr große Industrieentscheidung gewesen. Es ist ja nicht einfach die Partei lenkt das alles. Das ist ja vollkommener Unsinn. Und dann, was du schon angesprochen hast, worum geht es denn jetzt eigentlich? Ist der Klimawandel jetzt unsere primäre Aufgabe, um die wir uns kümmern müssen? Wenn die Antwort darauf Ja ist, dann kann man sagen, es gibt keine Überkapazitäten, sondern wir haben offenbar viel zu wenig E-Mobilität, viel zu wenig Photovoltaikanlagen. Wenn wir aber sagen, na Klimawandel ist schon ganz wichtig, aber nicht so wichtig. Viel wichtiger sind geopolitische nationale Interessen im Sinne von wer ist der Stärkere. Dann kann ich sagen, scheiß auf Klimawandel, die sollen mit den Autos draußen bleiben. Und genau das passiert ja jetzt gerade.
Ja, ich bin über ein TikTok-Video gestolpert, das ich jetzt per Plexity mir inhaltlich nochmal aufrufe, mit der Frage, konnte ein Audi mit Verbrennermotor mal mehr als 4.000 Kilometer fahren? Das ist ja gerade die technischen Errungenschaften, die Deutschland so gemacht hat. Jedes zweite verkaufte Auto ist ein SUV und alle wiegen doppelt so viel. Und der Rebound-Effekt, die Motoren werden ein bisschen effektiver, aber das Auto ist doppelt so schwer, also verbraucht es am Ende mehr. Stellt sich raus, im Jahr 1989 führt der Audi eine bemerkenswerte Werbeaktion durch. Sie sind mit einem Audi 100 durch Europa gefahren. Bedingung war eine Tankfüllung. Sie haben zum Beispiel eine Route ausgewählt mit wenig Verkehr und kaum Steigung. Sie haben Seitenspiegel abgebaut für Luftwiderstand. Die Reifen wurden übermäßig aufgepumpt, um den Rollwiderstand zu reduzieren. Also würde ich jetzt so sagen, das sind alles so Sachen, die kann man auch noch mal technisch optimieren und daraus Serienmodelle machen. Sie sind damals mit diesem Audi 100 mit einer Tankfüllung 4.818 Kilometer weit gekommen. Hätte man in die Richtung optimiert, hätten wir gar keine Diskussion zum E-Mobilität, sondern da könnten wir einfach mit so Autos, die ein Zehntel des Verbrauchens. Durchschnittsgeschwindigkeit, 60 kmh. Wenn man heute auf die Autobahn schaut, klar, wir wollen alle irgendwann mal ankommen. Aber was spricht dagegen, LKWs, Stromlinien, förmig zu machen und die mit 50 kmh über die Autobahn zu schicken? Wird für sie halt die linke Spur reserviert, sodass es einfach klar ist? Da stören sie nun wirklich niemanden. Alle anderen fahren so. Es gibt so viele Sachen, auf die man hin optimieren könnte. Man hat in die völlig falsche Richtung hin optimiert und er erklärt jetzt eine systemische Rivalität, während die Chinesen wirkliche soziale und ökonomische Probleme lösen. Und nicht wie wir, solche ästhetischen. Also es ist grotesk, wie diskutiert wird. Und dank Precht wird mir das klar am Kopf. Wie umgedacht hier eigentlich werden muss?
Wir hören jetzt Franz 24, da wird Li Qiang zitiert. Er ist im Sommerlager von Davos, also vom World Economics Forum. Ja, haben wir diesen Monat gar nichts mitbekommen. Spielt auch keine große Rolle, aber hier mal ein Auszug.
China's Premier Li Qiang spoke about this this Tuesday in Dalian in China during the World Economic Forum taking place there, arguing that China's production of green technologies meets domestic demand and is a boon for global supply, adding that any advantages Chinese producers have are, quote, competitive advantages, not unfair ones.
Wir können nicht unseren Pace in der grünen Transition im Exchange für kurze-Term-Ekonomik-Wachstum verhindern, sondern auch den Protektionismus in der Name der grünen Entwicklung oder der Umweltversorgung.
Worum es ja gehen muss, ist, dass man klar erkennt, auch dieser Mann, der Premierminister Chinas, hat geopolitische Absichten und vertritt die Interessen seines Staates. Aber wir haben doch eigentlich diese Idee, dass wir alle für das Klima verantwortlich sind, die einen mehr, die anderen weniger, und dass wir alle entscheidend zusammenarbeiten müssen. Also man kann doch eigentlich nur über den Weg des Klimas, oder am einfachsten über den Weg des Klimas, nur Kooperationen herstellen, wo sie wirklich gebraucht ist und wo auch der Wohlstand zugleich wächst. Also eine florierende chinesische Autoindustrie mag zwar jetzt gerade für Mercedes oder BMW ein größeres Problem sein, aber de facto ist es ja so, dass wo alles klimafreundlicher wird, auch dann wieder eine neue grüne Wirtschaft prosperieren kann. Wenn ich jetzt einfach nur sage, ich will meine überkommenden Modelle noch weiter festhalten, dann verzögert man eigentlich nur sein eigenes Abgleiten. Denn die Weltbedeutung kann man nicht mehr damit erlangen, dass man sagt, wir haben noch mal den Verbrennermotor noch mal optimiert, ihr werdet es nicht glauben, man kann noch mal 100 kmh schneller fahren.
Ja, vor allem das sind alles diese Autos, hier S-Klassen und so. Die Spitzenmodelle, auf die diese Konzerne auch so angewiesen sind, dass sie sich verkaufen, also die Dinger. Die werden selbst in Deutschland nicht von Privatleuten gekauft, sondern das läuft über dieses Firmleasing, dann kommt irgendwie die Mercedes-Benz Bank und macht diesen ganzen Kram und so.
Die kosten 200.000 Euro.
Die Welt hat gar kein Geld dafür. Die Welt will jetzt in Afrika vorwärtskommen. So brauchen die Leute jetzt Autos. Die kaufen niemals. Jetzt im großen Stile so, dass es für die Deutschen irrtragreich ist, irgendwelche Mercedes, Audis, BMWs oder so.
Auch hier ist es ja so. Wer kann ein Auto kaufen, das 50.000 Euro kostet? Wie lange will man das fahren, dass sich das für einen irgendwie rechnet? Die Autos sind generell einfach zu teuer. Der sogenannte Mittelklassewagen ist ein Oberschichtswagen. Der Mittelklassewagen ist nicht für... Was ist da Mittelklasse? Ist schon die Frage, aber wenn man jetzt verbeamteter Lehrer ist, kauft man sich so ein Auto schon nicht. Und da gibt es ja noch ganz viele, die sehr viel weniger verdienen. Und man wird über individuelle Mobilität nicht drum herum können, es sei denn, man wohnt in Frankfurt wie Stefan.
Ich kann hier ohne Führerschein leben, sonst wird das eher schwierig werden.
Und wir sehen ja auch an diesem Begriff Überkapazitäten. Die deutsche Autoindustrie produziert mehr als die Deutschen brauchen. Da sage ich jetzt, das ist aber schlimm mit diesen Überkapazitäten, das müssen wir denen aber mal abgewöhnen. Jetzt hören wir, die Chinesen wollen jetzt die Schweine importen, die vor allem aus Spanien kommen, wollen sie dann auch mit Zöllen belegen. Soll ich jetzt sagen, die Spanier produzieren offenbar Überkapazitäten. Naja, das ist Welthandel. Wir hören einen letzten Clip, denn es gibt jetzt so einen Deal von China und das ist natürlich toll, wie man jetzt einfach sagt, gut, die Deutschen wollen ihre alten Marken und Verbrenner und so. Dann machen wir denen doch jetzt mal so ein Angebot, das auch einen Habeck in die Pradoje bringt.
China ist aber auf die Frage nach, ob es möglich ist, in dieser Allianz eine Bedingung zu finden. Der deutsche Kommunalminister Robert Habeck hat mit seinem chinesischen Gegner am Sonntag in Beijing geschehen. Und laut Reports hat Beijing die Möglichkeit, dass die deutschen Luxury-Karrenmacher mit dem EU-Kommissionen in Brüssel mit dem EU-Kommissionen in Brüssel die Provisionen auf die Chinesischen EU-Importe.
Ich bin hier über ein Text gestolpert oder ein Interview mit Jens Südekum, geführt von Mark Schiritz und Kollegen. Und die Zusammenfassung, da kann man auch nur sagen, es ist im Grunde, weil Schiritz sich da so positiv, Südekum so positiv, ja das muss schon sein. Es geht um 700.000 Arbeitsplätze. Wir sollten nicht denselben Fehler machen wie bei der Solarindustrie, als wir zu spät die eigene Industrie produktionistisch gesichert haben und dann alles nach China abwanderte. Nur wenn man sich diese Argumente so anschaut, das ist ökonomischer struktureller Realismus. Hier wird einfach, Zölle sind Lenkungsinstrument. Damit machen wir Interessenpolitik. Da würde ich sagen, ja genau. So haben wir das hier auch diskutiert. Ursula von der Leyen kommt ins Amt, sagt wir brauchen einen Green Deal. Wie erreichen wir das? Dass Saarstahl jetzt auf Wasserstoff als Hitzequelle für die Stahlproduktion umstellt. Naja, wir müssen halt der Stahl, der von außerhalb kommt, Straf bezollen. Wir haben dann einen Ring um Europa. Und dann heißt es einfach, hier wird eine Klimaanpassung gezahlt. Und alles, was den Stahl billiger macht, weil noch mit Kohle und sonst wie hergestellt, wird halt einfach als Preis draufgeschlagen. Da wird also nicht mit Überkapazität oder die befluten uns oder irgendwas, sondern nein, wir haben des Ansinnen hier die Stahlproduktion umgestellt. Also hat das einen Preis für die Welt. Wenn in Europa entschieden wird, das so zu machen, hat das einen Preis. Und das sind aber ganz andere Argumentationen als wenn hier irgendwie systemische Rivale, da müssen wir mal dagegenhalten, aus Prinzip und die befluten uns und das ist Überkapazität, sollte es doch woanders verkaufen.
Vor allen Dingen ist ja momentan der Anteil chinesischer Autos noch wahnsinnig gering in der EU. Das mag sich ändern, nur das ist dann eine Sache, die liegt nicht bei den Investitionen, die da von chinesischer Seite getätigt wurde, sondern sicherlich auch daran, dass diese Autos eine gewisse Qualität haben und auch einen Preis, den Leute eher bereit sind zu zahlen. Und Kanada versucht ja jetzt auch, die chinesischen Autos auszudrängen, wo man erst sagen kann, naja, die Chinesen stehen da vor dem Beginn und da sieht man, es geht hier also um Staatsinteressen und es geht nicht mehr darum, dass man das Klima an den Mittelpunkt rückt. Von den Sozialdemokraten kommt ja auch nichts entscheidendes dazu.
Und damit würde ich überleiten. Wir können bei den Autos noch sagen, Autos kann man halt gut an der Grenze abfangen. Das geht bei sehr vielen anderen Gütern nicht. Wenn wir aber diese anderen Güter jetzt aufladen, mit so einem politischen Wunsch, die müssten wir auch mal so abfangen können, dann kommen wir in Teufels Küche. Weil dann sind die Maßnahmen so kompliziert, dass wir uns näher dieser schießenden Auseinandersetzung nähern. Weil dann kommt irgendwie so, ne, wir müssen hier eine Firewall einrichten, damit nicht die digitalen Services darüber schwappen und so weiter. Und dann wird's, so was ist alles brenzlig. Also ich bin total, wenn irgendwer auf der Welt ein billiges Auto herstellt. Ich hab mich das immer gefragt, als es immer hieß, ja, die Deutschen, die machen immer so, und dann leben die auf dem Defizit der anderen. Wo ich mir dachte, wo ist das Problem, wenn Deutschland jetzt an alle exportiert, die dann ein Handelsbilanzdefizit haben, weil im Hintergrund kann man sich auch einfach sagen, na ist doch schön, dass die chinesische Regierung für uns die Autos bezahlt, uns die Autos billiger macht.
Ja, so ist es ja.
Und das sollten wir doch eigentlich dankbar annehmen, oder? Statt uns zu beschweren, dass die Chinesen uns Autos anbieten, die 18.000 statt 23.000 Euro kosten. Ich geh da auch nicht in die Opern und sag, dass sie jetzt so eine Opern-Card haben und ich auf jede Karte, die ich kaufe, 30% Rabatt bekomme. Das ist doch bescheuert, das will ich gar nicht. Und so. Also so auf der Ebene. Sollen sie doch ihr Handelsbilanzdefizit verbuchen? Und ja, dann stehen wir halt bei China in der Kreide, in Anführungszeichen. Hauptsache, wir haben halt kostengünstige Mobilität.
Ja, oder man lässt sich dann herausfordern und sagen, okay, Challenge angenommen. Wir produzieren noch günstigere Autos. Oder produzieren Autos, die noch was anderes tolles können.
Wo ist der deutsche Ingenieursgeist?
Was du jetzt gerade deutlich machst, ist, wir Konsumenten profitieren doch davon. Also verstehen wir uns doch viel mehr jetzt mal wieder als Konsumenten.
Ich bin eigentlich in systemischer Revalität mit unserer Bundesregierung, die mir die E-Mobilität teurer macht.
Ja, richtig. Du sollst ja, und da ist ja dann auch schon so eine Moderationseinleitung für da, dich als Staatsbürger angerufen fühlen. Und nicht als Konsument.
Okay.
Weißt du, du sollst, wenn du jetzt durchs Geschäft gehst, sagen, oh, ist das mit der deutschen Staatsräson vereinbar?
Damit sind wir jetzt beim Thema Scholz, oder was?
Nein, eigentlich nicht, aber darum scheint es wohl zu gehen. Ja, Thema Scholz, es ist ein weiteres Trauerspiel, das ich hier mitbringe. Es gibt eine Institution, die heißt das Progressive Zentrum, das so ein bisschen Think Tank und Veranstaltung machen, die jedenfalls war dort Lea Ippie zu Gast. Das ist eine Philosophin, die hat auch ein sehr interessantes Buch über ihre eigene Kindheit und Jugend geschrieben. Frei heißt das über ihre Zeit in Albanien. Und sie hat also eine Unfreiheit erfahren, erlebt aber jetzt in einem westlichen Kapitalismus auch eigentlich keine Freiheit. Jedenfalls ist sie dort und diskutiert mit dem Kanzler. Also der Kanzler hat sich gedacht, ich setze mich jetzt mit einer Philosophin und Schriftstellerin und Sozialistin, wie sie sich selbst bezeichnet, auf ein Podium. Könnte ja interessant werden, denkt man. Und sie macht auch gleich zum Einstieg mal einen Witz. Ja, Lorenzo war der Bratenwurde von Machiavelli. Nun will sie über den Kapitalismus reden.
Ich denke, es geht um Kapitalismus.
Ja, beziehungsweise könnten wir sagen, was ja auffällig ist, und Veit Selk schildert es ja auch in dem Buch, ist, dass das Vertrauen in die Demokratie da nachlässt, wo der Kapitalismus ins Straucheln gerät. Also wo dauerhaft Krisen sind, wo nicht mehr dieses Wirtschaftswachstum wie ein Star ist, da merkt man, dass ich beides nicht mehr so gut miteinander verträge.
Es ist ja in Deutschland wirklich eine historisch einmalige Co-Evolution gewesen. 49 wird hier die Demokratie eingeführt und 55 beginnt das Wirtschaftswachstum. Das Wirtschaftswunder. Dass das bei den Leuten in die DNA einprogrammiert wurde, ist klar. Dass die Aussies dann heute anders wählen, ist auch klar, weil die haben genau diese Co-Evolution eben nicht mitgemacht.
Und diese Co-Evolution hat ja auch stattgefunden in anderen westlichen europäischen Ländern.
Große zweite Weltkriegsnachgeschichte.
Jetzt sagst du auch gerade Einmaligkeit. Heißt das, es kann sich nicht wiederholen? War das eine Laune der Geschichte? War das ein Zufall? Die Frage ist, hängen also Demokratie und Kapitalismus eigentlich gar nicht miteinander zusammen? Aber da sind die mal zusammengekommen.
Ja, das wäre so die Arbeitshypothese.
Sind die gar keine Geschwister?
Wir haben ja die größte Zerstörung Europas, die gleichzeitig die Lehre mitbrachte, wir müssen es jetzt politisch ganz anders machen. Also hat man es demokratisch gemacht. Und dann müsste man jetzt mit Historikern darüber streiten und sich Ökonomisches nochmal anschauen, ob diese Art der, wir öffnen es demokratisch und lassen damit eben auch Unternehmen machen. Also zur Demokratie gehört die Freiheit und das eben auch die unternehmerische. Dass es da schon einen Zusammenhang gibt, der auch strukturell begründbar ist und nicht einfach nur Zufallshistorie darstellt. Aber ich würde trotzdem unter Maßgabe, dass wir ja noch andere Regionen auf der Welt sehen und wie es anders funktioniert, gerade jetzt China, die nun mal den zentralen Zugriff auf alle unternehmerische Freiheit sich immer noch erlauben, politisch, und trotzdem Wirtschaftswachstum organisieren und vielleicht sogar unter Druck besser als wir gerade. In der Ansicht müsste man jetzt diskutieren eigentlich mit so jemandem wie Scholz, der am Hebel sitzt.
Wir hören aber vorher noch einmal Lea Epi.
Die Demokratie und Kapitalismus sind nicht kompatibel, sagt er.
Das ist ja noch die ganz alte SPD.
Ja, er wurde allerdings historisch dann schon ein bisschen schach gesetzt. Nicht schachmatt, aber schach vielleicht.
Wir hören uns jetzt die Argumentation von Scholz an.
Die Frage ist, ob wir die Demokratie entwickeln können, wenn man in einer Gesellschaft ohne Angst lebt, wie ein der berühmten Philosophen, als liberaler Demokratie, oder wenn man in solchen Situationen nicht lebt. Und die zweite Frage ist, ob es möglich ist, dass es unterschiedliche Modelle der Kapitalismus-Ekonomie gibt. Und einer ist das soziale Welfarestaat, das meine Partei betrifft. Und insbesondere die ehemaligen Leader unterstützen in der Entwicklung unserer Gesellschaft.
Scholz lehnt also einen sozialistischen Stil ab. Worum es ihm geht, ist, den Sozialstaat zu vertreten. Und diesen sozialstaatlichen Kapitalismus, von dem wir jetzt nicht so genau wissen, war das nur eine Laune der Geschichte oder ist das wirklich ein festes Band? Das ist etwas, was jetzt da auf dem Podium debattiert wird. Wir hören aber ganz kurz einen Ausschnitt aus einer Scholz-Rede jetzt vor wenigen Tagen im Bundestag.
Wir brauchen einen funktionsfähigen Kapitalismus in Europa, der die Wachstumsfinanzierung der Unternehmen zustande kriegt.
Wir sehen jetzt Wintmar Klatschen. Ich glaube, er jubelt FDP und CDU zu. Merz freut sich auch über diesen Satz. Er bunt es scheint ja offenbar darum zu gehen, dass Scholz nicht nur den Kapitalismus lobt als Wohlstandsmacher, sondern hier eigentlich implizit deutlich macht, der Kapitalismus muss das aus sich selbst heraus schaffen, dann zu investieren. Das heißt, das ist schon eine kleine Absage an jene in seiner Partei, die die Schuldenbremse gerne abschaffen würden.
Ja, dieser Satz in der Kürze, wie er ihn sagte, ist, finde ich, von allen gut zu finden. Die Frage ist dann, wie man ihn auslegt. Denn Elizabeth Warren hat auch gesagt, sie will mehr Kapitalismus, nur eben mit klaren oberen Untergrenzen. Nichts geht unter Mindestlohn. Und ab 100 Millionen oder so bezahlt man jedes Jahr 2% auf sein Vermögen, bis man unter 100 Millionen liegt. Also es wird nichts wirklich aufgezehrt, aber es wird abgeschöpft oben. Und dazwischen dann aber totale kapitalistische Freiheiten. Hauen und stechen.
Wir gucken mal, wie Scholz das so der Philosophin erklärt.
Das Globalisierung ist ein Vorteil für die Weltentwicklung. Und dass wir von den Augen, die wir in den 70er Jahren in dieser Frage hatten, weggehen müssen, oder als die Diskussion über den globalen Süden war, die gesagt hat, dass das ein Risiko für sie ist. Aber die Realität ist, dass Billionen Menschen all over die Welt in der Mittelklasse entstanden sind, besonders in Asien, aber nicht nur dort, sondern auch im Süden der Amerika, auch in Afrika. Und es ist eine gute Chance, dass das Weltmeer, das wir in der Mitte des Jahrhunderts sehen, mit 10 Billionen Menschen, ein Weltmeer wird, das möglicherweise eine Lebensstandard hat, die sehr ähnlich ist wie die, die wir hatten, sagen wir mal, 1950.
Naja, also die sind nicht alle in den Mittelstand aufgestiegen, sondern die sind aus dieser existenziellen Armut ausgehoben worden. Und das ist selbstverständlich eine große Leistung, die aber vor allem den asiatischen Staaten zuzurechten sind. Da ist jetzt nur zu sagen, und der Westen hat es nicht verhindert, denn es war ihm daran gelegen, jetzt ist ja gerade die Frage, wenn er das so beschreibt, ist der Westen nicht gerade dabei, das zu verhindern, dass genau dieser Prozess weitergeht, zum Beispiel durch einen Handelskrieg. Jetzt kommt er aber darauf zu sprechen, und da kommt man nicht umhin, wenn man sich kurz nach der Europawahl mit einer Philosophin trifft, auf diesen Rechtsruck einzugehen.
Und du siehst es in Finnland. Von außerhalb von Finnland fragen die Leute, ob sie Probleme haben. Du siehst es in Schweden. Das gleiche mit Norden, mit Dänemark, mit der Niederlande, mit Deutschland, mit Österreich, mit Schweden. Und das ist das Norden von Italien, um präzise zu sein. Wenn man auch in einer Familie von schwachen Menschen lebt. Das müssen wir verstehen. Aber es ist ein Welt, in dem es auch Industrialisierung gibt, in diesen Plätzen der Welt.
Also man kriegt das noch nicht so ganz zusammen, was er da beschreibt. Also die Globalisierung, es scheint darum zu gehen, denn die Globalisierung ist ein Erfolgsmodell, aber damit wächst die Welt näher zusammen. Also die, die dort an der Globalisierung so weit entfernt beteiligt sind.
Sind doch näher an uns herangerückt und er sagt dann Folgendes.
In gewisser Weise sagt er hier etwas sehr Ähnliches wie Precht, dass er sagt, deshalb weil andere auch jetzt eine wichtigere Rolle spielen, wird das als eine Unsicherheit wahrgenommen. Und das wiederum wissen die Rechten auszubeuten.
Vor allem sagt er ja The Success of the Globalization. Wir kennen ja eigentlich den Globalisierungsverlierer. Der wird jetzt plötzlich zum Globalisierungsgewinner gemacht, der aber sein Schicksal nicht versteht und deswegen verwirrt die Neurechtenwelt.
Ja, beziehungsweise ist die Frage, ob er uns als die Globalisierungsgewinner betrachtet oder ob er diejenigen, die jetzt aufgestiegen sind, als die Globalisierungsgewinner betrachtet und die Globalisierungsverlierer sind zwar die, die, wenn man sich mal die Löhne ansieht oder die Vermögensverluste ansieht, eigentlich die Reicheren sind, aber plötzlich nicht mehr so ganz reich sind, dass sie so weit weg sind von den anderen dort, dass das nie zusammenkommen kann. Lea Ippie sagt Folgendes.
And we know that inequality has been rising and that power differentials between the north and the south of the world put pressure then on countries in the north as well. Where again, it's not about developing social welfare states here and then hoping that globalization will trickle down and will produce the same effects elsewhere. It's about understanding that what is done here comes at the cost.
Das ist sehr gut. Auf dieses Ungleichheitsargument muss man immer wieder kommen, denn es ist so wirkmächtig und verschwindet aber immer so aus dem Blick. Es hat ja sehr viel mit nicht mehr absoluten Argumentationen, sondern eben mit Anmerkungen zu Relationen zu tun. Und mit Relativitätstheorien tun wir uns ja immer schwer, nicht nur in der Physik. Das ist dann immer nur so, versteht man alles nicht. Aber in der Ansicht ist das natürlich, jetzt können wir die ganze Diskussion noch mal von hinten aufziehen. Wenn das als Grundbegriff jetzt einmal da ist, Globalisierungsgewinner und Verlierer, wenn wir die bisher eingeteilt haben in, naja, es gibt die Herrenländer und dann die Vasallenstaaten und dann ist das halt die Werkbank und so weiter. Dann stellt man irgendwann fest, nee, also es gibt schon noch die Näherin in Bangladesch, aber die gehört jetzt nicht mehr dem reichen Amerikaner, sondern dem Schieneninhaber in China. Es ist sozusagen das selbe Ausbau- und Verhältnis, aber das Wir und Die passt nicht mehr. Also dann kommt alles durcheinander. Und dann muss man sich alle Relationen neu anschauen. Und in deren Sicht, ja, so wie immer, wenn man sagt, was ist der Unterschied zwischen Männern und Frauen, kann man drüber reden. Aber die Unterschiede innerhalb der Frauen sind halt größer als die Unterschiede per se zwischen Mann und Frau. Arm und Reich genauso, jung und alt genauso. Auf allen Themen holt einen das dann immer wieder ein. Nur sich auf Relativitätsargumente einzulassen ist natürlich superschwer. Da kannst du ja nicht mal einfach mit Zahlen argumentieren und so. Du musst ja immer beide Seiten betrachten. Und noch Veränderungen im Zeitverlauf.
Also es fordert uns alles einfach aus.
Denn du wirst nicht einen oder kaum einen von diesen finden, die heute in der Wirtschaft sind. Und ich nenne nur die bekanntesten, wie Google oder Tesla, oder was in den letzten Dekades passiert ist.
Na ja, man kann natürlich jetzt sagen, eine Enteignung ist schwierig. Und man kann auch betonen, dass die Firmen, die einst groß waren, heute abgelöst wurden durch andere. Jedoch kann man ja steuerlich schon etwas dafür tun, dass diese Firmen nicht zum Beispiel irgendwo in Steueroasen sich ansiedeln können. Man kann auch was dagegen tun, dass Kapitalerträge niedriger besteuert werden als Arbeitseinkommen. Also das sind ja alles Dinge, die wir jetzt anzusprechen von einem Sozialdemokraten, kommt aber nichts. Wir hören mal weiter.
Und die richtige Frage aus meiner Sicht ist, dass man eine sichere Perspektive für die Menschen in einem veränderten Welt hat. Sie geben ihnen Hoffnung, dass sie, die Menschen, die sich ähnlich sind, eine gute Zukunft haben werden.
Also Hoffnung kann er uns versprechen. Was machen wir damit? Wenig?
Und wenn wir diese bestimmten Diagnosen haben wollen, wird es alle in geopolitische Konflikte, in politischen Konflikten, in Kulturen oder in Religionen. Das alles hat Faktoren, die, obwohl sie wichtig sind, auf einen sehr wichtigen Teil der sozialistischen Tradition vermissen, die auch distributiven und materiellen Konflikte sind.
Sehr gut, schließt an alle Diskussionen an, die wir immer haben, solange wir in einem kapitalistischen System leben oder marktwirtschaftlich, ist ganz egal, solange wir so leben, wie wir jetzt leben, ist Inequality, Ungleichheit immer das zentrale Problem. Wir bräuchten im Grunde so eine Psychoanalyse, die sagt, egal mit welcher Diagnose du kommst, egal wie du dein Leiden beschreibst, die Ursache ist immer dieselbe, die Eltern. Und so müsste man hier auch. Egal mit welchen Problemen du gerade kommst, egal welches Thema hier ist, Migration, der schickt die ganzen Verbrecher, der ganze Kram, da hat ein Syrer jemanden erstochen, wie er immer. Breche es erstmal runter, welcher Ungleichheitsverhältnisse haben wir, welche Lebenschancen können hier wie oder nicht genutzt werden, wie es stellt sich das im Alltag da, woher kommt die Wut und so weiter.
Würdest du so weit gehen, dass du sagst, man kann alles darauf runterbrechen? Also der Psychoanalyse würden wir ja auch den Vorwurf machen, dass es vielleicht ein bisschen zu einfach ist, wenn man immer mit den Eltern sich beschäftigt nur. Und genauso würde ich auch sagen, ja es gibt Ungleichheit und das ist ein großes Phänomen, das auch ganz, ganz viel durchdringt über das Potmanier hinaus. Aber zum Beispiel bestialisch zu morden, Femizide zu verüben, andere Dinge dieser Art sind jetzt nicht über Ungleichheit gleich herzustellen oder aus der Welt zu schaffen.
Wir haben als Anlass Einzelfälle. Und dann suchen wir das strukturelle Argument. Und das finden wir aber nicht, weil wenn du jetzt sagst bestialisch morden, ja dann ist jemand eine Bestie gewesen. So, jetzt können wir natürlich danach gehen, die Menschen in Bestie noch nicht einzuteilen. Also man findet dann schon so ein paar. Nur ein strukturelles Phänomen sehen wir dann nicht. Wenn wir ein strukturelles Phänomen aber haben wollen und politische Entscheidungen können nun mal nur am strukturellen Phänomen rumdoktern, deswegen sind es ja politische Probleme und dann keine pädagogischen, persönlichen, was auch immer. Für die niederste Ebene der politischen Handlungsfähigkeit sind immer die ökonomischen Ungleichheitsargumente die wichtigen.
Also das sei bestimmt das Bewusstsein im Prinzip.
Ich will es mal historisch-theoretisch aufdröseln. Also wir haben eine ganz klare Entwicklung und die ist wirklich strukturell einfach einprogrammiert. Wir hatten zuerst eine ökonomische Ungleichheit. Menschen haben irgendwo ein Eigentum abgesteckt, haben das verteidigt. Es gab also eine ökonomische Ungleichheit, die dann zu Gewalt führte und diese Gewalt wurde politisch eingehegt. Wir haben Gewaltmonopole. Gewalt wurde nicht ausgemerzt, sondern man hat gesagt, wenn ihr jemanden zuschlägt, ist es der Polizist und wenn er sich rechtfertigen muss, dann nicht vor dem, den er verprügelt hat, sondern vor dem Staatsanwalt. So, also zuerst sind die ökonomischen Asymmetrien. Diese werden politisch eingefangen, führen aber ihrerseits wieder zu politischen Asymmetrien. Es gibt mächtige und nicht so mächtige. Das muss dann auch wieder eingehegt werden. Also hat man dann im Dritten da nochmal juristische draufgebaut und beim Rule of Law haben wir zwar einen Richter, aber der weiß von sich immer, ich bin nicht die letzte Instanz wie und so weiter und dann haben wir immer noch diesen Sonderfall, dass es dann doch so letzte Instanzen gibt. Weshalb man ja im amerikanischen Richterwesen immer von Judge spricht, außer beim Supreme Court, dort heißen sie Justice. Also wir übersetzen Richter mal mit der Richter, außer für diesen Posten, da nennt man sie quasi Gerechtigkeit, da nennt man den Begriff der Gerechtigkeit dafür. Und da kriegt man es halt nicht ausgemehrt. Aber die ökonomischen Ungleichheiten werden politisch eingefangen, weshalb immer wenn politische Fragen im Raume stehen, im Grunde Eigentumsverhältnisse, egal in welcher Verbriefung.
So kann ich das nachvollziehen. Ich würde nur unterstreichen wollen, dass es auch Probleme gibt, die nicht ökonomisch begründbar oder lösbar sind.
Genau und dann ist aber die Frage, sind es politische? Und da würde ich sagen, sehr häufig wahrscheinlich nicht.
Also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel fundamentalistisch in irgendeiner Richtung wäre.
Das sind juristische Probleme, weil dann gibt es Urteile darüber, wie wir mit diesen Leuten umgehen.
Richtig, aber das ist nichts mehr, was sich ökonomisch grundieren kann. Also in vielen Fällen zumindest nicht.
Ganz viel findet statt und entzieht sich dem politischen und dem ökonomischen und sie können trotzdem juristisch gefasst werden. Deshalb wir ja vom juristischen, also vom Rechtssystem, auch vom Immunsystem der Gesellschaft sprechen. Denn mit jeder kleinen Handlung, die man macht, kommt eine kleine Variation in die Welt. Und wenn diese Variation mal jenseits unserer Korridore liegt, dann wird das markiert und aussatiert. Der Täter wird vor Gericht gestellt, zurück in die Bahnen gebracht. Die Strafprozessordnung ist wichtiger als das Verbrechen. Wenn man die nicht einhält, ist das ein Verbrechen auch und so weiter. Und am Ende wird der Täter isoliert. Das ist ja der Sinn des Urteils. Die Welt weiß, egal ob ihr das anerkennt oder nicht, der normative Zwang gilt. Er ist verurteilt, er ist isoliert bis hin zu Haft.
Scholz macht sich diese Überlegungen nicht.
Wir müssen schauen, dass jeder eine gute Chance für eine sichere Entwicklung in seinem Leben hat.
Es kommt wieder zu einem Respektsbegriff. Ja, im Minimum-Wage, also der Mindestlohn wäre etwas, woran man wirklich festmachen kann, wenn er dann in einer entsprechenden Höhe wäre, was er nicht ist. Und damit hat man jetzt nur so das Allerniedrigste beseitigt.
Weil ich denke, dass diese Kritik uns eine Analyse der Gesellschaft als Gesellschaft gibt, die auch durch ökonomische Konflikte hergestellt wird.
Ja, sehr richtig. Wir haben es gerade angekündigt.
Ja, das müssen wir nochmal ausbuchstabieren. Denn der Appell da drin ist ja, liebe Linken, werdet Nationalisten. Denn ihr kommt am Nationalstaat als Akteur nicht vorbei.
Sie sagt ja gerade nicht. Sie sagt doch jetzt gerade, das Problem ist, dass die eigentlich ökonomischen und Ungleichheitsverhältnisse verhandelt werden jetzt als ein Konflikt zwischen den Nationen. Also das, was jetzt mit dem Handelsstreit stattfindet zwischen China und der EU. Darum ging es ja eben nicht in dieser nationalistischen Denkweise das zu tun, sondern jetzt zu sagen, wie kann man dann über das Thema Ungleichheit reden, ohne jetzt nur darüber zu reden, ja, aber wir bauen Fahrradwege in Peru.
Genau, deswegen ist mir ja wichtig, dass wir das jetzt nochmal reformulieren. Aber du hast jetzt gerade gesagt, wir sollen den Nationalstaat denken. Also wir haben ja Precht gelesen. Und Precht hat ja gesagt, es wird alles so kreuz und quer abstrahiert. Und dann haben wir noch so rausgelesen, sozusagen mehr in den Text reingelesen, als drin stand. Okay, wir erkennen jetzt an, global Handel der Nationalstaat und schafft damit besondere Freiheit für Unternehmen unter seinen Fittichen. Also eine ökonomische Freiheit kann gewährleistet werden, wenn eine höhere Instanz für Sicherheit sorgt. Und das ist der Nationalstaat. Precht hat ja dann auch im Gespräch nochmal gesagt, am Nationalstaat führt kein Weg vorbei. Was für mich jetzt bedeutet, wenn ich so einen Clip höre, und sie betont auch nochmal, ja die Rechten kapern so den Nationalstaat und bringen ihn so auf Konfrontationskurs. Ja, der Konfrontationskurs ist falsch, aber nicht das Kapern des Nationalstaats. Dann müssen jetzt die Linken den Nationalstaat kapern, um dann zu sagen, ne, wir sind nicht in systemischer Rivalität, sondern wir könnten das auch brüderlich in Gesprächen, die nicht auf Konfrontation getrimmt sind, in dem Sommer Davos klären. Aber am Nationalstaat kommen wir nicht vorbei.
Nur kommt man ja damit in eine Präduje, man muss ja dann sich in Einsätzen mit dem Nationalstaat, was man ja eigentlich nicht tun sollte. Denn aus der nationalstaatlichen Perspektive betrachtet war die Schaffung des größten Niedriglohnsektors Europas durch Gerhard Schröder absolut richtig. Aber das ist ja eine Perspektive, die man von Link jetzt links nicht einnehmen kann oder sollte. Das hat ja gerade die SPD so unglaubwürdig gemacht. Sondern man müsste ja jetzt etwas jenseits dieser nationalstaatlichen Interessen, die in eins gesetzt werden, wiederum mit Kapitalinteressen betrachten.
Das Wunder, das ja da drinsteckt, dass sich, sagen wir mal, 20.000 Kapitaleigner durchsetzen gegen 8 Millionen Menschen, die in diesem Niedriglohnsektor arbeiten. Das hat nichts mit dem Nationalstaat zu tun als Rahmen. Sondern das ist einfach, wie führen wir Diskussionen? Welche Rolle übernehmen die Medien? Wer kommt mit welchen Argumentationen? Da würde ich jetzt nicht den Nationalstaat immer. Das hat mit dem Nationalstaat gar nichts zu tun. Das ist so ein bisschen wie...
Aber der muss es ja umsetzen. Also am Ende muss ja eine Regierung dann so was wie die Agenda 2010 auf den Weg bringen.
Ja, aber wenn wir jetzt die Europäische Union etabliert hätten und den Nationalstaat entsprechend aufgelöst, dann würden wir sagen, die EU ist schuld, dass sich da die Mehrheiten nicht durchsetzen.
Das sollte ich deutlich machen, denn das unterscheidet mich auch nochmal. Oder was heißt unterscheidet mich? Vieles unterscheidet mich von denen. Aber das ist nochmal so eine Differenz, die aufzumachen ist gegenüber Volt. Volt macht das ganz interessant. Volt ist gegen dieses nationalstaatliche Denken. Aber die transferieren das nur auf die höhere Ebene und sagen, bitte die EU soll nationalstaatlich denken.
Das ist das Brechtilammer.
Aber das ist nicht internationalistisch gedacht. Und worum es, glaube ich, gehen muss, ist, dass wenn man sozialdemokratisch agiert, dass man zunächst mal die Bredouille erkennt, dass man zum einen Arbeiter vertritt. Und damit meine ich jetzt alles, was die Arbeitskraft verkaufen muss und Miete zahlen muss und so weiter. Und dass man zugleich aber angehalten ist, nationalstaatliche, das heißt Kapitalinteressen zu vertreten, also Autoindustrie und was weiß ich. Und dadurch ist man natürlich in einer permanenten Zwickmühle. Das kann man aber zunächst mal so benennen, und dann wird es schon mal deutlich. Hier wird hier von Scholz so getan, als, und wir hören da jetzt gleich noch ein sehr gutes Beispiel für, als würde er nur koordinieren, was ohnehin super Hand in Hand funktioniert. Und das ist nicht der Fall. Wir hören nochmal, wir kennen oder wir erinnern uns, so will ich es einleiten, an Christoph Möllers, der sagte, was ich an der AfD doch bewundere ist, dass sie noch an die Politik glaubt. Und da waren wir ja so verblüfft über diese Aussage. Epi vermisst auch das Politische.
Aber ich denke, dass wir kein europäisches Debatte über Politik haben, weil wir eigentlich keine Politik haben. Wir haben nur Politiker, wir haben die Politik verloren. Und das ist das Problem. Lass mich mal noch einmal sagen, Partei-Politik. Das heißt, politische Projekte, wie die Gesellschaft sich verändern sollte, im Hinblick auf die Krise, die wir verhandeln. Ich sehe keinen Verhandlung zwischen politischen Projekten. Und europäischen Parteien. Und ich sehe, dass es eine Art Narrative hat über Konflikte, über Kultur, über Zivilisationen.
Also wie sie das sagt, es gibt ja so ein politisches Projekt, das wir alle nicht mögen, das ist der Rechten. In Amerika wollen die Hälfte der Wähler Trump wählen. Und ich höre ausschließlich im Podcast, dass man dagegen ankämpfen muss, dass das ja gar nicht geht. Und nirgendwo gibt es ein Verständnis dafür, warum die das machen. Als würde man gegen so eine dunkle Masse irgendwie oder so ankämpfen. Und das verstehe ich einfach nicht. Und das fällt mir dann immer wieder auf, wenn ich solche Halbsätze irgendwie höre. Auch in Deutschland, 16% haben jetzt die AfD gewählt. Und zwar Menschen, die auf der Straße rumlaufen, in denselben Supermarkt gehen, mit denen wir reden können. Die können einfach fragen, warum die das machen. Und dann immer so, ja, das ist die dunkle Masse, gegen die müssen wir einfach ankämpfen.
Und die Art, wie man das Neoliberalismus nennen will, ich nenne es Kapitalismus in der neoliberalen Phase, hat Politik aus Gesellschaften ausgedreht, weil es sie mit Parteien verwechselt hat, die technokratisch-manageriert werden, in Leitungen, die nur durch Fragen des Charismas und diesen schlauen und unprinzipiellen Diskussionen über den Leader und den Parteien zu sein sind. Und das ganze Debate geht um nichts. Es gibt keine Substanz zu diesen Debatten.
Wir alle wissen, was sie meint.
Erinnere ich an deine Argumentation zur Schuldenbremse. Ja, der Bundestag kann prinzipiell alles entscheiden. Und wir kritisieren, dass er immer nur so ganz eng fernstern, ob jetzt der Mindestlohn 12,40 Euro oder 60 Euro oder so und dann wie die Mindestlohnkommission da beauftragt wird. Oder eben er ist nicht mehr dafür zuständig, sondern hat das schon aus der Hand gegeben. Könnte er alles zurückholen? Kann alles selber machen, nur der Bundestag könnte dann halt wirklich über alles bestimmen. Und wenn dann der Wind falsch weht, ist schlecht.
Scholz probiert es mit einem Scherz.
Let me answer as a technocratic manager. The question is, what do we understand as politics? Is there politics that are going to questions that are more near to what we can reach? Or is it only starting when it's far away? So my view is that there is a lot of politics that will change people's life. We could discuss about and which are different between the parties on the national level as also on the European level. And we have to develop these questions and discuss them and they will be part of our activities.
Jetzt hätte man ja gerne mal ein Beispiel für diese Politik gehört, die nicht irgendwo in der Ferne liegt, die nicht allzu abstrakt ist. Dann denkt die Moderatorin sich, frage ich doch mal was Konkretes nach in der Hoffnung auf eine konkrete Antwort.
I mean, there's something pulling all this together when you talked about all of these things that are affecting this age of uncertainty with Ukraine and Gaza and the cost of living and climate crisis. And there's a particular issue, isn't there, with young people feeling alienated from mainstream politics and particularly voting for the far right. And I wonder if there's anything in what Lea says that you think could be relevant there.
Warum haben so viele junge Leute nichts gewählt? Scholz beginnt jetzt und es wird jetzt sehr zäh. Es wird jetzt sehr schlimm. Ich verspreche es, es wird ganz, ganz schlimm, aber wir müssen da einmal durchgehen.
They can probably take them longer to afford somewhere to live than their grandparents.
No, I think that it is not surprising that we will find every political position between young people you find between older people.
Okay, das ist doch der reine Wahnsinn. Die Moderatorin sagt jetzt nochmal, ja, diese jungen Leute, die sind doch ärmer als die Eltern. Darauf geht er gar nicht ein. Und dann sagt er, ja, wir hatten gedacht, die könnten vielleicht was völlig anderes tun. Und dann würde ich sagen, ja, die jungen Leute haben ja was ziemlich anderes getan. Du hast jetzt ein extremes Beispiel für Frankfurt gebracht. Aber wir können generell sehen, junge Wähler, und zwar 16 bis 24, haben zu etwa einem Viertel andere Parteien gewählt. Das meint also Parteien, die nicht zu dem Spektrum aus dem Bundestag gehören. Andere Parteien. Also die haben einzelne kleine Parteien sehr groß gemacht. Das heißt ja, ja, es mag ja sein, dass da auch noch 7 Prozent oder was die SPD wählen. Also nicht alle wählen alles anders als die Großeltern und Eltern. Aber es gibt ja offenbar eine große Differenz.
Es gab ja fast mehr sonstige Wähler als Nichtwähler. Das ist ja vorher undenkbar gewesen. Ich finde auch den Satzbau von ihm sehr problematisch. Sein Einstieg, es war falsch, zu glauben, die Jungen wählen anders als ihre Eltern. Weil da steckt ja so ein bisschen die Manufaktur dieser Entscheidung drin, warum man jetzt das eröffnet hat, auch den 16-Jährigen zu wählen. Ich würde grundsätzlich sagen, es ist natürlich immer richtig, die Jüngeren auch wählen zu lassen, unabhängig davon, was man glaubt, wie die wählen. Aber wenn nicht, dann nicht. Das steckt da so ein bisschen...
Kalkül auch bei den Grünen, denke ich, das nicht aufgegangen ist.
Weil ich bin ja dafür, dass wir wählen ab null Jahre. Wenn alte Menschen dement werden, wählt für sie der Betreuer. Ihm wird die Stimme nicht weggenommen. Wir nehmen sie Kindern aber weg. Und die Kinder haben alle Betreuer. Und deren Eltern, die diese Betreuerrolle einnehmen, wissen sehr genau, was gut für ihre Kinder ist. Wenn wir die ganzen Mütter ermächtigen, in Deutschland für ihre Kinder mitzuwählen, haben wir einen ganz anderen Wahlkampf. Deswegen will ich hier noch mal ein Plädoyer dafür machen. Lass die Eltern für ihre Kinder wählen. Und nicht nur die Rentner, die dann ihren Betreuer los schicken, dem sie nicht mal erklären können, was sie eigentlich mit ihrer CDU-Stimme vorhaben.
Ja, ich bin dagegen. Denn es ist ja nicht so, dass man nur für die Zukunft wählt, sondern man wählt auch für die Gegenwart. Und die gegenwärtigen herrschenden Verhältnisse sind dann von Leuten bestimmt, die einfach drei oder vier Stimmen haben aufgrund der Anzahl ihrer Kinder.
Wer hat denn die drei Kinder in Deutschland?
Du hast drei Kinder.
Wir kommen gleich auf die Großtablieren zurück.
Die gibt es ja. Du hast dann vier Stimmen, aber selbst wenn es nur ein oder zwei sind, andere haben dann mehr. Und die entscheiden dann auch mit über die Gegenwart. Also das heißt, du entscheidest über meine Gegenwart dann vierfach, während ich über deine Gegenwart nur einfach entscheide.
Wolfgang, ich habe eine Stimme für meine Gegenwart. Du hast eine Stimme für deine Gegenwart.
Aber deine Kinder werden ja nicht gefragt von mir, sondern du entscheidest ja dann für deine Kinder.
Ja, aber die sind ja trotzdem da.
Ja, aber du entscheidest für sie.
Ja, und? Ich entscheide sowieso für meine Kinder, alle möglichen Lebensentscheidungen, jeden Morgen. Wie viel Nutella kommt aufs Toast?
Also ich glaube, dass es tatsächlich schwierig wird.
Da wünsche ich mir jetzt mal Kommentare.
Ja, ja, ich bin sehr gespannt darauf.
Auf welcher Seite seid ihr hier? Wolfgangs oder meiner?
Ich würde sogar sagen, es wird sich wahrscheinlich gar nicht viel ändern. Also es ist ja nicht so, also wenn wir uns...
Jetzt haben wir nicht den Scholz-Fehler.
Nein, nein.
Dass man ja vorher und dann hat man aber... dass man das glaubt. Nein, nein, wir glauben ja gar nichts. Wir wollen nur man one vote.
Hast du Zahlen darüber, dass Familien eher klimapolitisch sinnvoll abstimmen? Hast du Zahlen dafür, dass Familien eher für eine Vermögenssteuer und Erbschaftssteuer sind? Ich würde behaupten, nein. Ich würde sogar so weit gehen, zu sagen...
Wolfgang, ich bekomme das Recht, zu sagen, ich beziehe mich auf Kant. Die Leute sollen wählen, was sie wählen.
Ich beziehe mich auf die Empirie, die du auch immer so hochhalten willst. Glaubst du wirklich, dass Menschen, die in der Familie sind und dann viel mehr Stimmen plötzlich zur Verfügung haben, diese Stimmen dafür einsetzen, dass hier von uns Dinge, die wir oft ansprechen, dann eher umgesetzt werden? Oder neigen nicht gerade Leute, die eine Familie haben, häufig dazu, einen gewissen Konservatismus zu pflegen? Wäre dein Vorschlag nicht einer, der der CDU zu ganz neuen Höhen verhelfen könnte?
Ja, jetzt lass mich mal antworten. Wenn in Thüringen sehr viele Menschen die AfD wählen wollen, bin ich der Meinung, sollten sie ihren AfD-Ministerpräsidenten kriegen. Wenn alte Menschen sagen, die Jungen sind mir egal, ich will nochmal Sturm und Drang für meine letzten 8 Jahre, ich wähle jetzt CDU. Sollen sie CDU kriegen? Wenn junge Familien sagen, das Familiengeld in Bayern ist eine gute Sache, ich wähle die CSU, dann sollen sie die CSU wählen. Ich möchte nicht, dass Eltern eine Stimme für ihre Kinder haben, um irgendetwas zu verhindern oder etwas zu ermöglichen. Ich habe da keine Hintergedanken. Mir geht es um das Prinzip. Und zwar egal, was dann inhaltlich passiert. Mir geht es um das Prinzip, es sind Menschen in der Welt und wir sagen, in der Demokratie hat jeder eine Stimme. Unabhängig davon, was er mit der macht. Und jetzt haben wir verschiedene Prinzipien, in denen wir diese Stimme übertragbar machen. Zum Beispiel in diesem Krankheitsfall. Eine Stimme wird nicht zurückgenommen. Wer lebt, wählt, darf wählen. Das kann dann ein Stellvertreter machen. In dem Fall der Betreuer. So, Kinder leben auch. Und die haben auch eine eigene Gegenwart. Und ich kann dir sagen, auch 7-Jährige führen sehr politische Diskussionen. Im Vergleich zu dem, was wir gerade bei diesen 80-Jährigen gesehen haben, sehr viel bessere, sehr viel wichtigere und von beiden Seiten sehr viel besser argumentierte politische Diskussionen.
Nach dem, was wir heute gesehen haben, bin ich bereit, das zu glauben.
Es gibt keinen Grund, einem 3-Jährigen, einer 1-Jährigen oder einem 7-Jährigen die politische Stimme zu verwirken. Und sei es nur, um ihn darauf vorzubereiten, hör mal zu, mein Sohn, die letzten drei Male hab ich für dich gewählt, jetzt bist du selber dran. Wollen wir darüber mal reden. Es gibt sehr viele Gründe dafür, ein Familienwahlrecht einzuführen. Wichtig ist mir nur dieses Prinzipielle. Eine lebende Person hat eine politische Stimme.
Aber es gibt dann, also am Ende gibt es ja eine Gerechtigkeit für jeden, der über 18 oder jetzt bei der Europawahl über 16 ist, darf wählen. Und diese Gerechtigkeit ist ja eine, wo die Gleichheit der Stimme geachtet wird. Es geht ja hier darum, dass Leute dann, nur weil sie Kinder haben, mehrere Stimmen bekommen. Und die Stimmen geben sie ja nicht, das ist ja nicht wie, ich lege 100 Euro für mein Kind monatlich an.
Nee, das ist ja nicht, die gibts ja aus.
Nein, ich sage, das ist ja nicht stellvertretend. Das ist ja nicht 100 Euro, die lege ich da an und die kriegt das Kind, wenn es mal groß ist. Sondern ich kann einfach meinen... Natürlich trau ich den Wählern nicht. Na wir haben Feit Selk gelesen, ich wäre ja völlig irre, wenn ich den Wähler vertraue.
Wir kommen gleich auf die Bildungserfolge.
Also es sieht überall düster aus und ich bin auch mittlerweile bereit zu sagen, wenn dieses Präsidentschaftsduell unter 7-Jährigen stattgefunden hätte, wäre es vernünftiger gelaufen.
Das wäre besser gewesen. Die Frage, gibt es Pudding zum Mittag oder nicht? Das sind übrigens Fragen für 4-Jährige. 7-Jährige stellen wirklich gute Fragen.
Ich habe ein Kinderbuch jetzt geschrieben, aus den Gründen, weil ich nicht sage, Kinder sind doof, sondern weil ich sage, Kinder sind vermutlich, gerade was solche Fragen wie Ungleichheit anbelangt, viel intelligenter. Also du musst nämlich jetzt jemanden, der schon siebenmal FDP gewählt hat, erst mal austreiben, darüber nachzudenken, dass es einfach richtig ist, dass von Generation zu Generation Vermögen wächst und weitergegeben wird. Während jetzt jemand, der zehn Jahre alt ist, diese ganze Ideologie noch gar nicht geschluckt hat und dann vielleicht sagt, das ist aber ungerecht. Warum hat denn dann plötzlich jetzt mehr, nur weil dessen Großvater vor 100 Jahren mal das und das gemacht hat? Also Kinder verstehen das intuitiv viel besser. Dann müsste man eher nochmal...
Ich würde sagen, wir lassen mal die Hörer entscheiden. Schickt gerne E-Mails, also schickt E-Mails. Auf der Seite haben wir unten mailatneuezwanziger.de. Diese E-Mails kriegen wir beide. Und wir lassen Claude das dann auswerten, wie das Stimmungsbild ist.
Okay, ich bin sehr gespannt darauf.
Also ihr könnt frei schreiben zum Thema. Ihr müsst nicht irgendwelche, wir sagen jetzt nicht, sagt ja, sagt nein oder so, sondern Claude macht das dann schon. Claude versteht euch nämlich alle. Schickt ganze Sätze zum Thema.
Gut, wie er es nicht machen sollte, das führen wir jetzt vor. Wir hören jetzt einen dreiminütigen Clip. Ich will es aber wirklich machen. Also Scholz hat jetzt angefangen zu sagen, ja, wir hatten geglaubt und es ist aber anders. Er ist aber noch nicht zu Ende mit seiner Rede. Er wurde jetzt schon darauf hingewiesen, ja, aber die jungen Leute sind ja auch nicht mehr so vermögend wie ihre Eltern oder Großeltern. Scholz sagt, wir müssen auch eigentlich mal konkret und das ist die Antwort.
We have to work on, we have to work very hard to give security to people about the future and we have to tackle all the relevant questions that are important for them. And this is on the one hand, I'd say, labour rights, it's a social welfare state, I will not come back to it because I mentioned it often enough in our debate, but it's also about security. Is there an international order we work for? Which is something you can rely on. I think, for instance, it would be very useful if we could establish again something like North-South Policy, which was established by Willy Brandt, which was really a big success, and we have to come back to it. We have to develop a policy that is equal-footed with the rising countries of the Global South, which have the best rights to be influential in the future. And we have to find a way to explain to our people that in the world of 10 billion, the European Union, with its then 400-500 million inhabitants, will be relevant. We will have a chance to defend what's important for us, democracy, rule of law, social market economy, just to name them, in this world. But it is not a threat for us that there is economically and politically successful 400 million nations of Indonesians or of Indians or of people from Thailand or the Philippines or from Vietnam, South Africa, Nigeria, or the young people. To develop a scenario for the future where we can live together in a good way is something which is, I think, progressive policy. We are following it. We have to react to all these strongmen and dictators coming up. And we have to organize security on both fields in developing international and in national order supporting it, which is relying on the idea of peace. But also making clear that we are strong enough that no one can conquer our territory.
Wir haben uns eben über beide lustig gemacht.
Not just looking to the politics, but I name them. They have to get some security from us that we will not let them alone. Das ist die Frage der Sicherheit in unseren Ländern. Es ist niemals eine Frage, dass man auf jeder Straße gehen kann, ohne Angst zu haben. Und es ist auch das gleiche, wenn wir die Frage der ökonomischen Entwicklung diskutieren. Und das muss eine Frage sein, die nicht ein unimportantes Aspekt der Zukunft ist.
Artifizierte Intelligenz, es wird doch einfach nur noch irgendwas rausgesprudelt.
Das, was ich gerade sagte, also diese soziologische, subkultane Grundlogik, wir haben ökonomische Ungleichheiten durch Eigentumsverteilung, wie auch immer, seit Jahrzehnten, also Zehntausenden Jahren in der Menschheit. Und haben dann immer versucht, politisch darauf zu antworten, um das wieder einzuhägen. Was ja einfach nur bedeutet, und das muss man da nicht verstehen, sondern jeder fühlt es. Christopher Nolan könnte einen Film darüber machen, es würde ihn so langweilen, weil es so einfach wäre, das darzustellen. Junge Menschen, von denen eben gesagt wurde, sie sind ärmer als ihre Eltern, und ihnen wird auch ein bisschen mitgeteilt, dass sich daran wahrscheinlich wenig ändert, weil ihr seht ja wie die Welt ist und so. Die fragen sich die ganze Zeit, ok, ökonomisch schaffe ich es nicht. Wie hilft mir die Politik jetzt aus der Patsche? Und die politische Antwort ist dann, ja, ich geh jetzt nochmal in meine Exetabelle. Wir hatten uns gestern in der Gremium-Sitzung 16 Punkte rausgeschrieben, die wir auf jeden Fall ansprechen wollten, im Sinne von, um euch zu verdeutlichen, dass wir für euch handeln, und dann kommt nichts bei rum. Und dann wird noch über irgendwas im Ausland und hier und da und Indonesia und so. Und da sitzen diese jungen Menschen da und verstehen, ach so, die Politik hat nichts für mich im Angebot, um diese ökonomischen Asymmetrien auszugleichen. Ich werde immer der ökonomische Verlierer bleiben, die Politik hilft mir hier nicht.
Punkt.
Das ist die Antwort, die er jetzt gegeben hat. Politik hat nichts für dich im Angebot. Sie versteht dein Problem nicht, sie möchte es nicht akzeptieren, dass das überhaupt problematisiert werden muss. Fertig.
Er könnte auch sagen, mir sind die jungen Menschen egal. Die Moderatorin fragt noch einmal nach.
Und du denkst, das sind größere Gefühle für die Jungen?
Ich denke, das ist der Junge, der das Führerrecht nicht unterstützt. Das ist mein Ansatz auf diese Frage. Also würde ich sagen, wir müssen diese Themen diskutieren und die Themen entwickeln und eine Perspektive entwickeln, in der die Dinge in die richtige Richtung laufen. Mein Ansatz an alle, und ich arbeite dafür, ja, wir werden eine unterschiedliche Intelligenz haben, es wird unsere Wirtschaften verändern, wir werden eine andere Art von Wohl haben, wir werden es kontrollieren können, dass wir nicht durch diese Systeme geruht sind, aber im Endeffekt wird es ein besseres Leben und wir arbeiten für das, und du wirst einen Job haben.
Diese Claude-Diskussion zum Thema gesellschaftlicher Zusammenhalt. Claude sagt Wohnbau, weil machbar keine internationalen Verstrickungen. Jeder muss wohnen. Es ist für jeden da. Es ist total praktikabel und so weiter. Wenn ich jetzt diese Antwort hier transkribiere und Claude als Nachfrage in diesem Thread sage, das ist die Antwort von Olaf Scholz, warum wird sie nicht funktionieren? Claude wird sagen, bist du bescheuert? Ich hab's doch oben geschrieben. Es steht doch alles schon drin. Wieso schickst du mir hier den dümmsten möglichen Kommentar von ach, das ist dein Kanzler? Ja, gut, okay.
Er sitzt einer Philosophin gegenüber und sagt, er will konkrete Politik. Wir können jetzt nicht nur über abstrakte Visionen sprechen und er bringt nicht eine einzige Sache mit, bei der er sagen kann, das haben wir jetzt im nächsten vor. Das wird den Jungen oder den Alten oder sonst wem helfen. Es gibt nichts, was er hat. Es ist nur die Verwaltung des Status, wo er dann noch gefragt wird, was er von Kias Dahmer hält. Den findet er auch toll. Da freut er sich darauf, weil er so ein anderer Techno kann. Was wir jetzt gerade sehr gut erleben können, ist, wie diese herrschenden Politiker, Biden, Scholz und andere, einfach signalisieren durch ihr Auftreten und ihr Sprechen. Ihr seid uns egal. Mir ist etwas aufgefallen in den Interviews, die Tilo mit Pranko Milanovic und Adam Touz geführt hat, dass beide da gefragt werden, was sie wählen. Und Milanovic sagt, ich habe eine Green Card. Ob er dann in Serbien wählt, ich habe vielleicht ein- oder zweimal gewählt, weiß ich nicht, wähle ich nicht. Dann wird Adam Touz dazu befragt. Adam Touz sagt, ich habe keine amerikanische Staatsbürgerschaft. Ich würde aber auch keinen der beiden wählen. Und über UK will ich gar nicht reden. Wen soll ich dann wählen? Ich kann doch nicht Kirsten Dahmer wählen. Also da sieht man eigentlich, dass die Leute, wenn sie zu der Elite da gehören, sagen, die haben ja kein Interesse an den Menschen.
Aber ich zeige jetzt auch kein dem gegenüber.
Ja, es ist, ich habe eben schon versucht, deutlich zu machen, wenn politische Diskussionen laufen, einfach nicht dazu äußern, es ignorieren, nicht mal rezipieren.
Ist jetzt schwierig, wenn man so einen Podcast macht.
Ja, aber dasselbe hier.
Es hat auch meine Laune gestern sehr runtergezogen, als ich das schneiden musste.
Ja, wenn jemand vor mir sitzt wie Precht, Tuz, Milanovic, wie heißt er Milanovic? Milanovic. Und die gehen nicht wählen, dann gehe ich nicht in Kontroverse, sondern versuche ich zu verstehen, warum die das nicht machen. Und alleine, wenn ich das jetzt in meinem Kopf durchdenke, sage ich mir, ich muss das gar nicht diskutieren. Das ist mir total logisch. Das ist mir total schlüssig.
Ja, nachdem, was wir jetzt hier alles gehört haben.
Ja, ich meine, diese Leute haben Einfluss über Publikum, das sie erreichen. Sie haben besondere Zugänge, um nochmal zu informieren. Leute, die wirklich handlungsfähig sind und so. Warum sollen die jetzt an einem Sonntag sich einreihen und mit 60 Millionen nochmal ihre eine Stimme abgeben? Es macht wirklich keinen Sinn. Und sehr viele Menschen denken so, und zwar völlig zu Recht, diese Politik kann meine ökonomischen Asymmetrien, die ich sehr genau beschreiben kann, nicht beantworten. Obwohl doch die Antwort so einfach wäre. So, wir hätten, also bei der Frage, die er jetzt, wir können ja mal durch simulieren, wir wären so der Kanzler, wir wissen jedes Jahr 800.000 Schulabgänger. Was könnte man für die machen, um den guten Start ins Leben zu erleichtern? Na ja, jeder kriegt einfach 100.000 Euro überwiesen. Fertig. Warum machen wir das nicht? Weil der Bundestag nicht entschieden hat, dass wir das machen. Gibt es noch einen anderen Grund? Keinen sinnvollen jedenfalls. Man kann auch ein paar Sachen irgendwie, keine Ahnung. Dann sind wir immer wieder bei so entweder Klassismus oder Rassismus. Wir gönnen eben irgendweben was nicht. Du gönnst ja die Kinder keine Wählerstimme. Man gönnt dann einfach dem Nachbar, der ist ja eh scheiße, der soll jetzt auch 100.000 Euro kriegen. Nö, dann lieber gar keiner, bevor der noch 100.000 Euro kriegt. Das ist das Einzige, also diese menschliche Natur, in der Sicht, Rutger Brechmann, im Grunde gut. Man könnte ja noch mal von einer utopistischen Sicht aus das durchdenken und dann feststellen, im Grunde schlecht. Wir gönnen es uns einfach nicht. Aber der Weg aus dieser ökonomischen, beobachteten Asymmetrie, ich fühle mich hier wirklich aussattiert. Ein deplorable, wie kriegt man jetzt hin, dass ich nicht Trump wähle, dass ich nicht Far-Right in Europa wähle. So schwer ist es eigentlich nicht.
Naja, aber was wir doch erleben, ist im Journalismus, dass da ganz ähnlich gesprochen wird. Man redet ja auch da über die jungen Leute als so eine Verfügungsmasse. Und die soll sich dann bitte dort einpassen, wo man sich das gerade vorstellt. Oder wir haben ja dann die Debatten jetzt auch, das geht ja auch weit über so ein CDU-Lager hinaus, dass man schon eigentlich, ist noch nicht so massiv formuliert, wie jetzt ein Dobrindt, aber doch nahelegt, liebe ukrainischen Männer, kämpft mal anständig weiter. Denn es geht hier um Freiheit, verdammt noch mal. Und das sagt man ja auch aus sehr angenehmen Podcaststudios heraus.
Ja, vor allem, wir haben diese Europameisterschaft und jedes Polizeiauto. Und man sieht hier in den Spielstätten wirklich viele, haben diese Trauerbeflaggung, will ich nicht sagen, sondern die schwarzen Bänder an den Türgriffen. Jeder deutsche Polizist trauert wochenlang über einen Menschenleben. Und wir sagen völlig zurecht. Wir haben gleichzeitig eine politische Diskussion, in der wir sagen, also diese 100.000 Leute, die haben ihren Aufentrecht hier verwirkt, denen können wir gerade noch eine Waffe in die Hand geben und dann geht es ab, zurück in die Ukraine und seinen Krieg führen. Während gleichzeitig Julian Assange aus dem Gefängnis kommt. Und die einzige Logik, die zentrale Logik, kommen wir ja mal kurz spielen. Das ist nämlich dann, also wir haben eine ökonomische Asymmetrie, die nicht aufgefangen wird, weil die Politik versagt, dann juristischer und es schaukelt sich dann hoch in Kriege. Was, warum Kriege? Julian Assange hier. Ich habe mir diesen Clip, der kursierte jetzt wieder noch mal rausgezogen, der ist wirklich, da steckt im Grunde alles drin.
Die Medien hätten es stoppen können.
Sie hätten es stoppen können. So, Menschen gehen nicht von sich aus in Kriege. Wenn sie es doch machen, wurden sie belogen. Und zwar gilt das für jeden einzelnen Krieg. Wenn jemand losgeschickt wird, um jemanden zu töten, und akzeptiert, es sei nur ein politischer Maßstab, irgendwer muss irgendwas verteidigen, dann ist es immer eine Lüge, und dann sagt er dazu eine mediale Lüge. Denn man könnte ja durchaus sagen, der Dobrindt ist halt der Dobrindt. Keine Ahnung, warum diese 70.000 Leute in München, denen sie unbedingt wählen müssen, damit er da sein Wahlkreis oder was auch immer, nur irgendwer transportiert deutschlandweit, was Dobrindt sagt zum Thema ukrainische Männer und dass sie alles verwirkt haben hier, wenn sie nicht bereit sind, für unsere Freiheit zu sterben. Und da es hier um einen Kriegskontext geht, ist das per se immer eine Lüge. Und Journalisten, die das transportieren, lügen dann auch. Die tricksen uns hier als Verfügungsmasse oder was auch immer. Aber diese, vielleicht sollten wir dieses Kristallisieren noch ernster nehmen, noch härter, alles immer runterbrechen auf einfachste Logiken.
Ja, das ist ja schon, wie du das gerade deutlich gemacht hast, an diesem Beispiel Dobrindt lügt. Aber was ist eigentlich mit den Medien, die das so übernehmen?
Die machen einfach mit.
Wir haben Pro und Cons in den Medien. Brauchen wir eine Wehrpflicht für Männer und Frauen oder brauchen wir eine Wehrpflicht nur für Männer? Das ist Pro und Contra.
Das ist die Kontroverse, die jetzt diskutiert wird.
Es ist nicht mehr, brauchen wir eine Wehrpflicht oder nicht, sondern nur noch alle, alle, alle oder nur alle Männer. Das ist jetzt nicht ausgedacht, dass das genauso in der süddeutschen Zeitung erschien.
Ich hab mir das gestern gedacht, das kann doch alles nicht wahr sein. Dieser Olejarius wurde jetzt freigesprochen. Er wurde natürlich nicht freigesprochen, sondern es gab einen Beschlussurteil, er ist medizinisch nicht in der Lage zu... Warte, ich muss unbedingt diesen Titel des Politik-Podcasts... Also, wir haben einen Banker, der 82 Jahre alt ist. Wir haben uns gesehen, 82 Jahre, das ist schon ganz schön viel. Der sitzt vor Gericht, nicht weil er Steuern hinterzogen hat, sondern weil er mutmaßlich 42 Millionen Euro aus der Finanzkasse seines Finanzamts an sich hat überweisen lassen, mit der trickreichen Begründung, das steht mir zu. Und ich sage, nee, das hat doch jemand anders schon gekriegt. Nee, das steht mir zu, ich habe hier einen Zettel, da steht das. Ja, okay, dann überweisen wir ihn das. So, dann wurde später festgestellt, nachdem man vorher dachte, na, das wird ja keiner machen, oder? Es gibt erstmal keinen Straftatbestand. Dann kam raus, doch, es ist jetzt ein Straftatbestand. Also sitzt er vor Gericht. Seit acht Jahren läuft dieses Verfahren. 2011 kam das ja so auf, es ist 2024. Und jetzt stellt das Gericht fest, ja, wir haben das mal durchkalkuliert. Der Gutachter sagt, er kann nur 45 Minuten pro Verhandlungstag verhandeln. Die Beweisaufnahme würde aber noch so und so lange dauern. Also während das drei Jahre ist ihm nicht zuzumuten. Deswegen jetzt aus gesundheitlichen Gründen freigesprochen. Also in Anführungszeichen, aber ich sage trotzdem freigesprochen. Denn gesunden Menschenverstand würde sagen, Momentchen mal, die Beweisaufnahme dauert so lange. Wer könnte denn die beschleunigen? Vielleicht der Beschuldigte? Könnte da einfach mal ein bisschen mithelfen, dass es dann eben nicht drei Jahre dauert, wenn er darunter so leidet. Ich hätte hier schon gerne einen Abschluss des Verfahrens. Denn es geht ja hier um insgesamt, er ist ja nur einer von mehreren tausend Beschuldigten, 30, vielleicht 40 Milliarden Euro. Während uns die CDU gerade erzählt, sie wollen jetzt 170 Millionen sparen durch Bürgergeldtransalierungen. Also hier haben wir eine wirklich harte ökonomische Asymmetrie im System, die politisch und wie ich skandalös jetzt feststelle, auch juristisch nicht aufgefangen wird. Das ist für mich also das, was ja jetzt stattfand mit diesem olearios Prozess, gerade im Sinne von noch drei Monate und vielleicht hätten wir dann auch Scholz als Zeugen da gehabt und so. Eine der größten Ungerechtigkeiten und auch Frechheiten, die stattfand, das war also am 26. Mai, äh Juni. Am 27. Juni veröffentlicht der Deutschlandfunk den Politik-Podcast Nummer 374 zu den aktuellen politischen Themen, Thema Bürgergeld stützen oder stutzen. Und es ist einfach skandalös. War ja auch Thema. Also das ist nicht zurechtwertig.
Im letzten Presseclub auch wieder. Es ist jede Woche, ist das das Top-Thema? Das wird gesetzt.
Wenn jemand für 40 Millionen, die er mutmaßt, also er hat sie überwiesen gekriegt. Die Frage ist, jetzt mutmaßt er sich zurecht oder nicht? Und wir wissen, ne, das wurde schon, also es ist eigentlich alles klar so, ne? Und er kommt dann frei, weil, ah ne, ich hab mich am Prozess ja nicht beteiligt. Und weil ich mich nicht beteiligt hab, dauert das alles so lange, dass es mir nicht zuzumuten ist, ich bin frei. Also wir kommen nicht zu einem normativen, ihm zu irgendeiner Handlung zwingenden Urteil, weil er einfach keine Lust hat. Es tut ihm nicht gut. Er hat seinem Arzt gesagt, ich brauch eine Gangschreibung, aber er hat eine gekriegt. Und der mediale Diskurs parallel dazu, während wir 50 Milliarden im Haushalt suchen, ist Bürgergeld stützen oder stürzen. Das geht einfach wirklich nicht, liebe Journalisten. Das ist kurz vor Bürgerkriegserklärung.
Das ist durch die Bank, ist das ja so. Also wir hatten ja im letzten Podcast doch das Beispiel, dass dann tatsächlich Scholz mal einen höheren Mindestlohn angesprochen hat und sofort kommt Micky Beisenherz in seinen Podcast und sagt, muss der das dann jetzt auch noch sagen?
Dieser Stress. Ja, also wir haben ja ganz schiefe Diskussionen. Das ist alles nicht gut. Und wir kommen erst noch zum Bildungsbericht. Wir haben ja noch ein bisschen Scholz, haben wir noch, oder?
Wir hören jetzt auf damit. Mir reicht's.
Kommen wir zu ernsthaften Problemen. Die Jugend. Wir haben sie ja gerade schon angesprochen. Es gibt alle zwei Jahre einen Bildung in Deutschland Bildungsbericht, kurz vorm Bildungsbericht. Der wurde jetzt wieder veröffentlicht. Einmal in kompakter und ausführlicher Form. Und interessanterweise, Phoenix hat es nicht übertragen. Team Junge Naiv war vor Ort. Und auf der Webseite des Ministeriums gibt es ohne weitere Angabe ein Video der Bundespreisekonferenz dazu. Also ich weiß nicht genau. Für mich wurde das versteckt als Thema. Deswegen holen wir es uns hier raus. Wir hatten ja einige Themen bisher schon mal behandelt, die wir jetzt aufgreifen. Leseleistung, also die Analphabeten, die Seg uns aufgeschrieben hat. Die Leseleistungen, steht im Bericht, sind sowohl im Primar als auch im Sekundarbereich 1 rückläufig. Bei wachsendem Anteil leserschwacher SchülerInnen. Also was diesen strukturellen Analphabetismus, der ja 17 Millionen Menschen betrifft in Deutschland.
Zwischen 18 und 64.
Das ist im Grunde jeder dritte Wähler. Das ist viel.
Also man muss es nochmal gerade deutlich machen, für die, die den Salon nicht gehört haben. Wir haben über das Buch von Veit Selk gesprochen, Demokratiedämmerung, und da zitiert er eine Studie, die jetzt auch wieder aufgegriffen wurde medial, die besagt, dass 17 Millionen der 18 bis 64-Jährigen auf dem Niveau von Viertklässlern oder darunter lesen, schreiben, Texte verstehen können. Weshalb jetzt die Tagesschau auch einmal am Tag in einfacher Sprache gesendet wird. Da wird dann deutlich gemacht, ja, das richtet sich an Leute, die kognitive Schwierigkeiten haben oder Leute, die frisch nach Deutschland gekommen sind und noch nicht so gut Deutsch können. Ja, aber das ist nicht die größte Gruppe. Die größte Gruppe ist wirklich die, die da von Selk auch beschrieben wird, die eigentlich gut lesen und schreiben können müsste. Also wo offenbar es andere Probleme gibt und die können wir ja einfach bildungspolitische Probleme nennen.
Genau, wir stellen ja zum Beispiel fest, wir hatten ja über die Needs gesprochen, N-I-E-T, auch ein Grundbegriff, Not in Education, Employment or Training. Die werden ja auch aufgegriffen. 2022 verließen bundesweit wieder mehr Jugendliche ohne Schule den Abschluss. Es waren jetzt 6,9% eines Jahrgangs, also 7%. Plus, das wird im Bericht deutlich, und auch in der Bundespressekonferenz, es gibt eine Dunkelziffer, die da sehr beachtenswert ist.
Ich hör grad schon TPA-Frage an Herrn Prof. Marz. Die Anzahl der Schulabbrecher würde mich nochmal interessieren. Da haben sie ja 52.300 oder so. Können Sie das mal erklären, was an dieser Zahl so relevant ist, wenn man das im Vergleich zu 11 Mio. Schülern insgesamt und den Trend der vergangenen Jahre da mal skizzieren und warum das Ihnen auch wichtig ist, weil Sie das ja im Bericht auch haben?
Die Zahl ist aus verschiedenen Gründen wichtig. Einerseits transportiert die Zahl noch nicht die gesamte Geschichte, weil hier nur diejenigen jungen Menschen gezählt werden, die am Ende des Schuljahres die Schule ohne Abschluss verlassen. Diejenigen, die das unterjährig machen, sind in der Statistik nicht enthalten. Wir können auch nicht verlässlich sagen, wie groß der Anteil ist.
Es gibt eine Dunkelziffer. Und selbst ohne Dunkelziffer verlassen am Ende des Schuljahrs mehr als 50.000 die Schule ohne Abschluss. Wir haben es auf einer Folie gehabt in der CASE letzte Woche. Bürgergeldverweigerer, die dann wirklich Sanktionen bekommen, 13.000. Unter der politischen Diskussion, die sollten wir ja auch mal für den Arbeitsmarkt fit machen, da müssen wir jetzt mal richtig ran und so, wird ewig breit diskutiert. Mehr als dreimal so viele Leute verlassen die Schule ohne Abschluss, sind also noch jung, den könnten noch 40 Jahre vor sich haben im Berufsleben, kein Thema, nirgendwo Thema. Das kann doch alles gar nicht sein.
Und von denen ist ja niemand verloren. Müsste niemand verloren sein.
Von denen ist niemand verloren, die sind da, die sind geboren, die sind am Leben. Mit denen müsste man einfach nur, wir haben es ja besprochen, win-win-win, das ist für alle ein Gewinn, für die Gesellschaft, für sie, für die Familien.
Denn die Sache ist ja, es gibt sicherlich einige Totalverweigerer, die sind nicht mehr einzugliedern. Jetzt kann man sagen, wir sind ein reiches Land, wir müssen damit leben, dass es diese Art der Dissidenz gibt und dann ist es so, nur sich damit jetzt zu beschäftigen, solche volkswirtschaftlichen Aufwallungen zu machen, bis man die doch noch in irgendeinen Beruf bekommt, ist völlig irrsinnig, während ich mit 18-Jährigen grundsätzlich was machen kann.
Die müssen nur ins 1 zu 1 Betreuungsverhältnis, sodass man halt sieht, um die kümmert sich jemand. So, also Leseleistungen rückläufig, Schulabgänger ohne Abschluss werden mehr. Rückgänge bei Weiterbildungsaktivitäten, nur 42% der Betriebe in Deutschland nehmen an Weiterbildungsaktivitäten teil. Also nicht mal die Hälfte, während wir hier einen auf Wissensgesellschaft, lebenslanges Lernen und so, findet alles nicht statt. Gab es denn mehr Geld für die Bildung? Es werden jetzt Zahlen genannt, ich will nur daran erinnern. Also die Inflation 10% plus. In diesem Zeitraum, alle zwei Jahre machen die diese Studie.
Eine Entwicklungslinie, die wir ausmachen konnten, ist, dass für Bildung mehr Geld ausgegeben wird. Dass dieses zum Teil aber sich darauf zurückführen lässt, dass die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung der letzten Jahre, wenn man Corona ausschließt, sehr positiv war. Der Anteil am Bruttoinlandsprodukt hat sich dagegen nur um 0,2% erhöht. Das ist insofern ein wichtiger Befund, weil einerseits die Bedarfe für Bildung, Stichwort frühe Bildung, Stichwort Ausbau von Ganztag, aber auch Ausfinanzierung von Weiterbildung in den letzten Jahren gestiegen sind und steigen werden. Und die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung nach Corona sich in Deutschland noch nicht so erholt hat, wie das im europäischen Vergleich der Fall ist.
So, das Bildungssystem wechselt also einfach mit dem BIP. Wären wir in den letzten zwei Jahren, ja, Zuwanderung im in Deutschland nie gesehenen Rekordmaßstab mit mehr als zwei Millionen Menschen pro Jahr 2022 den Ukrainekrieg hatten. Was ja bedeutet, wenn mehr als die Hälfte der Migrationsströme Minderjährige betrifft, Frauen mit Kindern kommen, dass die in dieses Bildungssystem reinrutschen. Ich würde nicht sagen, dass man an den Zahlen sehen kann, dass die irgendwie aufgefangen wurden, aber es ist wirklich haarsträubend. Hier hören wir Christine Streichert Klivot. Sie ist in Saarland zuständige Kultusministerin und gleichzeitig Vorsitzender der KMK, also der Kultusministerkonferenz. Zum Thema sind ganz schön viele mehr Aufgaben.
Wir haben viele Herausforderungen. Das bestätigt der Bildungsbericht aufs Neue. Nicht nur in quantitativen Zahlen haben wir mehr Schülerinnen und Schüler im System. Das ist etwas, was zunächst mal sehr positiv zu bewerten ist. Das heißt, wir haben weiterhin junge Menschen, die in unsere Bildungseinrichtungen kommen. Wir stellen aber auch fest, dass wir eine zunehmende Heterogenität haben, dass die Gesellschaft sich wandelt und dass das mit zusätzlichen Herausforderungen verbunden ist.
Aber was ist das überhaupt für eine merkwürdige Formulierung? Es steht einem ja nicht frei, in die Schule zu gehen oder was anderes zu machen, sondern man ist jung und geht in die Schule, oder?
Eigentlich hat man Schulpflicht und so. Und ich dachte, wir hatten das mal diskutiert, als irgendwie alle dann plötzlich freitags demonstrieren gingen für zwei Stunden oder so, aber...
Ja, weil sie sagt, es ist schön, dass so viele das Angebot wahrnehmen. Das ist ja nicht so, dass man stattdessen als junger Mensch auch was anderes machen könnte.
Es gibt ein paar Freiwillige, also wie bei Thomas zum Beispiel da in Bamberg. Man möchte gerne eine Hochschulzulassung, wird aber im bayerischen Abwiesystem aussortiert, ist dann volljährig, hat keine Schulpflicht mehr, kann aber auf die Oberschule gehen und da noch. Und dann ist natürlich freiwillig so.
Aber ich hatte nicht den Eindruck, dass sie diese Leute meint.
Nee, es ist eigentlich total bananen, das so zu sagen. Wir halten auch nur von ihr fest, sie sagte, es sind mehr.
Und es ist heterogener.
Und es ist heterogener. Also mehr in der Zahl und mehr in der Qualität, der man sich da stellen muss. In der Gesamtentwicklung ist festzuhalten, gegenüber 2012 ist um sieben Prozent der Anteil der Menschen gewachsen, die diese Bildungseinrichtungen in Anspruch nehmen. Also Kindertageseinrichtungen ab, also auch die U6 und U3. Allgemeinbildende Schulen aller Arten, berufliche Schulen, Hochschulen und so weiter. Wir sind in Deutschland bei 17,9 Millionen Menschen, die also im Bildungssystem zugegen sind. Wir wollen natürlich, dass alle so durch das Bildungssystem rauschen, dass sie am Ende für die Volkswirtschaft nützlich, ich sage es ganz ausdrücklich, denn es macht keinen Sinn irgendwie zu argumentieren, ich finde es nicht gut, wenn wir Menschen unter Verwertungslogik, es ist immer Win-Win. Also wenn wir den volkswirtschaftlichen Verwertungslogik folgen, ist das immer gut für den Zögling, der da reinrutscht. Er wird umso erfolgreicher für die Volkswirtschaft verwendbar sein, umso mehr er da beiträgt und Produktivität schafft, umso mehr wird er auch verdienen und so weiter und so fort. Also da kann man sich einfach gemütlich dranhängen an das Argument, da gibt es jetzt gar keinen moralischen Gesichtspunkt, warum man das nicht tun sollte.
Denn hier kann man es ja auch wirklich mal direkt an die individuelle Situation binden. Es leuchtet ja jedem sofort ein, je mehr ich in mein Kind investiere, Zeit und Geld für eine Ausbildung, desto mehr Chancen wird es haben am Arbeitsmarkt, desto besser qualifiziert wird es sein. Niemand würde dem widersprechen. Auf volkswirtschaftlicher Ebene denkt man, hm, also wenn wir da jetzt nochmal Millionen locker machen, wie finanzieren wir das denn eigentlich?
Ja, deswegen ja auch nochmal mein Plädoyer, Kindergrundsicherung braucht kein Konzept. Wir haben den Familien einfach Geld, die wissen schon, wie sie es verwenden können für die Kinder. So, damit aber alle erfolgreich oben rausporzeln, müssen wir irgendwie, das ist eine deutsche Eigenart, mit diesem soziale Herkunftsding umgehen. Der Bildungsbericht ist dazu ganz interessant. Es ist ein recht komplizierter Satz, ich lese ihn mal vor, der da drin steht. Der Bildungserwerb ebenso wie die Wahl eines Berufs sind nach wie vor stark an die familialen Gegebenheiten einerseits und an die damit zusammenhängenden Bildungs- und Erwerbsbiografien andererseits gebunden. Okay, brechen wir das mal runter auf einen politischen Wunsch. Wir hören Bettina Stark-Watzinger.
Wir wollen nicht länger hinnehmen, dass der Zusammenhang von sozialer Herkunft und Bildungserfolg in Deutschland überdurchschnittlich hoch ist. Und deswegen ist es ein Auftrag an uns alle. Und deshalb setzen wir uns mit aller Kraft dafür ein, die Startchancen für die Kinder und Jugendlichen in unserem Land nachhaltig zu verbessern, für mehr Chancengerechtigkeit. Und wir wollen zeigen, dass es geht.
So, sie wollte unbedingt das Wort Startchancen unterbringen, weil sie ja ein Startchancenprojekt hat. 20 Milliarden Euro für 4.000 Schulen. Und ich sag, okay, schon ganz gut. Aber da fehlt auch noch eine Null, so ungefähr. So, jetzt hat sie gesagt, wir wollen und so weiter. Wir kennen ja alle das Problem. Es sollte immer besser werden. Es ist ein bisschen blöd, dass es noch nicht erreicht ist. Die Zahlen sind wie folgt. Ich lese jetzt den original Bildungsbericht wie er dieser Expertenkommission geschrieben fürs Bildungsministerium der Bundesregierung vorgelegt wurde. Nur 25 von 100 nichtakademikerinnen Kindern nehmen ein Studium auf. Stammen Kinder aus einer akademikerinnenfamilie sind es 78 von 100 Kindern. Also 25 zu 78. Auch hier vermeintes und vermientes Gelände, es muss nicht jeder studieren. Und wer nicht studiert, hat auch jedes Recht dazu, eine Berufsausbildung zu machen. Nur, diese Zahlen sind für uns Indikatoren. Wenn die nicht konkurrent aufeinander liegen, sondern mit 25 zu 78 weit auseinander, haben wir es hier mit Disbalancen im System zu tun. Alle anderen Fairness-Gesichtspunkte würden sich nämlich, wenn sie fair wären, statistisch ausgleichen. Dann würden wir einfach sagen, wir haben 50% Abiturienten, die kommen zu 50% aus diesen und zu 50% aus diesen Familien. Das wäre einfach, weil Kinder werden biologisch gleichgeboren. Alles andere sind sozialisierungs- und pädagogische und eben politische und ökonomische Sachen, die da einwirken. Was für Bettina Stark-Watzinger heißt, sie bindet es auf diese Losung.
Bildung ist die Zukunft unseres Landes, individuell für jedes Einzelne, für jeden Einzelnen, aber auch für unsere Gesellschaft insgesamt. Und deswegen braucht es die bestmögliche Bildung für alle.
Aber sie sagt an keiner Stelle wie.
Nee, es ist wirklich so schlimm. Es ist wirklich eine schlimmere Bildungsministerin als diese komische Betsy DeVos, die als Milliardärin Trumps Pseudo-Bildungsministerin wurde. Das ist wirklich ganz gruselig. In dem Text, bei gleichen Leistungen, selbst wenn man jetzt sagt, die Leute haben es geschafft, bis an die Grenze, wo dann entschieden wird, du machst jetzt hier Bildungsweg und so weiter. Also jetzt können wirklich nur noch ökonomische, oder die Familie sagt so, ich kenne mich da nicht aus, in der Uni, willst du das echt machen und so, ich kann dir da gar nicht helfen als Mutter. Bei gleichen Leistungen also, bei gleichen Leistungen und Noten, gehen 44% der Kinder aus sozioökonomisch benachteiligten Familien an ein Gymnasium über, also es ist das harte Aussetieren in der Viertklasse, während es unter Kindern aus privilegierten Familien 58% sind. Also hier haben wir es auch immer noch, selbst wenn alles sonst stimmt, immer noch mit so einer krassen Ungerechtigkeit zu tun. So, könnte man diese Benachteiligung fördern? Ja, es ist ein volkswirtschaftliches Nullsummspiel. Das muss man hier immer ganz deutlich betonen. Wir haben so wenig Nachwuchs, dass kein armes Kind, das in ein Gymnasium kommt, irgendeinem Reichen den Platz wegnimmt oder so. Wir haben Ballungszentren, wo manchmal eine Schule fehlt, dann wird eine gegründet. Das funktioniert gerade hier in Frankfurt, finde ich, jetzt gerade sehr gut. Das ist dann schon. Wir könnten alle so weit wie möglich fördern. Niemand wäre was weggenommen. Plus volkswirtschaftlicher Win, privater Win, also wirklich Win-Win auf allen Ebenen. Mit 32% erhalten deutlich weniger Kinder aus sozioökonomisch benachteiligten Familien eine Gymnasial-Empfehlung als jene aus privilegierten Elternhäusern. Also die Eltern sind arm, die Lehrer 32% kriegen ja eine Gymnasial-Empfehlung. Bei den privilegierten Elternhäusern 78%. Nachhilfe, der ganze Kram, Kopf frei für solche Sachen.
Und du kannst ja mal mit Lehrern reden. Die Eltern, die privilegiert sind, kommen ja gleich mit dem Anwalt, wenn die Note nicht stimmt.
Das kommt dann auch dazu, genau. Es ist sehr viel schwieriger, diese Leute auszusatzieren. Selbst bei entsprechender Leistung, wie auch immer. Aber wie gesagt, man muss niemanden nach unten drücken. Man könnte alle einfach anheben. Wär schon gemacht. Soziale Unterschiede nach formalen Bildungsabschluss oder Erwerbsstatus bleiben bestehen, sowohl beim Präsenz als auch beim Online-Lernen. Also hier irgendwie, mal gucken, wie es jetzt ist. Mein Argument ist ja, wenn die Kinder erstmal alle Claude auf dem Handy haben, dann werden sehr viele ganz schön krasse Gespräche mit einer KI stellen, wo sie sich fragen, was reden die Erwachsenen da, wer besser golfen kann. Naja, frühkindliche Bildung. Also das große Thema Startchancen, wie sie da hat. Eine Journalistenfrage an Bettina Stark-Watzinger. Frau Stark-Watzinger, können Sie sagen, was Sie als die wichtigste Aufgabe aus dem nationalen Bildungsbericht ableiten?
Das ist jetzt natürlich eine Frage, die dem widerspricht, was ja einleitend auch von Prof. Marz gesagt wurde, dass die Herausforderungen im Bildungssystem ja vielschichtig sind. Insofern gilt es ja an jeder Ebene anzusetzen. Aber ich finde es sehr gut, dass die KMK sich in ihrer letzten Sitzung, und ich finde, das ist auch ein wichtiger Schritt, gerade noch mal mit der frühkindlichen Bildung, auseinandergesetzt hat, weil die ja traditionell, klassisch bei uns in Deutschland, eben von dem Finanzierungsvolumen her im Vergleich zu den anderen Ebenen eben nicht so stark finanziert wird. Und auch traditionell, da hat sich sehr viel getan, aber es startete ja eher mit Blick auf Vereinbarkeit von Familie und Beruf. Und der Perspektivwechsel dazu, dass es eben Bildungseinrichtungen sind. Und da hat die Forschung ja gerade auch sehr viel dazu beigetragen. Professor Marz kann das besser sagen, dass im Alter bis zu drei Jahren die Grundlagen für den weiteren Bildungsweg gelegt werden. Insofern finde ich, ist das wirklich ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Punkt, weil er eben am Anfang steht und dann den weiteren Bildungsweg so stark beeinflusst.
Also sie hat zur Kenntnis genommen, dass es eine Studie gibt, die das besagt, aber was sie da politisch für sich sagt, was sie sich draus ableitet, das verrät sie uns heute nicht.
Also bei der Frage, was ist am wichtigsten, würde sie als FDPlerin natürlich sagen, ich mag die MINT-Spitzenforschung. Wenn die da die Teilchen beschleunigen, das ist so geil, das ist genau mein Ding, und dann kommt sie aber und denkt, ich sag mal kurz, ich will mich nicht festlegen, aber diese frühkindliche Bildung, U3, das ist schon ganz wichtig. Nun, es ist aber so, U3, wer ist U3, wenn über zwei Millionen Menschen fluchtbedingt nach Deutschland kommen? Und wie du sagst, Frauen und ihre Kinder, weil die Männer müssen ja kämpfen. So steht im Bericht, so ist er im Bereich Demografie aktuell quantitativ relevanteste Faktor, die größtenteils fluchtbedingte Zuwanderung, dank der die Bevölkerungszahl 2022 gegenüber dem Vorjahr um 1,1 Millionen auf 84,4 Millionen Personen angestiegen ist. Also sie weisen nochmal kurz darauf hin, es gibt eine Großwetterlage, Demografie, Krieg und so weiter. Es kommen, ja wer kommt? Die Altersgruppe der 3- bis unter 6-Jährigen, besonders relevant für die frühe Bildung, hat sich mit einer Zunahme um 20% innerhalb der letzten 10 Jahre deutlich vergrößert. Kurzer Hinweis, es sind nicht die Geburten gewesen. Das ist dieser, deswegen ja auch vorher der kleine Hinweis für die Ministerin, wenn sie das hier lesen, der relevante Faktor ist hier Zuwanderung und nicht ihre tolle Familienpolitik, die dazu führte, dass hier alle Leute sich plötzlich wieder zukunftswohlwollend Kinder trauen.
Und diese Kindergärten, darüber sprechen wir dann hier, die sind ja nicht durchweckend im guten Zustand. Ich war bei einer Freundin zu Gast, die hat ihr Kind im Kindergarten. Das war aber dann schon zu Hause. Und dann erzählte mir der vierjährige Hannes, dass es jetzt schon zu warm ist. Und wir hatten da gerade einmal 26, 27 Grad. Aber dieser Kindergarten ist so schlecht gebaut, so schlecht isoliert und der ist erst zehn Jahre alt, dass die Kinder jetzt umgezogen sind in die Turnhalle. Und jetzt wird einfach der Sommer in der Turnhalle verpackt.
Die hat kein Fenster, das ist gut für die. Kommt nicht so viel Wärme rein, kommt auch kein Licht rein. Aber das gibt es doch nicht. Es ist wirklich dramatisch. Vor allem, du hättest ihm ja sagen können, na ja, die Ministerin hat gesagt, frühkindliche Bildung ist ihr das Wichtigste.
Ich habe ihm ein Stofftier mitgebracht.
Der U3-U6-Bereich. Jetzt hören wir den Bildungsforscher zum Thema U3-U6-Bereich. So viele neue junge Menschen, was passiert denn da?
Und hier wird deutlich, dass wenn man Bildung verbessern will, dass der Alleineblick aus der bildungspolitischen Richtung oftmals nicht ausreicht. Wir sehen beispielsweise bei der Bildungsbeteiligung der drei- bis unter sechsjährigen Kindern mit Migrationshintergrund, dass hier der Anteil in den letzten Jahren sogar gesunken ist. Das heißt, selbst wenn die Bildung in der Kita noch so gut ist, wenn wir die Kinder dort nicht erreichen, dann wird das jetzt endlich nicht hinreichen. Insofern ist es wichtig, dass hier auch immer die Familien bei Integrationsfragen mit in den Blick zu nehmen sind.
Diese Bildungsbeteiligung der U6-Jährigen ist rückläufig. Also ja, wir haben mehr junge Kinder, und die könnten wir in Deutschland, aus denen könnten wir Kristalle machen, müssten sie nur einmal ins Integrationssystem Bildung reinschleusen, findet nicht statt.
Und das heißt, die gehen nicht in den Kindergarten?
Die gehen nicht in den Kindergarten. Die kommen in die Schule, können dann kein Deutsch, dann sitzt Johannes Winkel mit mir in der Landsendung und dann sagt er, das geht ja gar nicht, dass die da nicht Deutsch sprechen. Und da hat der Kassen Lindemann auch völlig recht damit zu sagen, dann dürfen die auch nicht in die Schule. Also wir verweigern denen sozusagen, also wir ermöglichen denen gar nicht Deutsch zu lernen, mit anderen Kindern, die in dem Alter auch Deutsch lernen.
Aber warum gehen die nicht in den Kindergarten?
Weil die keinen haben. Wenn du als ukrainische Frau nach Deutschland kommst und du suchst einen Kindergarten, findest du keinen. Es gibt manchmal so in Thüringen, hat man ja gehört, dass dann so Plätze reserviert werden, aber die müssen halt wirklich reserviert werden. Weil wenn du als Kindergarten eh schon überlastet bist, mit allem, und dann kommt eine Anfrage von einer ukrainischen Familie, ob dein Kind damit, also ob das Kind mit aufgenommen werden kann, dann denkst du dir, wie war nochmal der Trick mit der Warteliste und so weiter. Das ist einfach, das gibt es hier einfach nicht.
Ich hörte dann von einer Dame, die im Kindergarten arbeitet, wie groß diese Last ist. Also Kinder bringen ja Krankheiten mit sich, und das Problem ist aber nicht nur das, sondern viele Eltern müssen ja arbeiten. Es gibt ja einfach für die nur ganz geringe Möglichkeiten, also kommt natürlich sehr auf den Job an, wenn das Kind krank ist, zu Hause zu bleiben. Also das wird nicht gern gesehen. Was passiert, erzählte sie, naja, die geben dem fiebernden Kind morgens ein Zäpfchen, setzen das im Kindergarten ab, dann verstreut sich das natürlich.
In der Hoffnung, dass sie erst 14 Uhr merken, dass das Kind Fieber hat und nicht nur um 11.
Richtig, und dann verstreut sich das natürlich auch gut mit den Keimen überall, sodass es dann bald jeder hat. Und das ist die Situation, der man da heute ausgesetzt ist.
Ja, es ist wirklich alles nicht gut. Jetzt könnte man ja denken, naja, es kamen ja auch diese Mütter mit. Wir brauchen Menschen, die Betreuungstätigkeiten erfüllen. Könnten wir nicht da so Anwerbeprozesse machen, wie zum Beispiel hier in Frankfurt. Es ist EM. Wer könnte denn mal als Ordner, komm, wir gehen mal hier ins Migrationsheim und so, und dann rekrutiert man. Also geht man wirklich als Stadt dahin und sagt, hier wohnen doch 20 junge Leute, oder können die nicht mal für uns hier die Security machen, den Leuten sagen, wo das Klo ist. Also es kommen nicht nur, und ich will jetzt nochmal die Zahlen nennen, der U6-Bereich ist in den letzten 10 Jahren um 20% gewachsen. Und naturgemäß, es sind nicht die Geburten, das sind Familien, alleinerziehend, kriegsbedingt, die kein Deutsch sprechen, die müssten ja aufgefangen werden. Dann haben wir aber Personalknappheit. Wäre das nicht irgendwie zu kombinieren? Also der Anteil der Personen mit Einwanderungsgeschichte an der Gesamtbevölkerung wird kontinuierlich größer. 2005 bedrug er noch 16%. 2022 ist er auf 24% angewachsen. Das ist auch so eine Textstelle. Da kommen dann immer gerne so AfD-Tweets mit... Das ist ja skandalös. Habt ihr diese Zahlen gesehen und so? Ja, weil die Zahlen vorher keine kannte. Also das sind krasse Zahlen. Nur die sind halt nicht skandalös im Sinne von rassistischer Denke, sondern die sind einfach krasse Zahlen. Also hier ist einfach eine echte politische Herausforderung. Wenn man die Zahlen allerdings zum ersten Mal mitbekommt in einem rassistisch konjunktierten Chat, dann ist man natürlich... Wie soll man das schaffen und so? Man könnte es ja auch einfach mal als politisches Problem einhegen. Würde natürlich bedeuten, dass Olaf Scholz dann keine Angst vor der AfD hat, sondern das Thema einfach proaktiv anspricht, statt da irgendwie Blödsinn zu erzählen. Ich erinnere an seine letzte Rede als Finanzminister im Bundestag.
Anhaltende Personalengpässe lassen sich in allen Bildungsbereichen feststellen. Und gerade nicht nur im Bereich der Schule, die da oftmals im Fokus steht. Wir haben das in der frühen Bildung, wir haben das in der beruflichen Bildung, wir haben das auch in der Weiterbildung. Die Probleme, entsprechendes Personal zu rekrutieren, wir haben einen hohen Anteil bei den allgemeinbildenden Schulen wie bei den beruflichen Schulen von SeiteneinsteigerInnen, die keine vollständige pädagogische Ausbildung haben. Und hier auch eine große Variation zwischen den Bundesländern. Potenzial liegt möglicherweise in einer Gruppe von Zugewanderten. Hier konnten lediglich von 14 Prozent, die einen Antrag auf Anerkennung ihres Hochschulstudiums gestellt haben, eine vollwertige Gleichwertigkeit attestiert bekommen. Das heißt, wir haben hier eine Gruppe, wo wir überlegen müssen, ob bestimmte Voraussetzungen, die wir an den Lehrkräfteberuf binden, in Zeiten des Mangels hinreichend sind, beispielsweise die Forderung nach einer Zweifachqualifikation.
So, er hat das jetzt.
Ich muss das jetzt nochmal gerade zusammenfassen. Es ist so, dass nur 14 Prozent jener, die sich beworben haben, nur 14 Prozent derer, von denen wurde der Bildungsabschluss anerkannt.
Es kommen Menschen, die haben was studiert, und dann sagt Deutschland, das ist uns egal, das erkennen wir nicht an. Dann macht man noch ein paar Feinde. 85 Prozent der Fälle, das ist nicht auf deutschem Niveau. Jetzt sagt er, wir könnten ja mal Anpassungen vornehmen bei unseren Erwartungen an den Lehrerberuf. Und da sag ich, no. Es gibt schon gar keine Erwartungen mehr. Hier greift Rassismus eins zu eins. Die Schulen haben Pools für Lehrer, die ausfallen. Das sind dann Rentner, also hier Pensionierte, irgendwelche Ehemaligen oder mittlerweile, wir hatten doch immer diese Oma von der Emily mit, die hat auch immer ganz toll die Kinder mit betreut, als wir da auf dem Ausflug waren. Könnte die nicht zweimal die Woche reinkommen und hier Unterricht machen? Hat die denn irgendwas mit? Nee, die hat an der Kasse gearbeitet, so ungefähr. Also völlig wesensfremdes, rein rekrutieren. Hauptsache deutsch.
Ich kann dir auch ein Beispiel nennen.
Wenn du im Ausland Pädagogik studiert hast. Nee, das geht nicht. Also diesen Abschluss können wir nicht annehmen. Du kannst auf gar keinen Fall Lehrer werden. Ach, sie sind schon 95 Jahre alt und erklären sich noch bereit. Kommen sie, wir geben ihnen noch eine Medaille. Betreuen sie mal die Dreijährigen hier. Der Rassismus ist so krass einprogrammiert in dieses System, dass nur 14 Prozent dieser Abschlüsse anerkennen.
Das ist wirklich grotesk. Ich kenne auch einen Fall von jemand, der kein Pädagogikstudium hat, nie Lehramt studiert hat. Ein geisteswissenschaftliches Fach studiert hat, das aber eher für den Unterricht nur bedingt tauglich ist. Und trotzdem unterrichtet er fast alle Fächer.
Notgedrungen, ist ja sonst keiner da.
Ja, aber er ist deutsch.
Irgendwer muss am Schuljahresende ein Zeugnis schreiben, in dem irgendwas für die Eltern drin steht, was sie verwerben können.
Aber er ist deutsch und sieht damit für alle anderen so aus wie ein Lehrer.
Das ist das GPT-Phänomen, also die Grammatik stimmt. Der Rest, aber die Grammatik stimmt. Sie weisen nochmal darauf hin, 2,7 Millionen Zuzüge 2022, 1,1 Millionen davon im Zusammenhang mit dem Krieg, was eben bedeutet, 1,5 Millionen sind auch, ne, 1,2 Millionen sind fortgezogen, also wir haben eine Nettoeinwanderung von 1,5 Millionen Menschen. Also hier ist richtig viel Bewegung in Deutschland, nur halt nicht in diesen Systemen, die irgendwie den Laden am Laufen halten. Die Integration von Menschen mit Flucht- und Migrationserfahrungen ist also eine, wie sie sagen, kontinuierliche Aufgabe. Ich würde mal sagen, das ist noch ein bisschen wichtiger als dieses lebenslange Lernen, denn das kann man ja intrinsisch motivieren. Die Leute, die hierher kommen nach Deutschland und dann vielleicht sogar sagen, für uns dankenswerterweise, sie wollen hier leben bleiben, die sind schon intrinsisch motiviert, die sind schon aktiviert, nur wir holen die halt nicht ab. Wir haben für die kein Programm, die irgendwie einzubinden. Und dann kommen sie noch auf so einen Punkt zu sprechen, und das müssen wir jetzt verweben. Also die soziale Herkunft war seit Jahrzehnten immer ein Thema, wird so krass vererbt. Und dann dieser hohe Ausländeranteil. Denn es gibt Risikolagen, und zwar drei. Risikolage formal gering qualifizierter Eltern, die also ihren Kindern nicht richtig helfen können oder wie auch immer. Eltern, die nicht erwerbsfähig sind, ist auch eine soziale Risikolage. Und Armutsgefährdung im Haushalt. Die gehen natürlich alle so Hand in Hand. Also da gibt es häufig Überschneidungen, was im Bericht heißt hier. 2022 war fast jeder dritte minderjährige Person von mindestens einer dieser Risikolagen betroffen. Also von 12 Millionen Kindern in der Schule oder so sind hier 4 Millionen. Entweder können die Eltern nicht helfen oder sie haben keine Ahnung vom System oder haben kein Geld, daraus zu helfen wie auch immer. Also jedes dritte. 60% der Kinder aus Familien mit Einwanderungsgeschichte wachsen aktuell unter der Belastung mindestens einer dieser Risiko lagen auf. Bei den Kindern ohne Einwanderungsgeschichte sind es demgegenüber 20%. Also es verteilt sich hart entlang dieser, ja hast du einen Migrationshintergrund oder nicht? 60 zu 20%. Was bedeutet? Hier kann es allein eine staatliche Aufgabe sein. Ihr nützt es nicht, die Eltern zu motivieren, jetzt seid ihr mal weniger arm, jetzt seid ihr mal besser gebildet, spricht noch mal besser Deutsch, wird nicht funktionieren. Entweder hier gibt es eine staatliche Investition ins System, oder es bleibt, wie es ist, und dann sinken diese Erwerbsbildungsbeteiligung der Kinder und so weiter, dann gehen die nicht in den Kindergarten. Es ist nun mal so, die müssen dann zu Hause abgeholt werden vom Kindergarten. Zumindest für die erste Zeit. Da spricht auch gar nichts dagegen. Meine Kinder waren auch in so einem, da gibt es so ein Übergangsjahr, wo die dann vormittags schon in der Schule sind, aber nachmittags noch im Kindergarten, da kommt der Kindergarten in die Schule und holt die ab. Warum kann man nicht einfach morgens alle Kinder abholen? Das ist auch lustig, wenn man mit den Kindern von Haus zu Haus geht und einfach vier Kinder sich da morgens abholen. Also es ist wirklich crazy. Während in Paarfamilien rund ein Viertel der Kinder von mindestens einer Risikolage betroffen sind, ist der entsprechende Anteil bei Kindern alleinerziehender mehr als doppelt so hoch. Wenn wir hören, alleinerziehende Ukrainerinnen haben Kinder hier, dann können wir gar keine Ansprüche an die stellen. Dann greifen einfach alle Risikolagen und wir müssen trotzdem diese Hoffnung formulieren, es wäre gut, wenn die es schaffen, hier in Deutschland Fuß zu fassen, weil volkswirtschaftlich brauchen wir die. Ansonsten können wir die Renten nicht bezahlen. Naja, also der Bildungsbericht zeigt mir wirklich sehr deutlich, wie tief der Rassismus institutionell verankert ist und wie krass Deutschland immer noch so eine Normfamilie hat. Bio-Deutsch Eltern mit 1 oder 2 Kindern, eigentlich gar kein Problem. So, da müssen wir auf jedes zehnte Kind mal achten. Zugezogen, alleinerziehend, immer ein Problem. Da kann man gleich sagen, haben wir registriert, fahren wir hin, holen zu Hause ab. Also das ist wirklich crazy. Und da ist gut gepasst, der Juso-Chef Johannes Winkel war in einer Diskussion mit der grünen Jugendvorsitzenden Svenja Ampun.
Johannes Winkel ist Juso-Chef? Nein, Philipp, der heißt doch anders.
Nee, das ist ein neuer. Vorher war es Tilman Kuban.
Nein, du meinst Junge Union. Ja, Junge Union.
Nein, nein, nein. Er ist natürlich, wie heißt er? Sehr gut, sehr guter Mann.
Junge Union.
Sehr guter Mann, der Juso-Chef. Nein, Junge Union. Sorry, sorry, sorry. Junge Union-Chef. So wie es hier auf meinem Notizzettel steht. Also die beiden, die Junge Union und die Grünen treffen sich hier. Und wir hören jetzt aus grüner Richtung Problembeschreibung und so weiter und so fort. Und dann platzt ihr auch kurz der Kragen, weil das einzige, was aus der Richtung JU kommt, ist wirklich einfacher Rassismus.
Im Krankenhaus erlebt, was passiert, wenn in stressigen Situationen Beschäftigte nicht gut Deutsch sprechen. Ich habe Freundinnen und Freunde, die gerade anfangen, als Lehrer zu arbeiten und die merken, was es für eine Belastung ist. In einer ohnehin schon sehr großen Klasse mit Kindern, wo sowieso schon Kinder mit erhöhtem Förderbedarf sind, dann noch mehrere Kinder, die nicht gut Deutsch sprechen. Es gibt Herausforderungen, die durch Migration entstehen. Keine Frage. Man kann auch noch mal sagen, wenn man sozusagen mal in Deutschland alle Menschen mit Migrationsgeschichte abzieht, dann bricht unser Gesundheitssystem, unser Bildungssystem, alles zusammen. Aber es gibt diese Herausforderungen. Was mich bloß ärgert, ist, weshalb führen wir dann keine Debatte darüber, wie wir mit diesen Herausforderungen konkret umgehen? Führen wir die Debatte über die Kita-Plätze? Führen wir die Debatte, woher kriegen wir die Kita-Plätze, die fehlen? Da müsste man Geld ausgeben. Da hängen aber einige massiv an der Schuldenbremse. Unter anderem die Union, die verhindert, dass wir da rangehen. Es geht ja um die Begrenzung der Migration. Gucken wir uns das Thema mehr Geld für die Schulen an. Aber das ist genau der Punkt. Ihr landet immer einfach nur bei Ausländer raus. Und das ärgert mich. Genau das hast du sogar gesagt, Migration begrenzen, die Mauern höher ziehen. Der Punkt ist bloß. Hast du mal mitbekommen, was in dieser Welt da draußen los ist?
Das würde ich jetzt nicht mehr argumentieren.
Und Migration ist eine Realität. Und wenn man die Mauern jetzt höher zieht, dann werden einfach nur Menschen auf dem Weg hierher, mehr Menschen auf dem Weg hierher sterben.
Ja, braucht man gar nicht machen, denn er hat ja schon eingestanden, dass es ohne die schon hier seienden Migranten nicht funktioniert. Und sagt aber dann, Migration ist unser Problem, Ausländer raus, sagt er nicht, aber sie legt sie mir in den Mund und ich finde, sie macht das berechtigterweise. Und genau das ist die Argumentation, die wir jetzt überall hören. Es geht der Wirtschaft schlecht, wen können wir ausweisen? Irgendwelche Ziele von uns erfüllen sich nicht, wer muss dran glauben? Neuerdings ukrainische Männer, die noch hier sind, bitte jetzt ab in den Krieg.
Ihr wollt ja nicht mit uns diskutieren, wir sagen doch, Migration begrenzen. Ihr lasst euch ja nicht drauf ein. Dann sagt sie, dass es genau dieser Ausländer-Ausrassismus, der uns hier nicht hilft. Und man muss da nicht mit, die Welt steht im Feuer oder so, Deutschland steht im Feuer. Wir sollten heilfroh sein, dass diese Kinder schon im Land sind. Ansonsten müssten wir uns wirklich bald Gedanken machen, von woher wir sie importieren. Denn irgendwer muss hier in zehn Jahren Rente bezahlen. Und ich finde es erstaunlich, als ich im September 2022 mein Buch rausbrachte, habe ich noch so gedacht, okay, gut Fachkräftemangel ist immer noch und so weiter. Und dann hat es ja nur ein Jahr gedauert, bis September 2023. Und dann war Fachkräftemangel plötzlich überall Thema. Und ich war so ein bisschen überrascht und dachte, oh, das Thema geht aber schnell. Nur jetzt bin ich gerade wieder, denke ich so, nee, die haben das alles zu eingehegt.
Die meinen damit MINT-Spitzenkräfte.
Aber dass ein Drittel der Hausärzte in den nächsten zehn Jahren in Rente gehen und ersatzlos diese Praxen wegfallen, ist irgendwie noch nicht so richtig angekommen.
Ich kenne Hausärzte, sie sind weit über 70.
Die verdienen sich immer noch so ein Zubrot, weil sie jetzt keine Abgut haben.
Die verdienen gut, aber die sagen auch eigentlich, ja, was mache ich sonst mit den Patienten?
Ja, man weiß ja nicht, an wen man sie übergeben soll.
Da gibt es bei denen auch noch die Idee, gut, ich kann mir noch ein Auto kaufen, wenn ich weiter Praxis mache, aber es ist auch wirklich so eine Verantwortung, dass ich denke, ja, wenn das jetzt hier zu ist, dann ist hier auch nichts mehr, da kommt nicht jemand anderes. Und du sagst gerade, im September 22 ist ein Buch erschienen. Im September 22 sagte Friedrich Merz, ich hatte es mir extra noch mal rausgeschrieben, ja, das ist auch alles nicht so richtig mit den Ukrainern, die fahren, die machen so einen Tourismus inzwischen, die fahren hin und her, fahren wieder zurück in die Ukraine, kommen wieder her, ja. Also diese ganzen Sachen, also seien die so zum Vergnügen, greifen sich also in Deutschland auch noch so ein bisschen Bürgergeld ab und fahren dann wieder in die Heimat. Das hat er im September 22 gesagt, daraufhin wurde er von allen Parteien extrem angegriffen, von seinen eigenen Leuten. Und jetzt ist genau das absoluten neu. Ich habe damals gesagt, ja vielleicht wieder so ein Testballon steigen lassen. Ja, offenbar. Und damals war es noch zu früh und jetzt ist es genau richtig. Jetzt kann man exakt diese These vorbringen und bekommt Applaus und kann davon ausgehen, dass die nächste Talkshow nach einem gerichtet wird.
Ja, also wer jetzt fünf Jahre alt ist, ist in 20 Jahren, ist eine absolut sensationelle Nachricht, die ich jetzt verkünde.
25.
Politiker wissen das noch nicht. Der ist in 20 Jahren 25. So, mit 25 steigt man, ich sag mal so, spätestens, klar, gibt noch Nachzüge, ins Berufsleben ein. Und diese 20 Jahre liegen absolut in der politischen Verantwortung, was dann passiert.
Ich könnte mir jetzt aber auch...
Das ist eins plus eins ist gleich zwei.
Wenn dann Scholz in 20 Jahren gefragt wird, dann wird er wahrscheinlich sagen, Die in Indonesien! Nee, nee, er wird wahrscheinlich sagen, wir haben damals nicht damit gerechnet, dass Kinder auch erwachsen werden. Heute müssen wir das anders sehen.
Ein Kind, das heute geboren wird, geht in sechs Jahren in die Schule. Völlig überraschende kommunalpolitische Einsichten, dass das wirklich passiert. Dass die wirklich sechs Jahre alt werden und dann plötzlich in die Schule angemeldet werden.
Aber was ja auch interessant ist, ist, dass wir jetzt sehr viel die etablierten Medien schelten. Und das ist mir auch immer sehr recht. Aber was doch bemerkenswert ist, dass wir von all den Twitch-Streamern, all denen, die die ganze Zeit nur junge Leute adressieren, dies niemals thematisiert bekommen. Das einzige Mal, dass überhaupt Thema Schule aufkam, war während der Schulschließungen. Und da haben Rezo und Co. so eine Zero-Covid-Politik vertreten und haben es dann im Zuge von MyLab und so weiter völlig übertreiben wollen. Haben aber auch selbst natürlich nie irgendwelche Lockdown-Repressionen gehabt. Und sonst kommt das einfach bei den jungen Leuten auch selbst gar nicht vor. Also man könnte ja denken, dass man 14-, 15-, 16-jährige Damen und Damen spricht, dass man dies als großes Thema macht. Es ist aber nicht da. Du siehst doch auch, wie heißt da der dunkle Parabelritter oder wie diese ganzen Funkformate. Die reden einem doch auch jetzt nur ein Jahr. Also wenn keine Wehrpflicht, aber dann doch wenigstens eine Dienstpflicht oder irgendwie ein freiwilliges, gezwungenes Ja, dass wir alle ableisten müssen. Also die sind ja auch alle nur im Gemütszustand Rentnerrepublik. Was kann ich den jungen Leuten noch zumuten? Während es bei eigentlich ihrem Publikum ja darum gehen müsste, jetzt Preaching to the choir zu machen. Und das findet nicht statt. Es ist wirklich erstaunlich, dass man zwar heute jenseits der etablierten Medien die jungen Leute besser denn je erreicht, beziehungsweise man erreicht sie nur noch darüber. Also man kann ja nicht eine Fernsehsendung machen und glauben, dass da 14-Jährige davor sitzen. Man kann sie also nur darüber erreichen. Das Einzige, was man denen aber andrehen kann, sind E-Zigaretten und Glücksspielangebote.
Ich empfehle auf Instagram Herr Schröder, der Korrekturensohn. Kennst du ihn? Ist ein Lehrer, der Comedy macht auf der Bühne. Er hat 686.000 Follower auf Instagram. Und wenn er in irgendeiner Stadt zu Gast ist, macht er eine Halle voll und am nächsten Abend nochmal und am nächsten Abend nochmal. Und auf Instagram kann man dann verfolgen, weil er sehr viel mit dem Publikum interagiert. Es sitzen nur angehende Lehrer vor ihm. Wenn ich jetzt Politiker wäre, hätte ich wahnsinnig Angst, dass ich da gerade eine Schicksalsgemeinschaft zusammenschmiede, der irgendwann der Geduldsfaden platzt. Weil das scheint mir eine der größten sozialen Bewegungen in Deutschland gerade zu sein. Diese Comedituren vom Herrn Schröder. Das sollte man sich mal echt angucken.
Es ist auffällig, dass alle jungen Formate, die es gibt, und da ist vor allem Funk zu nennen.
Na ja, die kommen aus der Schule und du willst denen dann zu den Hausaufgaben nochmal ihre Themen am Nachmittag vorlegen.
Nein, aber man könnte es ja anders politisieren. Man könnte es ja auch mit der Entertainment aufgreifen. Es findet einfach nicht statt. Also die Jugendformate des öffentlich-rechtlichen Senders...
Ich habe einen Vorschlag.
Lass mich ausrechnen. Die Jugend-Sender des öffentlich-rechtlichen Senders sind dazu da, aus den Kindern und Jugendlichen schon Omas und Opas zu machen, bevor sie volljährig sind.
Ich habe einen Vorschlag für dich, ein Plädoyer. Diese Kinder erleben, was in der Schule los ist. Aber die wissen ja nicht, wie es mal vorher war oder wie es sein könnte oder so. Für die ist es einfach so eine Fisch-und-Wasser-Realität. Aber deren Eltern, wenn du die mit einer Wählerstimme ausstatst, die können diese Besorgnis wirklich politisch transportieren. Es muss nur für sie wirkungsvoll sein. Und wenn sie wissen, da geht eine Oma wählen, da geht eine Oma wählen, da geht eine Oma wählen, ich gehe jetzt für vier wählen, dann gehen die auch für vier wählen.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, ob du damit recht hast, denn ich sehe momentan auch nicht die große Elternbewegung auf der Straße.
Ja, wie auch, wenn einer ausgenockt ist, dann doch wohl die Eltern. Was meinst du, was ich mache vor so einem Podcast? Die Debatte gucken, ich schmier Toastbrote, ich mach Brotbüchse, ich guck, dass jeder heil in die Schule kommt. Debatte guck ich dann noch nebenbei. Also für die Debatte stelle ich mir einen Wecker auf die Uhr 30.
Ich sage nur, ich glaube du überschätzt, dass Familien so progressiv denken, wie du es tust.
Wir warten mal ein Buch ab, was dann zum Thema Familie, und zwar mit Munition, Feuer und so darin. Vermutlich musst du sie munitionieren, die Familien, damit sie dann aufgeklärt sind, um wählen zu können. Warte mal ab, wie ich die Familien munitioniere. Ich glaube, sehr viele Eltern wissen schon sehr gut, was sie politisch wollen. Sie haben nur keine Zeit, das auf die Straße zu tragen.
Aber sie haben am Ende auch gewählt. Also diese Eltern, die du da meinst, davon gehen sehr viele auch wählen. Es ist ja nicht so, dass man sagt, aber alle Menschen mit Kindern wählen.
Ja, wir haben keine Erhebung darüber, wie Eltern wählen.
Und da würde ich sagen, die wählen nicht viel anders. Die wählen vielleicht sogar eher noch.
Okay, dann sollten sie halt anders wählen. Also ich bin ja dran. Da ich heute nicht zu meinem KI- und Emotionthema komme.
Nein.
Na, das ist ja schon spät.
Ja, wir haben uns heute sehr aufgereben.
Genau, das kann man ja durchaus vertagen. Es kann auch durchaus auf der nächsten Bühne oder so. Dieses Thema lässt uns ja nicht los. Ich will trotzdem zwei KI-Clips spielen zu diesem Thema. Nachwuchs, Bildung, Sozialisation und so weiter. Das eine ist, wir hören Adam Curry, wie er kurz anmoderiert, weil ich habe den Clip selber nicht gefunden. Ich habe ihn nur bei Adam Curry im No Agenda Podcast gehört. Und wir hören Larry Fink, also den BlackRock-Chef, von dem wir wissen, dem ist egal, wer im Weißen Haus regiert, unter ihm, so ungefähr. Für demografisch in Schieflage geratene Volkswirtschaften.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass es passieren wird, aber die Verschuldigung des Alltags verändern die Produktivität, die wir alle denken, es wird.
Wir werden die Standards des Lebens der Länder und der Lebensstandards der Menschen mit schrinkenden Populationen erheben. Die sozialen Probleme, die man in der Verwaltung von Menschen für Maschinen hat, werden in den Ländern, die der Populationenwahl haben, viel einfacher sein.
So, jetzt lass ich frage dich jetzt, was glaubst du, wie ich diesen Clip einschätze? Du siehst mich als Fanatiker des Claude-Zeitalters, der demografisch aufgeklärt zum Thema publiziert und viel redet. Und jetzt kommt er mit so einem Umschwung in der Denke. Was glaubst du, wie ich darüber denke, was er da sagt?
Du bist ja jemand, der sagt, man kann jetzt mit Chachipiti und Claude alles Mögliche wegrationalisieren. Aber du bist ja zugleich jemand, der weiß, dass es eine menschliche Komponente gibt, die nicht so ersetzbar ist, so sehr man die auch mit Emotionen und allem trainieren möchte. Diese menschliche Komponente kann natürlich sehr verstärkt werden und nützlich eingesetzt werden, ganz neutral gesprochen, indem man viel in Bildung, Erziehung und all das investiert. Du hältst ja auch die Familie hoch, weil sonst könntest du auch sagen, bald können wir die Familie abschaffen. Darum kümmern sich nicht mehr Mama und Papa, sondern das machen zusammen Claude und Chachibi-T.
Genau.
Und insofern denke ich, dass du auf der Position bist, dass man eigentlich nur durch massive Bildungsinvestitionen eine sinnvolle AI-Politik machen kann.
Also recht nah dran. Ich halte diesen Clip für das Erschreckenste mit, was ich zuletzt gehört habe. Denn wenn das die Idee ist, wie die ganz superreichen Steuerer auf dieser Welt, die die Billionen bewegen, jetzt an die Sache rangehen, wenn sie sagen, Bildung ist was für diese Länder, die noch wachsen, die anderen schicken wir mal in dieses, und da muss man auch den KI-Winter, muss man umdefinieren. Was ist KI-Winter? Ich denke so an Dolly und sowas, solche Filme. Das ist wirklich, also mein Interesse an Familie ist, die Familie ist ein Interaktionszusammenhang, der sich nicht weg organisieren lässt. Das ist die große Lehre. Wir können die elementarsten Dinge in unserer Gesellschaft nicht weg organisieren, nicht automatisieren, sondern entweder sind da Menschen in Interaktion, also im Gespräch, oder nicht.
Und er könnte ja hier auch gleich sagen, ja, Gefühle, soziale Beziehungen, das ist so was für so einfache Völker noch irgendwo, die noch nicht ganz von BlackRock beherrscht sind.
In der Hinsicht, wir haben jetzt diesen Clip gehört.
Nicht so verwunderlich. Wenn du jetzt mal überlegst, was BlackRock vor allem auszeichnet als Schattenbank, ist es ja nicht so, dass wir hier das Warren Buffett Prinzip haben. Wir schauen uns die Unternehmensergebnisse an, lesen Berichte und machen dann Investitionsentscheidungen, sondern sie haben diesen Supercomputer, Aladdin.
Genau.
Und Aladdin entscheidet, wo investiert wird. Und ganz viel, was BlackRock ja überhaupt verwaltet, ist ja rein passiv verwaltet, also wo gar nicht mehr irgendetwas anderes geschieht als Index-Abbilden. Und das ist das, worüber er Herr ist. Und dann muss man nicht mehr den Einzelnen seine Souverität und seine Entscheidung hochhalten, sondern dann kann man sagen, wir delegieren das ja schon lange an Aladdin, an unseren Supercomputer. Und jetzt bekommt Aladdin noch ganz viele neue Geschwister.
Ja, also die Welt, die ihm hier vorschwebt, als erlösend, und er sagt ja, das ist hoffnungsvoll, ist nicht mehr lebenswert. Das ist im Grunde dieses, wir schützen das Klima für uns, damit es lebenswert bleibt. Wenn wir das jetzt aufgeben, ist es alles, also wir schützen die Natur nicht für die Natur, sondern für uns, und wenn wir das aus dem Blick verlieren und dann einfach nur wild rumrennen und irgendwie und so. Und hier auch. Also wenn wir die Interaktion, Menschen begegnen sich, wenn es darum nicht geht, sondern dann einfach wieder diese japanische, ja der Roboter wird die Pflege schon machen und so. Dann, deswegen wir haben jetzt diesen Clip gehört, würden wir jetzt noch Zeit haben und diese Emo-K.I. Clips hören, würden unsere Hörer danach weinend auf dem Boden liegen und wären wirklich betrübt. Von daher ist es nicht verkehrt, wenn wir das entzerren, das heute nicht mehr hören. Aber ich will nur darauf hinweisen, dieses Bevölkerungsgröße, wir haben solche Sachen wie hier, also dieses Bildungsthema kommt ja auch unter Druck, weil wir einfach nicht mehr, ich meine, wir hatten schon mal ökonomischen Druck. Das ist der erste Versorgungsdruck durch Versorgungskrisen. Nur das war in den 70ern und da hat man gesagt, ach so viele junge Leute, komm wir bauen die größten Unis der Welt. Jetzt haben wir wieder einen Versorgungsdruck, einen ökonomischen Druck und blenden alles aus, was irgendwem weiterhilft. Also Bildungssystem einfach, ah jetzt ist alles eine Last und so. Das muss man ja alles mal, also es ist nicht die ökonomischen Zwänge an sich, sondern es ist so dieses Verhältnis der demografischen Schieflage. Also wenn es mehr Jüngere gewesen wären, hätte man denen eine Zukunft gebaut. Wenn es mehr Ältere sind, naja das ist scheiß Pfleger, nervt uns eh und so, können wir die nicht einfach wegsperren. So ein Tenor. Und diesen Zusammenhang aus KI und Bevölkerungsgröße, der wird häufiger thematisiert, auch bei anderen, wie zum Beispiel hier internationaler Kräftekampf und so weiter, im Big Technology Podcast, den ich übrigens wirklich sehr empfehle, also dieser Big Technology Podcast, das ist so von LinkedIn irgendwie finanziert, aber dieser Alex Cantoro, witzig, wie er heißt, macht den wirklich sehr gut, da diskutieren die auch mal so ein bisschen KI und Demografie.
Es ist oft, weil sie mehr Menschen haben. Ohne die Hilfe der USA. Aber weil China mehr Menschen hat. Wenn AI vier Menschen umsetzen kann, kann die effektive Population eines Landes erhöhen.
Er illustriert das jetzt nur am Kräfteverhältnis. Aber wollen wir wirklich, dass jetzt solche kleinen Organisationen wie hier die Hisbollah und da irgendwer in Afrika denkt, ich hab gar nicht so viele Leute, aber ich klick mir jetzt per KI irgendwie so ein Angriffsszenario zurecht und zieh das dann durch. Ich schaff das auch zu zehnt. Also es treibt Blüten dieses Thema. Es ist alles nicht sehr gut.
Sollen wir noch über etwas auch nicht erfreuliches, aber vielleicht ein bisschen Heiteres sprechen?
Zum Abschluss haben wir Joseph Haider, äh Hader, Joseph Hader und Heidenreich, Elke Heidenreich. Das sind ja so kleine Rausschmeißer-Clips. Kannst du also gerne noch die Stimmung runterziehen.
Also, wir hatten ein Live-Sanon und zuvor haben wir dort auch unsere gemeinsame Freundin Constanze getroffen, Constanze raucht gelegentlich.
Ja, es hat uns ja fast süchtig gemacht.
Aber jetzt vapet sie auch.
Hattest du es auch probiert? Ja.
Wir haben beide probiert.
Es ist nicht.
Es ist merkwürdig, es schmeckt sehr süß. Es war.
15-jährige unwiderstehlich, würde ich sagen.
Wir hören mal in die Sache rein, es ist ein Riesenphänomen. Überall wird gevapet. Wir hören jetzt im NDR wurde folgendermaßen darüber gesprochen.
Toll ist, dass es nicht stinkt, dass man das zum Teil in der Wohnung rauchen kann und dass man selbst danach nicht stinkt. Und es schmeckt meistens besser als normale Zigaretten.
Die 27-Jährige ist vor etwa einem Jahr auf den regelmäßigen Geschmack der Einweg-E-Zigarette gekommen. Katharina dagegen ist Gelegenheitsvaperin. Kiwi, Passionsfrucht, Guava haben sie heute dabei. Im Vergleich zu den vielen Geschmackssorten der Vapes sieht der traditionelle Tabak ganz schön alt aus.
Man kann sich ja immer was aussuchen, wo man gerade Lust drauf hat. Und bei Zigaretten schmeckt das irgendwie immer gleich oder sehr ähnlich.
Wir hatten irgendeinen Himbeer-Geschmack.
Ja, das stimmt. Wir müssen es echt mal beschreiben, weil es nützt nichts jetzt zu sagen, nee. Weil jeder, der es benutzt, merkt es ja dann auch. Wir sind ja alle so ein bisschen auf der Suche nach Süßigkeiten, die uns nicht dick machen. Und mit diesen Waves hat man plötzlich so, man zieht da dran und dann legt sich auf den Gaumen in, wie so eine Zuckerschicht, die wirklich gut schmeckt. Alles, was negativ ist an Zigaretten, findet nicht mehr statt. Und man hat das unendlich den ganzen Tag. Und man weiß aber, die wissen selber noch nicht genau, was das so ist, aber es ist irgendwie giftig, es ist so richtig gut und man hat... Also es ist, was das Verlockungspotenzial angeht, so crazy. Selten ein Produkt gehabt, das so fesselnd sein kann.
Und sofort funktioniert. Die meisten Leute, die anfangen zu rauchen, machen das ja oft dann mit 14, 15, 16 aus einem Gruppendruck heraus. Aber in Wahrheit schmeckt ihnen das natürlich nicht gleich. Man muss sich also daran gewöhnen, dass einem dieser Geschmack dann so vertraut wird, dass man irgendwann sagt, ja, ich bin jetzt Raucher. Ich muss ja hier zur Transparenz sagen, ich rauche ja, aber sehr, sehr wenig. Das heißt, ich rauche zwei bis drei Zigaretten am Tag und das aber auch immer nur abends. Wir beide rauchen ja auch schon mal, wenn wir in eine Bar gehen und du bittest mich darum, dir eine Zigarette zu geben und dann rauchst du.
Da steht ein Tisch auf einer Terrasse. Wenn ich an diesem Tisch stehe, rauche ich ab und zu mal eine. Also das kommt auf alle zwei Wochen zwei Zigaretten oder sowas.
Ja, da müsste ich vielleicht auch noch hinkommen. Jedenfalls bist du dann...
Es ist trotzdem nicht gut zu rauchen.
Ja, es ist trotzdem nicht gut. Also auch drei Zigaretten sind nicht gut.
Ich mache das aus Gruppendruck.
Ich zwinge dich dazu. In Deutschland rauchen insgesamt 22,7 Prozent der Frauen und Männer ab 18 Jahren. Bei Männern sind ein bisschen mehr. Bei Jugendlichen gibt es einen enormen Rückgang, das jetzt klassische Zigaretten anbelangt. 2001 haben noch 27,5 Prozent der Jugendlichen geraucht, also 12 bis 17 Jahren. 27,5 Prozent, inzwischen 6,1 Prozent. Könnte man sagen, also ein Riesenerfolg der ganzen Nichtraucherkampagnen. Überall geht das Rauchen zurück von Zigaretten, aber die E-Zigarette, die ist etwas, was wirklich boomt. Wir haben jetzt hier einen Auszug aus dem Spiegel. Die Deutschland-E-Zigaretten-Branche setzt ihren Boom ungebremst fort. Der Umsatz mit Geräten, Flüssigkeiten und Zubehör wird in diesem Jahr schätzungsweise bei 810 Millionen Euro liegen und damit 40 Prozent höher sein als 2022. Und überall sind Rekorde zu vermelden. Nun hören wir mal ein bisschen weiter. Wie ist denn das eigentlich mit diesen Babes? Du hast es ja jetzt gerade schon gut beschrieben. Also vielleicht noch muss gesagt werden, man hat also ein Mundstück, meistens aus Kunststoff. Dort wird es eingefüllt. Das ist auch batteriebetrieben. Und dann nuckelt man daran. Ich finde es ja im Ganzen völlig unästhetisch und deswegen würde ich es schon nicht tun. Ich bin, du weißt es ja, Erotiker.
Das weiß ich ja.
Ein erotisches Beiwerk. Die Zigarette kann man sowieso danach, aber nein, die Zigarette als solches, wir kennen es aus den Hollywood-Filmen von einst, ist ja etwas, womit erotisch gespielt werden kann.
Es wird ja erstaunlich häufig auch auf der Bühne geraucht. Also dieser eine Zug, der kurz symbolisch gezeigt wird.
Das ist mit so einem Nuckel-Ding nicht möglich. Du hast jetzt gerade schon gesagt, ja man sehnt sich so ein bisschen nach was Süßem den ganzen Tag, aber bitte etwas, was nicht dick macht. Damit hast du es glaube ich schon gut beschrieben. Ich würde aber auch sagen, E-Zigaretten sind die Schnuller für Erwachsene.
Ja, wir sollten es auf jeden Fall diffamieren.
Dennoch habe jeder Dritte zwischen 14 und 17 im vergangenen Jahr schon E-Zigaretten konsumiert, so die Deutsche Gesellschaft für Pneumologie und Beatmungsmedizin. Ärzte befürchten, dass E-Zigaretten eine neue Generation an Nikotin heranführen.
Nikotin ist eigentlich bitter und der bittere Geschmack wird damit komplett untergraben. Das heißt, ich habe nicht den Eindruck, nicht das Gefühl, dass ich etwas Giftiges inhaliere und damit werden insbesondere Kinder und Jugendliche gelockt und mit unter zu langfristigen Kunden.
In Deutschland werde zu häufig an junge Menschen verkauft, so Experten.
Man kann vielleicht sagen, wir sind in einem großen Feldversuch. Wir lassen als Gesellschaft Kinder und Jugendliche diesen Inhalationsvorgang machen, um später herauszukriegen, wie schädlich das ist. Das ist im Prinzip ein Unding.
Man macht da einen großen Test. Schauen wir mal, was passiert. Wahnsinn, oder?
Ich denke mir halt, du hast jetzt von der Erotik-Schiene, ich meine so allgemein, den meisten geht es ja um die Ästhetik.
Und die ist ja nicht gegeben.
Also ich würde jetzt sagen, eine Cocktail-Party der Gespräche wegen, was man denn in der Hand hat, ist egal. Also nimmt man halt einen Cocktail. Cocktail hat Alkohol. Könnte man sich das alles auch genauso ohne Alkohol vorstellen? Ja, es ist nicht so kompliziert. Geht durchaus. Bei diesen Zigaretten kann man nicht einfach die Leute gut duftendes Zeug einatmen lassen, das sich kurz auf ihren Gaumen legt, ohne dass da noch Nikotin dabei sein muss. Ich glaube, die meisten Leute, denen ist das mit dem Nikotin eigentlich egal. Ja, die kann man auch noch mal in so eine Sucht reinbringen, aber nur weil Zigaretten damals Nikotin hatten und so. Man kann jetzt auch so Cuts eigentlich mal machen in der Entwicklung und sagen, nukel doch einfach an Sachen, die dann auch so ein bisschen dampfen und rauchen, aber es ist jetzt nicht mehr Nikotin und auch nicht der ganze andere Kram und überhaupt. Müsste doch irgendwie gehen.
Die Sache ist ja auch die Permanenz, mit der das getan wird. Ich habe mit einem Bekannten gesprochen, der jetzt auch angefangen hat zu vapen, der raucht gelegentlich noch eine Zigarette. Also standen wir draußen, rauchten eine Zigarette. Dann gingen wir durch die Stadt. Ich hatte ja diese eine Zigarette dann geraucht, dann war das für mich gut. Er ging fortwährend neben mir her und vapte.
Das hört gar nicht auf.
Der hört ja gar nicht auf. Das heißt, das kann ja auf Dauer auch nicht, weiß ich nicht, sinnvoll sein, wenn wir jetzt eine Gesellschaft sind, die die ganze Zeit etwas nuckelt. Also ich will es jetzt nicht gleich Leuten verbieten. Dafür mache ich ja auch selbst Dinge wie Zigaretten rauchen, die nicht gut sind und will jetzt aber auch nicht grundsätzlich Verbot bekommen. Ich finde nur, diese Dosierung, die man da vornehmen kann, also dass man einfach so permanent wie an so einem Tropf fängt, das finde ich sehr erstaunlich. Und finde ich, kann eigentlich gut zusammengebracht werden mit einem anderen Gerät, das wir immer mit uns schleppen, nämlich dem Smartphone. Also ich würde sagen, dieses ständige noch mal schauen, ob da was ist, noch mal was aufrufen, gucken, wer hat bei Tinder geschrieben. Und dieses konstante Vapen ist eigentlich etwas, was sehr ähnlich ist und was auch mit Sucht ja beides zu tun hat. Wir hören mal, was eigentlich mit der Werbung los ist. Denn eigentlich kann es ja keine Tabak-Werbung im Fernsehen zum Beispiel geben. Zapp ist dem nachgegangen.
Wir haben einen Hinweis bekommen. Die Tabakindustrie mache trotz Verbot möglicherweise weiterhin Werbung. Online und in Magazinen. Und das ohne es als Werbung zu kennzeichnen. Wir fangen an zu recherchieren, wühlen uns durch diverse Magazine, Zeitschriften und das Internet. Zum Thema Rauchen und wie man damit aufhört, finden wir viele Artikel. Etwa in Zeitschriften wie Echo der Frau, der Hör zu, der Fernsehzeitung TV Digital oder auch auf der Nachrichtenseite Wiesbaden lebt. Dabei fällt eines schnell auf. Zigaretten werden kaum mehr thematisiert. Anders als Rauchalternativen. Besonders oft erwähnt der Icos von Philip Morris.
Philip Morris hat schon vor vielen Jahren Interviews gegeben, in denen es hieß, wir kämpfen nun gegen die Zigarette. Und man dachte, was ist da los? Wir hören mal rein.
Nachdem der Tabakkonzern Philip Morris jahrzehntelang Milliarden mit dem Verkauf von Zigaretten gemacht hat, propagiert das Unternehmen seit einigen Jahren eine neue Strategie. Die Alternative heißt Icos. Ein Tabakerhitzer, der von Philip Morris entwickelt wurde. Vermarktet als weniger schädliche Alternative zur Zigarette. Clean und smart. Statt wilder Westen und Cowboy-Romantik gibt es zu Icos wissenschaftliche Studien und Erklärvideos. Das cleane Design erinnert an Technik von Apple und passt in die moderne Produktwelt.
Mich stört ja gar nicht so sehr jetzt, dass man herausgefunden hat, dass diese E-Zigaretten auch schlecht sind für die Gesundheit, sondern ich würde vielleicht einen Schritt weiter gehen und sagen, Genüsse haben auch eine Gefahr und sind deshalb auch interessant. Und deshalb muss man sie wohl dosieren. Und das Versprechen aber jetzt dieser Vapes und all der anderen Geräte, die es jetzt da gibt, ist, du kannst konstant genießen, aber ohne irgendein Risiko. Wenn es stimmen würde, wäre es natürlich mega. Ja, aber das ist ja eigentlich das neue Ding unseres Kapitalismus, dass wir sagen, du musst dich nicht mehr selbst zügeln, also musst nicht mehr selbst dich für einen Genuss oder gegen einen entscheiden. Nimm einfach Osempic, dann wird das erledigt.
Aber du musst ja die dichotomie nicht nur seriell, also du darfst ab und zu genießen und dann aber lange nicht, sondern du kannst ja auch das Vergnügen zu unvergnüglichen Sachen. Also Arbeit ist ungemütlich, aber jetzt, wenn du in der Bibliothek sitzt und dich auf deinen Staatsexamen vorbereitest, kannst du dabei wappen.
Ich glaube, in Bibliotheken ist das nicht gestattet, aber da wird es dann wirklich so eine Droge, um zu funktionieren. Und das ist nicht mehr dieses, wie heißt das Goethe-Wort, Tagesarbeit, Abendsgäste, saure Wochen, frohe Feste, sondern man will sehen, dass man die sauren Wochen irgendwie so noch angenehm sich bereit, dass man nicht völlig daran zugrunde geht. Und deswegen glaube ich, ist dieses Wappen kein Zeichen dafür, dass man es mit einer hedonistischen Gesellschaft zu tun hat, sondern eher mit einer Gesellschaft, die funktionieren muss, die sich auch nicht erlauben kann, rauszugehen, dort zu rauchen, irgendetwas zu machen, was nicht so ganz richtig ist, sondern es ist so eine, die einem erlaubt zu arbeiten, zu funktionieren und auch noch ein bisschen zu wappen. Wir hören mal noch weiter zu diesem Gerät iCos.
95 Prozent weniger Schadstoffe soll die iCos im Vergleich zu einer Zigarette enthalten, so der Werbeclaim von Philip Morris. Was ist da dran? Am Deutschen Krebsforschungszentrum in Heidelberg forscht Dr. Katrin Schaller zum Tabakkonsum und dessen Folgen. Was sagt sie zu den Werbeversprechen?
Es ist so, dass einige Schadstoffe tatsächlich deutlich reduziert sind. Andere sind wesentlich weniger stark reduziert. Und es gibt Substanzen im Aerosol von Tabakerhitzern, die gibt es in Tabak auch überhaupt nicht. Also es gibt auch neue Substanzen, von denen man noch gar nicht weiß, was die im Körper anrichten. Und diese Erklärung 95 Prozent weniger Schadstoffe soll natürlich auch suggerieren, dass es 95 Prozent weniger schädlich sei. Und diesen Schluss kann man nicht ziehen.
CNBC hat sich mit dem Thema auch beschäftigt und zeigt mal ein bisschen, wie hoch die Verbreitung ist.
Inzwischen ist die Zahl der Smokers Jahr für Jahr verlaufen und hat in 2022 auf 12,9 Prozent der Bevölkerung gestiegen, die höchste, seit die Rekorde begonnen sind, in 2011. Das britische und amerikanische Tabak hat von seinen Vaporkomplikationen in 2023 auf 40,3 Prozent erhöht, als in 2022. Es ist also nicht überraschend, dass große Tabakos an die Vapen geflogen sind. Aber der große Wachstum im legalen Vapenmarkt ist nur ein Teil dieser Geschichte. In den letzten zehn Jahren haben illegale Vapen große Anzahlungen Geld generiert. Einer von neun Kindern hat im März 2023 mit Vapen experimentiert, das ist von einem von 13 Jahren in dem selben Monat im Jahr 2022. So ist eine fastentwicklende Industrie sowohl legal als auch auf dem schwarzen Markt. Es sieht so aus, als würde Vapen hier bleiben.
Die Verbreitung ist groß, auch medial. Die BBC hat sich dem Thema angenommen.
Er hat einige davon konfiskiert. Wir haben eine Batch von ihnen in ein Laborat in Liverpool, um zu schauen, was in ihnen war. Wir wissen von Nikotin, und das ist adjektiv. Also 2,4x die gewünschte Sicherheitspositionslevel, 9,6x die Nikel, 6,6x die Chromium. Das ist aufgrund der Sicherheitslevels in der Pharmaceutical-Industrie. Und dann ein anderes Set von Konstituanten, sogenannte Carbonils, die in chemischen Komponenten wie Formaldehyd verbreiten. Und in einigen Fällen waren sie über dem Niveau, den du in Zigaretten findest.
Wie kann es sein, dass meine Zigaretten stark reglementiert sind? Es gab ja früher sehr viel mehr Marken und dann hat man ab einer gewissen Nikotinmenge gesagt, die dürfen jetzt nicht mehr in Deutschland verkauft werden. Wie kann es sein, dass man hier eine solche Wild-West-Stimmung noch hat?
Vor allem Nickel, überall wird gewarnt, kaufst du Schmuck, steht dann da, wie wenig Nickel da drin ist und so und da ist es einfach eine Zigarette.
Da inhaliert man es, ja.
Also in meiner Lunge habe ich nichts dagegen, aber auf der Haut, nee.
Circa 90% der Zahlen stimmen, der E-Zigaretten, der Vape-Angebote werden in China produziert, also diese kleinen Geräte. Wir hören jetzt mal, wie das so in China gehandhabt wird. Hier ein ZDF-Bericht.
In Deutschland sind sie der absolute Hype. In China, wo sie millionenfach hergestellt werden, sind sie verboten. Vapes, E-Zigaretten mit Fruchtgeschmack. In Deutschland machen sie seit zwei Jahren nicht nur Erwachsene süchtig.
Ich sehe immer wieder in den Straßen überall, dass Kinder, 12-Jährige, 10-Jährige, sogar unter 10-Jährige schon da stehen mit dem Vapes und rauchen.
Nur in China selbst wollen die Behörden die Frucht-Vapes nicht in den Läden sehen, aus Jugendschutzgründen.
Die Regierung hat den Verkauf verboten, wegen des Fruchtgeschmacks, denn der verführt viele Nichtraucher.
Dazu kommen kistenweise geschmuggelte illegale Vapes aus China und Südostasien. Der deutsche Zoll hat bereits Hunderttausende sichergestellt. Doch die Bundespolitik scheint bislang hilflos.
Und wir hören weiter. Wie ist das mit diesen verbotenen China?
Ganz anderes Bild in China, dort, wo mehr als 90% aller E-Zigaretten weltweit hergestellt werden. In den Kirsten der Volksrepublik dürfen nur E-Zigaretten mit Tabakgeschmack verkauft werden. Vapes mit Fruchtaroma sind seit zwei Jahren verboten. Damals war der größte Teil der Käufer Kinder und junge Leute, Studierende. Deshalb hat die Regierung den Verkauf verboten, wegen des Fruchtgeschmacks. Denn der verführt viele Nichtraucher.
Du hast ja hier schon mehrmals über die Zuckersucht gesprochen. Und wie Cem Özdemir mal ganz kurz versucht hat, dagegen anzukämpfen. Und dann hat man das alles sofort wieder ankassiert.
Das haben zuletzt die Nazis gemacht, gegen Zucker zu kämpfen. Herr Özdemir, was machen sie da?
So etwa. Und jetzt hat man hier noch mal so ein anderes Zuckerangebot geschaffen, in dem man einfach sagt, das schmeckt ganz süß, nimm es doch.
Ja, aber ich meine, die verordnen ihren Kindern einfach Osempick. Kein TikTok, wie wir es kennen. Und keine Vapes.
Charité freut sich.
Hier ist einfach alles.
Die Charité freut sich nicht.
Die Charité in Berlin schlägt Alarm. Zitat, seit 2021 hat sich der Anteil der Rauchenden 14- bis 17-Jährigen fast verdoppelt. Und rund jedes vierte Schulkind hat schon einmal Erfahrungen mit E-Zigaretten gemacht. Heißt, bei uns in Deutschland kommen Kinder viel zu leicht an Vapes.
Jetzt hören wir mal den Pressesprecher von Elfbar. Das ist eines dieser chinesischen Produkte.
Wir machen uns auf Spurensuche im Vape Valley der Volksrepublik, Shenzhen. Die chinesischen Fruchtvape-Firmen produzieren hier rein fürs Ausland, das ist erlaubt. Und die chinesische Staatsführung hat es ihnen besonders einfach gemacht. Es gibt eine White List der Behörden. Wer auf dieser Liste steht, dessen E-Zigaretten kommen mit weniger Kontrollen durch den chinesischen Zoll. Auf Anfrage bestätigt uns Elfbar, Marktführer in Deutschland, auf dieser Liste zu stehen. Als Qualitätsunternehmen. Auf die Frage, warum Elfbar trotz Verbot im eigenen Land millionenfach Fruchtflavour-Vapes nach Deutschland exportiert, sieht man sich nicht in der Verantwortung. Wir glauben nicht, dass die Aromen Kinder anziehen. Auch erwachsene Kunden, vor allem die, die versuchen, mit dem Rauchen aufzuhören, brauchen die Geschmacksrichtungen.
Ja, an seiner Stelle würde ich dasselbe sagen. Und das ist aber dann einfach eine Frage, ob man diese Importe zulässt. Und das ist nicht das Problem von Elfbar, sondern das ist ein Problem von Deutschland oder der EU. Wir hören mal weiter.
In jeder Einweg-E-Zigarette ist eine Lithium-Ionen-Batterie verbaut, die nach dem Dampfen mit der E-Zigarette weggeschmissen wird. Ziemlich mies für die Umwelt. Einweg-Vapes senken die Schwelle für Raucher auf ihrem Weg, mit den Zigaretten aufzuhören. Man kann sie nicht einfach verbieten. Man muss erkennen, dass es dafür einen Bedarf gibt. In Deutschland gehen jeden Monat rund 5 Millionen Einweg-Vapes über die Ladentheke, schätzt der Branchenverband Bündnis für tabakfreien Genuss. Eine Recycling-Pflicht gibt es nicht. Die meisten Tankstellen und Kiosk bieten auch keine Sammelstellen an.
Das ist alles ganz schlecht.
Ist Wahnsinn, oder?
Gibt es in China eigentlich so ein Büro, wo die so die Zerstörung der Welt organisieren?
Ja, das ist vielleicht die neue Soft-Power-Politik. Ich mein, wir hatten ja schon diesen Dialog zwischen Biden und Xi, dass sie beide sich darüber freuten, dass man übereingekommen ist, dass man jetzt nicht mehr die Menschen abhängig macht von diesen neuen Drogen, diese Opiate sind das. Und jetzt hat man natürlich auf dem Level nicht dasselbe. Aber was man generell sehen kann, man kann also Menschen heute wieder in neuer Art und Weise abhängig machen, beziehungsweise diese ganzen extremen Nichtraucher-Schutzgesetze. Und ich sage jetzt hier extrem, weil ich es bei manchen Dingen wirklich ein bisschen albern fand und finde. Also wo man sagen kann, hier sind jetzt Erwachsene unter sich und die können auch Dinge entscheiden. Aber das hat nicht dazu geführt, dass einfach die Sucht aufhört, sondern die Sucht verlagert sich. Und jetzt kann ich natürlich auch wieder Dinge hier verbieten. Und manche Regeln sind wohl dringend nötig. Aber man muss ja auch hier immer fragen, warum setzt sich so etwas gerade so durch? Wir wissen, dass gerade junge Leute unter sehr viel Stress leiden, Mental Health und all das. Greift man dann eher zu einem Ersatz, wenn man das andere nicht bekommt? Also, sind diese Phänomene, die wir jetzt hier beobachten, natürlich politisch so lösbar, dass man jetzt Verbote ausspricht. Ich bin auch grundsätzlich nicht dagegen, einige Sachen dazu verbieten oder stärker zu reglementieren. Aber die Sache ist auch, dass natürlich erst ein gewisser Umstand, auch ein ökonomischer Umstand, dazu führen kann, dass man dies oder das macht. Jetzt will die EU auch da das strenger regeln. Sie will zum Beispiel jetzt, dass man diese Einwegprodukte weiterhin verkaufen kann, aber dass man den Akku rausnehmen kann und separiert dann entsorgen kann. Aber wer wird das schon tun, fragt man sich. Wir hören jetzt mal ganz kurz in eine Bundestagsdebatte ein. Wir springen also ein bisschen und könnten da mal gerade hören, was Hans-Jürgen Thies von der CDU-CSU sagt. Denn die Ampel hätte jetzt die Chance gehabt, viel stärker das zu regulieren.
Mit der vorliegenden Änderung des Tabakerzeugnisgesetzes wurde leider die Chance vertan, Einweg-E-Zigaretten zu verbieten. Der Bundesrat forderte bereits in seinem Beschluss vom 3. März 2023, dass die Bundesregierung sich für ein nationales und ein EU-weites Verbot von Einweg-E-Zigaretten einsetzen solle. Nun, dreieinhalb Monate sind vergangen und man hört und liest aus den Reihen der Bundesregierung in dieser Richtung überhaupt nichts. Dabei werden aktuell, meine Damen und Herren, in Deutschland jeden Monat mit deutlich steigender Tendenz circa drei Millionen Einweg-E-Zigaretten gekauft, geraucht und letztlich achtlos weggeworfen.
Wir hören ihn noch weiter.
Letztlich vertan wurde mit diesem Gesetzentwurf leider auch die Chance, den Rechtsstatus von Nikotin- und Tabakbeuteln, also von Snooze und von Pouches, zu klären. Snooze sind Tabakerzeugnisse zum Oralengebrauch. Sie sind daher in Deutschland verboten. Pouches sind tabakfreie Nikotinbeutel, die nach lebensmittelrechtlichen Vorschriften zu behandeln wären und damit eigentlich in Deutschland auch nicht gehandelt werden dürfen. Tatsache ist dennoch, dass beide Arten von Beuteln leider sehr leicht im Online-Handel zu erlangen sind und auch in manchen Tabakgeschäften leider erworben werden können.
Hast du von Snooze schon gehört? Ein Riesenphänomen, kommen wir gleich nochmal in einem Clip drauf. Jetzt können wir uns überlegen, in der Ampel, wie werden da so die Einzelnen eingestellt sein zu dem Thema? Oder wer könnte möglicherweise verhindert haben, ich weiß es natürlich nicht, aber wer könnte verhindert haben, dass es da Verschärfungen gibt? Nun, machen wir uns selbst ein Bild. Wir hören Gero Hocker von der FDP.
Der Ausstieg aus der Nikotinsucht, meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren, ist für viele allerdings nicht trivial und gelingt, trotz zahlreicher Anläufe vielen Menschen nicht ohne Weiteres. Deswegen glaube ich, dass wir gehalten sind, als Gesetzgeber Wege aufzuzeigen, die es ermöglichen, Menschen, die von der konventionellen Zigarette abhängig sind, Wege aufzuzeigen, die es ihnen ermöglichen, von den besonders gesundheitsschädlichen Folgen des Konsums von Zigaretten, nämlich Kohlenmonoxid, was beim Verbrennungsprozess freigesetzt wird, wegzukommen und ihnen andere Alternativen an die Hand zu geben. Das ist unsere Verantwortung, meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren, als Gesetzgeber. Ohnehin schon süchtigen Menschen wie Rauchern von konventionellen Zigaretten, sie auch noch der maximalen Gefahr bei der Befriedigung dieser Sucht auszusetzen, das kann und darf nicht der Weg dieses Parlamentes und auch nicht der Bundesregierung sein, meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren.
Das ist also Gesundheitsschutz, ja. Das ist eine Ausstiegsdroge, keine Einstiegsdroge, eine Ausstiegsdroge und wenn du jetzt die verbietest, dann führst du die Leute ja näher an die Zigaretten an.
Und ich sage es ausdrücklich, ich weiß, dass das etwas zugespitzt ist, aber niemand hier im Saal würde süchtigen, dass Methadon verweigern, weil das zweifellos mit Nebenwirkungen, die Einnahme zweifellos mit Nebenwirkungen verbunden ist. Und deswegen...
Also Methadon bekommen ja wirklich Leute, wo man sagt, die muss man irgendwie von der Heroinabhängigkeit losbekommen. Wir sprechen ja hier doch noch von was anderem.
Muss eben auch für alternative Möglichkeiten tatsächlich auch geworben werden. Deswegen müssen möglichst viele verschiedene Geschmacksrichtungen auch möglich sein, damit eben der Umstieg möglichst leicht gemacht wird. Und deswegen, und das ist das Zentrale, meine Damen und Herren, müssen wir tatsächlich solche Technologien auch aus der Illegalität in die Legalität herüberholen, gerade um die Abgabe tatsächlich auch regulatorisch erfassen zu können, um gerade tatsächlich dafür zu sorgen, dass nicht in irgendwelchen osteuropäischen Laboren Ingredienzen sozusagen zusammengepumpt werden und die Menschen sich noch viel größeren Gefahren aussetzen würden.
Technologieoffenheit. Man hält es nicht mehr aus. Ja, und die Sache ist, wir müssen dann so möglichst viele verschiedene Geschmacksrichtungen anbieten. Dann erst werden die konventionellen Raucher sagen, hm, das ist ja super, aber es kommen keine Neuen nach. Also um die, das wird ja nicht passieren. Es geht jetzt nur um so einen Ausstiegsdruck.
Die Leute weisen auch nach, wenn sie so tanke gehen, dass sie Raucher sind.
Und dann bekommen sie ihr Methadon, ja. Nun, wir springen jetzt noch ganz kurz zu einem SWR-Bericht. Nämlich nur fragt man sich ja, wie kann sich das so sehr verbreiten? Ich habe da mal so ein bisschen mehr Twitch-Streams angesehen. Da sitzen die ja alle und vapen. Und Hip-Hopper haben ja ihre eigenen Marken. Die verkaufen millionenfach diese Vapes. Also wir können eigentlich, ich finde es so interessant, dass diese ganzen Montana, Black, Zido und diese ganzen, also aus diesem ganzen Bereich Hip-Hop, Twitch-Stream, Glücksspiel, Universum, ja. Also diese ganzen schrecklichen Leute, so will ich sie jetzt mal nennen. Ich glaube, man sagt dann auch Real Talk bei Twitch, bevor man sowas dann anfängt zu sagen, wie ich das hier vorhabe. Diese Leute sitzen da und sind immens reich geworden, nicht durch Talent, sondern das Einzige, was ihnen geglückt ist, ist das, was immer wieder in der Menschheitsgeschichte passiert ist. Was kann man am besten tun, um an das Geld anderer Leute zu kommen? Man macht sie in irgendeiner Weise abhängig von Glücksspielen. Man füttert sie mit Eistee, man füttert sie mit schlechter Pizza und jetzt jubelt man ihnen noch Vapes unter. Dann kann man sich selbst immens daran bereichern und ist aber gleichzeitig bei diesen jungen Leuten auch noch so eine Art Hero- und Gallionsfigur.
Die Zahlen sind da unheimlich in die Höhe gegangen im Jahr 2023. Sie haben tatsächlich fast 38% der 14- bis 17-Jährigen angegeben, in dem Jahr schon mal eine E-Zigarette gedampft zu haben. Das sind wirklich bedenkliche Zahlen.
Wie kommt das? Liegt es daran, dass die Tabakindustrie andere Wege gefunden hat, außerhalb der Werbung an die Kinder und Jugendlichen ranzukommen?
Na, das ist schon vor allen Dingen auch die Werbung, die ja eigentlich verboten ist. Aber sie wird natürlich vor allen Dingen stark beworben in den sozialen Medien, in denen ja Jugendliche ständig unterwegs sind, eigentlich sozusagen den ganzen Tag. Dann gibt es viele Idole, viele Vorbilder, die eben für E-Zigaretten werben, auf TikTok, auf Instagram, sonst überall kann man die durchaus noch finden und natürlich auch an den Verkaufsorten. Also gehen sie mal in eine Tankstelle zum Beispiel, da sehen sie reinweise die buntesten Vapes, die man sich nur vorstellen kann.
Ja, extrem bunt. Das ist fast wie so ein kleines Teuceras, wenn du da reingehst. Nun ist das hier gar nicht das Einzige, was so verbreitet ist bei jungen Leuten. Anderes Phänomen hören wir jetzt hier beim Länderspiegel.
Überreste von Lachgas-Partys in der Kölner Innenstadt. Der Park am Kaiser Wilhelm Ring ist regelmäßig vollgemüllt mit benutzten Luftballons, leeren Kartuschen. Zu kaufen ist der kurze Kick am Kiosk um die Ecke, ohne Altersbeschränkungen, bunt, aromatisiert, in immer größeren Flaschen. Kaum ein Jugendlicher, der Lachgas nicht kennt.
Ja, in der Schule ist es eher so was Temporäres, was die Leute dann nehmen, was sie dann für einen kurzen Moment glücklich macht oder in dem Fall benommen. Aber sonst, nee, ich nehme es nicht, nein.
Ich kenne Leute, die das auch schon konsumiert haben. Man hört ja genug von genug Leuten, die da irgendwie negative Folgen mitnehmen. Für die paar Sekunden, die man da erlebt, finde ich völligen Schwachsinn.
Die mehr oder weniger spontanen Lachgas-Partys sind völlig legal. Das Gas wird in Ballons gefüllt und eingeatmet, verursachte Lachanfälle und einen kurzen Rausch.
Nach 30 Sekunden fühlst du dich wie der Pate von Frankfurt.
Ein zweifelhaftes Vergnügen, das Folgen haben kann.
Wenn man zu viel nimmt, könnte man ohnmächtig werden. Dann fällt man um. Die Gefahr ist, dass man mit dem Kopf gegen die Kante stößt und nicht mehr aufsteht danach.
In Wuppertal hat der Lachgastrend so stark zugenommen, dass die Stadt Ende April die Bundesregierung aufgefordert hat, das Rauschmittel als Droge im Jugendschutzgesetz aufzunehmen. Experten warnen schon länger vor neurologischen Schäden.
War dir das auch klar, dass das so ein Phänomen ist?
Ja, ich wusste, dass es riesig ist. Ich weiß, dass es in keinem anderen Land der Welt einfach so verfügbar ist. Ich habe auch schon private Sicherheitskamera-Aufnahmen gesehen, wo einfach Leute stehend umfallen. Und dann wirklich mit dem Kopf so knapp an der Kante vorbei.
Kommen wir noch zu einem letzten Clip. Snooze wurde eben schon erwähnt. Wir hören einen Beitrag von Bloomberg.
Das ist Morten. Er ist 20 Jahre alt und hat gerade ein paar frische Packs von Snus in einer Shop in zentraler Stockholm auf seinen Mittagessen gekauft. Das ist die niedrigste Zahl in Europa. Die Schwedischen Schmuckrate sind in den letzten 15 Jahren über halb so. 6% der Frauen. Aber ca. 15% der Bevölkerung benutzt Snus. Die Frauen benutzen die Nikotin-Pouchen, ein relativ neues Produkt, das vor weniger einer Dezade war. Sie denken an Snus, aber mit keinem Tobak. Ich bin in Nikoteket. Das ist eine Nikotin-Store. In einer Store wie dieser findet man eine ganze Menge Nikotin-Produkte, Vapen, Nikotin-Pouchen und traditionelle Snus.
Ja, es ist ein wunderschöner Laden, wo man auch sicherlich prima Parfum verkaufen könnte, aber es gibt dort alle Sorten an Zigarettenersatz. Nur Zigaretten gibt es nicht mehr dort zu kaufen. Es ist ein so großes Kautabak, so wie man das früher hatte. Kautabak wurde ja auch nicht gekaut die ganze Zeit, sondern den schob man sich dann da unter das Zahnfleisch quasi und dann wirkt das und gibt dann den Wirkstoff ab. Und das ist etwas, was so verbreitet ist, dass auch die Politiker dort Werbung für Snooze machen und damit kokettieren, dass sie alle Snooze nehmen. Es gab dazu einen sehr interessanten Artikel im Spiegel von Jan Petter. Der hat das mal aufgedreht, wie dieser schwedische Wahlkampf da verlaufen ist und wie eng das gekoppelt war mit Snooze. Was man, glaube ich, festhalten kann, ist, dass wir es mit einer Gesellschaft zu tun haben, die die wirkliche Rausch hafte im Sinne von ein Fest erleben, dass diese Gesellschaft eigentlich immer mehr ausstirbt. Also wirklich die Gesellschaft, die feiert. Die Gesellschaft, die genießt und sicherlich auch da den einen oder anderen Grenzübertritt wagt. Aber die quasi das Außeralltägliche im Fest und im Rausch sieht. Was hier eigentlich stattfindet, ist, Suchtstoffe in den Alltag zu integrieren, damit der Alltag und das Funktionieren im System weiterlaufen kann. Das heißt, es ist genau das Gegenteil. Es ist nicht, wenn wir sagen, wir nehmen den Salon auf und gehen danach noch in die Oper. Jetzt nur noch gedoppt.
Aber wir könnten das mit dem Salon auch verbinden. Wir sitzen hier, trinken Frankfurt Sauer und rauchen.
Das geht ja zum Beispiel nicht. Wenn ich jetzt wirklich diesen kleinen Rausch haben will, dann kann ich dann nicht arbeiten. Also ich kann nicht Cocktail trinken und Podcast machen. Aber das hier sind alles Produkte, die sagen, du kannst weiter hustlen und noch so ein bisschen deine Sucht befriedigen, damit es weitergeht. Also es ist genau das, was eigentlich gebraucht wird, damit die Leute weiterarbeiten. Eigentlich kann man es ein bisschen verbinden mit dem, was der Kaffee tat im 19. Jahrhundert. Es gibt ja Fälle, von denen auch Marx im Kapital berichtet, dass man Arbeiter, vor allem auch Arbeiterinnen, immer wieder mit Kaffee abgefüllt hat, damit die länger arbeiten können. Und wir gehen ein bisschen in diese Richtung gerade. Und dann gibt es, glaube ich, generell eine Industrie, die darauf aus ist, Sucht herzustellen. Und das ist dann einmal eine solche Industrie mit Vapes und Snooze und all dem. Und dann haben wir die große Smartphone-Industrie, will ich sie nennen. Und wir hatten mal diesen wunderbaren Text im Salon, wo es darum ging, ja, Kulturindustrie und Kunst, das hat man immer so als Differenz gedacht. Aber beides wird jetzt eigentlich geschluckt von einer süchtig machenden Industrie. Und das ist TikTok, sind all die anderen Apps.
Short Videos und Vapes.
Machen einen dann so nervös, dass man, um wieder runterzukommen, wahrscheinlich dann Kautabak braucht. Und in dieser Konstellation sind wir gerade, und hier würde ich das nochmal anschließen an dein Bildungsthema. Je mehr Menschen auf sich alleine gestellt sind und irgendwie sich durchwurschteln müssen, desto eher werden sie auch darauf zurückgreifen, auf irgendwelche Mittel, die ihnen dabei helfen, das Alltägliche zu bewältigen. Denn es sind Alltagsbewältigungs-Drogen. Es sind nicht die Drogen, die den rauschhaften Moment, an den man sich erinnert, kreieren, sondern es sind Drogen, die dafür sorgen, dass man funktioniert, dass man weiter arbeitsam ist und dass man in gewisser Weise auch brav ist.
Das stimmt, nicht zu unterschätzen. Nicht nur ordentlich arbeiten, sondern die Arbeit auch brav erledigen. Okay, Abschlussthema, die Boomer. Ich schleppe ja seit einer Weile hier Clips von Josef Hader mit mir. Wir kennen ihn. Hier ist so ein kurzer Kulturzeitbeitrag in typischer Form, nur damit man kurz versteht. Falls man ihn nicht kennt, vielleicht erkennt man ihn an der Stimmlage.
Scharfzüngig, selbstironisch.
So präsentiert sich Hader zuverlässig bei seinen Solos.
Scharfzüngig und selbstironisch. Oder auch, man könnte sagen, bei dem, was wir gleich hören, einfach mal ehrlich und direkt. Er hat jedenfalls ein Bühnenprogramm, wo er solo auf der Bühne sitzt und einen Boomer spielt.
Zufälle gibt es hier keine.
Dafür treffen sich ihre Pointen auch bei Hader und Eis.
Aber Vorsicht beim Lachen.
Was mich ein bisschen kränkt bei diesen Bettlern ist, ich geb ihnen oft was, ich geb ihnen gern was, dann geh ich weiter, erledig fünf Minuten was, komm wieder zurück, was passiert denn? Er bettelt dich sofort wieder an. Er kann sich nicht erinnern an dich. Das ist ein liebloser Umgang. Das mag ich auch nicht auf der Bühne stehen oder eins zu eins sagen, was ich denk. Erstens finde ich das urlangweilig, künstlerisch. Zweitens will ich gar nicht genau, da soll ich so ganz genau wissen, was ich denk, weil da lehnen sie sich zurück und denken, das ist ja ein zuverlässiger Kabarettist. Wir sind auch im Großen und Ganzen seiner Meinung. Das Publikum ist ja immer der selbe Meinung, wie der Kabarettist. Wenn es im Kabarett zu bequem wird, ist der Unterschied zum Bierzelt gar nicht mehr so weit, weil alle einer Meinung sind und sich gegenseitig vergewissern, dass eh alles passt.
So, er will also auf der Bühne sitzen, über Boomer reden, im Monolog, wie wir es eben auch schnitzweise gesehen haben. Und es soll nicht zu sehr bierzeltartig werden, weil wenn einfach nur alle dieselbe Meinung teilen und einer wird gefeiert, weil er sie besonders gut vorträgt, dann wäre das blöd. Jetzt hören wir Elke Heidenreich, wie sie in dieser 3-nach-9-oder-welcher-auch-immer-Talkshow im öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk sitzt und dort auch als recht ältere Frau über ihre Generation so spricht.
Heißt es ja, Alte sind nicht mehr interessant und leisten nichts mehr. Und auch dagegen schreibe ich an, wir sind schon sehr wohlwichtig. Und gerade meine Generation, unsere Generation, die ja angeblich jetzt an allem schuld ist, die ja von den Jungen sehr beschimpft wird, gerade unsere Generation hat nicht nur die 68er hervorgebracht, die verdruckste Moral befreit, dem § 175 Schwulenparagraph abgeschafft, 218 geknackt, wir haben Greenpeace gegründet, Amnesty International, Ärzte ohne Grenzen, die Grünen gegründet, das sollen die uns erst mal nachmachen, diese nächste Generation.
Wir waren gut.
Aber...
Gabriel hat schon mitgeschrieben.
To-do-List?
Nein, ich hab da ein großes Selbstbewusstsein, weil wir Alten sind jetzt angeblich an allem schuld. Wir haben ja die Entwertung der Welt, wie sie jetzt gerade ist, nicht ahnen können. Die Entwertung durch Pandemien, durch Kriege, durch Nationalismus, durch den Klimawandel. Wenn wir ein paar Mal nach Palermo in die Oper geflogen sind, haben wir nicht gewusst, dass das was mit Klimawandel zu tun hat. Das lernen wir ja jetzt. Aber ich finde, das, was meine Generation konnte, hat sie gemacht. Wir haben die Sache nicht so in die Scheiße gefahren. Und jetzt muss man sehen, wie man mit dem fertig wird, was jetzt gerade die Probleme sind. Wir hatten die Nazi-Eltern, ihr habt den Nationalismus.
So, also sehr viele Sachen, die sie so sagen.
Bei denen man ja auch zustimmen kann. Also das sind ja Errungenschaften. Die Frage ist natürlich immer, wir haben das ja schon häufiger thematisiert, sobald man anfängt von Generationen zu reden, kommt man in die Präduje, dass man Leute meint, die gar nicht gemeint sein können. Also andere 80-Jährige haben nichts mit Amnesty International oder sonst was zu tun.
Was ja jetzt bedeutet, sie sagt das ja aus Gründen, den Zeitgeist einfangend. Und der Anlass ist, wir werden ja hier aus dem Spiel genommen und für alles verantwortlich gemacht. Jetzt würde ich sagen, typischerweise sind diejenigen verantwortlich, die dann und dann gelebt haben, als Zeitgeist herrschte usw. Was eben auch bedeutet. Und deswegen auch dieser interessante Clip, den wir noch nie gespielt haben, als in Weimar dieses Museum eröffnet wurde über Bauhaus im Nationalsozialismus. Nein, nicht Bauhaus im Nationalsozialismus, sondern in Weimar gibt es jetzt ein Museum zur Zwangsarbeit. 20 Millionen Betroffene. Und wir hatten einen Betroffenen noch da, der sich heute dann vor den Fernsehkameras die Frage stellte, was wäre, wenn ich damals Hitler-Junge gewesen wäre und nicht Jude. Und dieses, ich nehme mich mal selber raus aus dem Bild und sehe das große Ganze. Da könnte man jetzt von der jungen Generation verlangen, einfach so eine Einsicht. Wenn ihr damals wir gewesen wär, hätte ihr dasselbe gemacht. Und dann hätten wir alle gesagt, ja, genau. Wir wären auch immer nach Palermo geflogen in die Oper. So mehrfach auch, ne? Da sieht man auch so ein bisschen, nee, vor 40 Jahren sind nicht Leute mehrfach in die Oper nach Palermo, sondern es gab schon viele Leute, die haben es ein bisschen übertrieben. Schicht, ja. So, was aber jetzt im Gegenzug dann wieder bedeutet, wenn man auf der einen Seite aufzählt, Ärzte ohne Grenzen, Amnesty International und so weiter und den Schwun-Paragrafen abgeschafft, und dafür reklamiert man eine Verantwortung. Das haben wir gemacht. Und dann kommen aber die negativen Sachen, die unausgesprochen im Raum stehen, weshalb sie ja diesen Debate-Prep hier, den sie gut gemacht hat, umsetzt und dann aber sagt, wir werden jetzt immer verantwortlich gemacht. Ja, du hast dich selber gerade verantwortlich gemacht für die positiven Sachen. Was ist jetzt mit den negativen Sachen?
Und dann würde man auch unterstellen, dass man um den Klimawandel schon ein bisschen früher als gestern wusste.
Ja, also die Nobelpreise, die jetzt vergeben wurden zum Thema Klimawandelforschung, sind alle in den 70ern erbracht worden.
Ich meine, sie erwähnt ja die Grünen. Die Grünen haben ja niemals in ihrem Programm stehen gehabt. Bitte fliegt oft in die Oper nach Palermo.
Worauf ich jetzt hinaus will, ist, es gibt Vergangenheit für uns nur relevant im Gegenwärtigen. Die Frage ist jetzt kulturell, politisch vor allem. Wie ziehen wir denn aus den Erfahrungen, die wir gemacht haben, Erwartungen an die Zukunft? Müssen wir jetzt etwas ändern? Und wir stellen ja fest, ja, wir müssen etwas ändern. Sonst würde Elke Heldenreich jetzt nicht sagen, bis jetzt war schon ganz gut oder wir wissen auch, dass es jetzt und so weiter, aber das muss jetzt die nächste Generation machen. Joseph Harder ist jetzt nicht als Bühnenrolle, sondern in der Sternstunde Philosophie, um dort aber dieselben Themen zu besprechen. Also ein Selbstgespräch des Boomers, vielleicht sogar mit einem Boomer, ich weiß gar nicht, wie alt der Ding ist, wir hören ihn gleich. Und er entscheidet sich für einen anderen Umgang mit, ich werde damit verantwortlich gemacht, ja, so verhalte ich mich auch dazu, wie sie hier verhalten wurde und verhalten wird. Das hören wir mal in zwei Abschnitten, weil ich finde, Joseph Harder macht das wirklich dafür, dass ich das Bühnenprogramm, ich habe ein paar ein bisschen mehr da gesehen als jetzt nur dieser eine Ausschnitt, das würde ich mir jetzt nicht angucken, weil da redet wirklich ein Boomer für die Boomer und es ist mir auch erstmal unklau, dass ironisch meint oder nicht, sondern da kommt so diese falsche Selbstgewissheit, wie von Elke Heidenreich, als Bühnenprogramm in Länge. Das ist aber ganz anders in dieser Sternstunde Philosophie, weshalb wir uns das in zwei Clips anhören.
Ich glaube, es gibt tatsächlich eine Sache, die sehr besonders ist und noch nie war, nämlich, dass die Leute, die 60 und 70 sind, die Bevölkerungsmehrheit stellen in einer Gesellschaft. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jemals in der Weltgeschichte schon mal passiert ist.
Was schonmal bedeutet, Demokratien entscheiden die Mehrheiten. Man kann jetzt nicht einfach sagen, die Jüngeren müssen es jetzt irgendwie besser machen.
Eine Generation, die ist so angetreten in den 60ern und 70ern, die wollten alles anders machen. Die haben gesagt, Regeln akzeptieren wir nicht. Das Althergebrachte.
Die 68er, wie man so sagt.
Und jetzt ist diese Generation, glaube ich, kann man sagen, hat so krachend versagt wie kaum eine andere. Man kann sich immer gut festmachen an dem Unterschied zwischen Helmut Schmidt oder Willy Brandt und Gerhard Schröder. Das beschreibt eigentlich, welche Art von Anständigkeit in der Generation vorher war. In Österreich gibt es auch Beispiele, die kennt hier niemand. Also unseren sozialdemokratischen ehemaligen Kanzler und Parteichef, der mit dem Siegner im Aufsichtsrat sitzt in diesem Konzern, der krachend runtergegangen ist, der Millionen kassiert. Also es hat diese Generation wirklich versagt. Das kann man, glaube ich, sagen. Aber sie hat unglaublich profitiert. Sie hat in diesem Erdteil wahnsinnig profitiert. Denn dann ging es richtig gut. Fast allen, nicht allen, ist klar. Und jetzt stehen sie sozusagen vor dem Tod in den nächsten 20 Jahren. Das betrifft mich ja auch. Und das Spannende ist jetzt, dass die ihre Deutungshoheit nicht abgeben wollen. Dass die nicht diese Rolle für sich annehmen wollen, die sie den alten Leuten in den 60er- und 70er-Jahren zugemutet haben. Da sind sie mit Glocken, Hosen und langen Haaren da gestanden, haben eine Sprache gesprochen, wo sie sich gefreut haben, dass die alten Leute das nicht verstehen, die durchsetzt waren mit irgendwelchen englischen Vokabeln. Und haben die alten Leute fertig gemacht, haben Universitätsprofessoren mit Megafonen angeschrien. Und jetzt sitzt die selbe Generation wehleidig in ihren Ohren und sagt, das darf man nicht mehr sagen. Und ich bin so arm, weil ich mit 75 jetzt bei der großen Fernsehshow abtreten muss. Das ist eine Generation, die hat nie Regeln beachtet und möchte Deutungsrohheit bis ins Grab. Und die unangenehme Wahrheit, glaube ich, ist, dass Donald Trump ein Kind dieser Zeit ist.
So, er kriegt jetzt die Nachfrage, ist denn gar nichts Positives übrig geblieben?
Es gab doch auch viele große Aufbrüche innerhalb dieser Zeit. Es gab eine ganze linke sozialdemokratische Aufbruch von der Neuen Linken mit Tony Blair, mit Bill Clinton, mit Gerhard Schröder. Das war doch ein riesen Aufbruchsversprechen. Und man würde ja nicht unbedingt sagen, dass die nichts bewirkt haben. Sie würden sagen, das war zwar ein wichtiger Schritt, aber in die falsche Richtung.
Was hat denn Gerhard Schröder, Clinton, was ist denn geblieben? Was war denn? Was haben die denn wirklich weitergebracht? Also ich will jetzt nicht streiten über Politiker. Aber es ist doch sonnenklar, dass vorher eine anständigere Politikergeneration war. Und jetzt eine, die sich bereichert. Früher der Bundeskanzler Sinovac, ein österreichischer Bundeskanzler. Den habe ich getroffen im Südburgenland, auf der Straße als kleiner Bauer. Da ist er hergekommen und hat von seiner Rente gelebt, in seinem kleinen Haus. Und jetzt sitzen die alle in Aufsichtsräten. Kann mir doch keiner einreden, dass das System sich nicht verschlechtert hat. Wir sollten doch nicht so tun, als wäre das alles selbstverständlich. Ist es so selbstverständlich, dass Politiker, die eine gute Rente bekommen, in die Industrie und in die Wirtschaft gehen und sich dort bereichern? Ist das so? Das war früher in Amerika. Und das ist kein System, das man so eins zu eins übernehmen sollte in der Demokratie. Weil die sind ein Beispiel, wie eine Demokratie sich nicht gut entwickelt.
In der Ansicht, wir haben mit der Debatte begonnen. Das sehen wir dann in 15 Jahren auch in Deutschland so.
Was er da über die Politik sagt, ist richtig. Und auch gerade, was er über die Leute sagt, die einfach damit berühmt wurden, dass sie Regeln brechen und die anderen von ihren Positionen vertreiben, sind jetzt genau diejenigen, die auf keinen Fall bereit sind, irgendetwas abzugeben. Das kann man auch gerade im Hochkulturbereich gut sehen. Ich würde aber auch immer sagen, die danachkommen sind dann auch wieder nicht besser. Also man hat ja so gewisse Me-Too-Wellen gehabt im hochkulturellen Bereich auch. Oder man hat sich zum Beispiel sehr abgearbeitet in Deutschland an den autoritären Theatermachern, die einfach sechs Wochen Probe machen und permanent schreien. Ja, kann man machen. Aber ich höre dann ja interessanterweise von den jungen Wilden, die so Mitte 30 sind und jetzt in diesem System sind, dass die sich natürlich genauso verhalten, sobald sie auf den Posten sind. Und wir sehen ja gerade auch an den Jungen, deswegen bin ich halt auch sehr gegen eine Chlorifizierung der Jungen. Wir haben ja jetzt Albrecht von Luke noch im Ohr. Für die, die den Salon nicht abonniert haben. Haben wir gecancelt. Und zwar lang und ausführlich in der Live-Show. Und er ist ja dann derjenige, der sagt, ja, die jungen Leute sollen einfach in die Politik gehen. Wir haben wahnsinnig viele junge Leute in der Politik. Und sie haben sogar auch Chancen bekommen. Sie haben nämlich wahnsinnig gute Listenplätze bekommen. Sodass wenn man dreieinhalb Semester Pädagogik studiert hat und man schon mal Kasperle Theater gespielt hat, jetzt Bundestagsmandat bekommen hat. Ich will das gar nicht abwertend sagen. Das klingt aber so. Vielleicht meine ich es auch so. Aber von diesen jedenfalls könnte man ja dann noch erwarten, dass sie wenigstens aus Dankbarkeit über dieses große Glück sich so verhalten, wie junge Leute sich verhalten könnten, wenn sie die Anliegen ihrer jungen Altersgenossen ernst nehmen. Tun sie aber nicht. Insofern, ich will mich auf niemanden mehr verlassen.
Du sagst es polemisch, aber meinst du es voll Herzen, wie Albrecht von Lucke sagte? Okay, dann ist uns weil du die Cancel Culture, wir haben ja Albrecht von Lucke gecancelt. Joseph Harder sagt hier auch was zum Thema Cancel Culture. Es ist eine, finde ich, sehr gute Einschätzung.
Meiner Meinung nach, man kann alles machen in der Satire, aber man muss ein bisschen genauer sein und klüger sich überlegen, wo man was platziert. Und wie man, weil ohne Provokation, ohne Ambivalenz macht es ja keinen Spaß.
Und Sie glauben, diese ganze Rede von den neuen Grenzen des Humors, das ist einfach Quatsch und letztlich eine handwerkliche Frage?
Ich glaube, es gilt dieser alte Satz, der auch von Karl Kraus sein könnte, aber in Wirklichkeit von Nesteroy ist, Witze, die der Zenzur versteht, sind eh schlecht. Das heißt, wer so banal seine Witze macht, dass er nach den Regeln der Woknes irgendwie nicht ganz entspricht, der ist einfach zu dumm, dass er das gescheit macht.
Aber damit haben doch viele Ihrer Kollegen offenbar Probleme.
Also wenn wir Sachen canceln, dann nur, weil sie zu dumm sind, dann gehören sie aussortiert.
Wir vertagen uns auf den Salon, weisen nochmal darauf hin. Wir werden uns mit den Gebrüdern Semmsrott auseinandersetzen. Arne Semmsrott hat das Buch Machtübernahme geschrieben. Was passiert, wenn Rechtsextremisten regieren? Eine Anleitung zum Widerstand. Wir sind sehr gespannt darauf. Er ist ja von Frag den Staat.
Ja, sehr gute Aufgabe. Wir gehen da nochmal drauf ein.
Einblicke in die institutionellen und politischen Zusammenhänge. Sein Bruder hat die Praxis versucht im Europaparlament Nico Semmsrott. Sein Buch Brüssel sehen und sterben lesen wir auch. Außerdem werde ich noch ein Buch vorstellen des Philosophen Gunnar Hindrichs. Der hat ein Buch geschrieben, das heißt Abseits des Krieges und versucht eine philosophische Antwort darauf zu geben, wie wir uns jetzt eigentlich dazu verhalten, dass Krieg stattfindet, dass Aufrüstung stattfindet, dass die Geopolitik komplizierter wird. Wir versuchen also eine philosophische Antwort darauf zu finden. Alles andere will ich mir noch offen lassen.
Gut, ich bringe das Buch von Christian Drosten mit. Er hat sich mit Hilfe von Georg Masculo, der ihm schon sehr kritische Fragen stellt, aber eben auch kritisch zum Thema eingestellt ist. Sachen erzählen lassen zur Corona-Pandemie, insbesondere zum Verhältnis Sachentscheidung. Wie war das jetzt mit den Schulschließungen? Dann Politiker. Sind die eigentlich alle doof? Oder gibt es noch einen, wo man, wenn man einmal im politischen Kontext drin ist, Bevölkerung und, den Teil habe ich noch nicht gelesen, Medien.
Ich bin sehr gespannt.
Also bisher sehr gute Lektüre. Da stecken ein paar interessante Sachen drin. Außerdem ist unser Hörer Klaus Badenhagen Taiwanese, zumindest im Kopfe. Er lebt auf Taiwan und hat jetzt ein Buch geschrieben, Die wichtigste Insel der Welt, was Sie wissen müssen, um Taiwan zu verstehen. Da wir alle Taiwan verstehen müssen. Und mich vor allem interessiert, wie wäre ihm jetzt so die politischen Konnotationen, sofern sie drinstecken, ich nehme mal an. Vorkommen schauen wir da rein, denn er ist ja als Weltreporter oder wie diese Orga da heißt, auch ein großer Verfechter, immer mal wieder Fokus auf Taiwan zu legen. Im Sinne der großen geopolitischen Gemengelage, die hier zu diskutieren ist.
Gut.
Und dann mal gucken.
Man findet uns im Salon. Und wir sagen noch mal ganz kurz, wie man da reinkommt, Stefan.
Wir gehen auf neuezwanziger.de. Ein Podcast, der eine Website hat. Jeder Podcast braucht eine Website. Man ist nicht nur bei Spotify und Apple und so, sondern man hat eine Website, liebe Podcaster. Und da ist ein goldner Button, da steht Salon drauf. Klickt man einfach. Und schickt uns in dieser Liste unten ist die E-Mail. Eine E-Mail, die geht automatisch an uns beide zu den diskutierten Themen. Familienwahlrecht vor allem.
Ja, wir sind gespannt. Wer das nicht über Static tun will, kann auch uns über Patreon abonnieren. Oder für wen das praktischer ist, der mit dem iPhone unterwegs ist, kann das auch für 50 Cent mehr dann über den Euro sogar mehr. Apple will ja doch ein bisschen mehr von uns haben. Er kann das also auch darüber sehr praktisch hören und auch sehr viel danach hören. Wir verweisen nochmal auf diesen Live-Salon, in dem wir uns nicht nur mit Albrecht von Lucke auseinandergesetzt haben, sondern wir sprechen da auch über...
Es kristallisieren, wir finden neue Grundbegriffe für politische Diskussionen, damit sie besser gelingen.
Und wir deuten an, dass Emotionen doch eine Relevanz haben. Aber wir werden dieses Emotionenthema noch mal größer...
Wir werden es tief und scharf werden. Wir haben es in Salon schon so ein bisschen angesprochen mit Fragen, die wir uns für uns stellen oder gemeinsam mal beantworten.
Und wir verraten, wie man reich wird. Wir haben uns nämlich mit dem passiven Einkommen auseinandergesetzt. Wir können aber schon mal spoilern, also um reich zu werden, hilft es, schon reich zu sein. So viel können wir festhalten. Dann sehen wir uns nächste Woche im Salon.
Bis dann.